foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
it is the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube pregame show presented by
YouTube TV we're spending time in the
juice box down in Houston Texas the
Houston Astros and the Kansas City
Royals and a little rubber match of this
three-game series that concludes on this
Wednesday it is Wednesday right it is
Wednesday I don't know how the players
feel too like what day of the week it's
August is it October yet no that's the
mayor Sean Casey I'm Stephen Nelson case
I did not get the memo for business I
got the memo for looking just awesome
okay that's what I that's what I want to
be wearing but somehow I jumped into
this because I did a little MLB Central
earlier that's what uh that's right you
look you look great I look like a
schmuck what did game two of this series
look like let's show you the highlights
from Tuesday night
here's a let Miss Diaz
on the ground Lopez a diving stop and
the throw gets by the first finish to no
Hearne two runs will score that ball
hits our center field Taylor on the Move
he'll watch this one Bounce Off the Wall
RBI double Carlos Correa it is four to
nothing swinging a Miss that's a good
change up one of his finest outings of
the year he is going to get a nice hand
when he heads to The Dugout
he will get some Rookie of the Year
consideration Luis Garcia that is so the
Astros shut out the Royals for nothing
and even up that series Houston's now
won four the last six in case they get a
huge boost today with the return of Alex
bregman and it's been a minute since
we've seen him play and I think
everybody who watches Astros baseball is
jacked up about his return well this
guy's game changing you know he's he's a
superstar one of the best players in the
game and you put him in the mix right
now when you're on the postseason push
this is huge couldn't be better timing
for the Astros to get Alex bregman back
he brings so much to the table I think
the third baseman since uh that replaced
him since he's been out really haven't
given the production the Astros need
listen when you have bregman in the
lineup top to bottom I mean it just it
makes everybody better and you're
talking about Korea you're talking about
Altuve Brantley guriel they're already
loaded bregman now in the mix makes them
so much more dangerous letting off those
names and it's like Dusty Baker did not
need a lot of help filling out the
lineup card but now he's got braveman
back again he's missed 59 games with
that left quad strain now Houston went
35-24 since he went on the IL in Houston
20 and up is also 35 and 24 when bregman
appears in a game this season but you
talked about that Hot Corner being
relatively cold now led Miss Diaz since
he came off the aisle has done quite
well but 93 weighted runs create a Plus
without bregman and so he figures to be
a massive boost in that department
massive boost massive listen he plays a
great Third Base yeah but energy wise
man when you're right when you're not on
the when you're hurt it it you don't
bring the same energy when you're back
in the lineup bregman's that energy guy
he's like he's one swing away from
changing the game he's One play away
from I mean like he's lifting guys up
and the energy is different when you've
got bregman that's healthy as opposed to
Breaking that's on the DL and apparently
he's bringing back a new look with him
he's got a beard now
[Applause]
I'm a baseball player uh and he said
he's the best this is the best he's felt
in his career so again we're then we're
if that if this is the best we're gonna
get about to break if we haven't seen
anything yet then it's going to be a
show on the other side of this matchup
case
Casey is a team that I think on paper
you would be like oh this is an Astros
dub but against the top-notch
competition against current first place
teams Kansas City is not a team that
folks should be sleeping on no they play
well and against the Astros too yeah you
know what topped up but they have guys
that can be I mean you look at Sal Perez
33 bombs this guy's one of the best
biggest bats in the game right now I
mean you know look at this right here
wow don't sleep and you know what listen
to this Nelly I played on a lot of teams
that were out of it late August into
September these are their playoff games
you don't think the Royals want to
factor in on what teams get in what
teams don't I've been there before these
are they're this is their postseason
game so the Royals are looking at this
like hey let's get let's get this series
win let's find a way to get in Houston
come in slap these guys around a little
bit and move on so these guys got they
listen they can pitch it you know uh
when they got some good arms and when
they when they throw well they could
shut anybody down but they got some bats
in that lineup especially South Prez in
the middle of there and Ben intended
who's been hot lately that can do some
damage you know look I'm a fan of the
White Sox so I watched this division a
lot and this year we hear a lot of the
comedy AL Central this year because the
rest of the division outside of the
White Sox has been on The Struggle Bus
for good points but if you look beyond
the surface level records and you look
at what Casey's doing like we did what
they're doing against first place teams
what AJ hinch and the tigers are doing
changing the culture there in Detroit
this division is going to be a problem
yes in the next few years and I think
Casey they're just trying to take that
next step develop as an organization
developmentally now for the starting
pitching matchup we have Mike Miner for
the Royals and the Lance McCullers
Junior for the Astros now there's some
history yeah that's because Junior and
the Kansas City Royals he actually made
his playoff debut against KC back in
2015. game four Houston has a chance to
close out the series against the Royals
and he pitched quite well the bullpen
did not hold on to it we know what
happened as the rose came back and won
that game won the series and then won
the whole darn thing and we've seen
Lance McCullers Jr kind of develop into
the postseason pitcher since then yeah
part of that game seven in 2017 but this
is what he did back in 2015. what do you
expect to see from him today case you
know he's only gotten better since 2015
a young Lance McCullers you know throws
a lot of breaking balls a lot of speed
pitches but you know this guy's a
veteran now it's it's so funny when you
look back you know from what he was back
then to what he is now he's got a lot of
different pictures Sinker slider that
knuckle curve change up cutter listen he
throws he throws them all but he throws
a lot of breaking balls and I think
that's the big thing about McCullers
like you can't sit on the fastball with
this guy he will get you off balance
he's got a great 12-6 breaking ball too
that that has some bite that gets
hitters off that fastball so it'll be
interesting to see how my colors matches
up today against the Royals and one
thing that's different about Lance
mccormless Jr now compared to then the
lettuce he's Let It Grow since then and
he looks spectacular yours as well okay
so the salt and pepper yeah but it's not
yeah I got the salt and pepper he has
like the nice fluff I'm with you dude so
you talk about somebody on the mound now
let's go back into your home okay you're
a career 300 hitter in their case so
teach the folks watching the YouTube
pregame show how to break out of a slump
like Yuli Grill well Yuli girl yeah man
you know I tell you what in his last
five games he's really right around 500
doing well but before that kind of got
into a you know a little bit of you know
this is what happens when you start
struggling you get out of this Strike
Zone you're just off the baseball a
little bit timing's a little bit off
when I see gurio just kind of getting
jammed getting outside the Zone it
happens though in in a period you know I
think he was one for 20 in the six games
prior to him getting hot and I think
when you think girl man this guy right
here when he's on that all speed pitches
he gets that pitch down in hater middle
end this is what he does so good he has
such great hands Nelly he really does
man this guy is so good because he's a
Line to Line guy now he's going against
Mike Minor today and he's got some
history against this guy you know what
if minor makes mistakes to Gary L today
he has made him pay in the past and I
minor knows that that he's got to keep
the ball down you see those three
pictures right there all out over the
plate and up curiel right now hitting
317 leading the Al and hitting man this
guy is having a great season look at
this though six games before his last
five he was one for 23 10 for 20 with
some damage over 1300 Ops it's just
what's so funny is
you go up and down the line we're
talking about bregman yeah we talk about
Brantley Gary on Brantley are one and
two in the AL batting race right so
these guys are loaded and Gary L
sometimes gets overlooked don't overlook
the sky man no especially against Mike
Minor this could be the game changer bat
in this game today there are no holes no
breaks when facing this Houston Astros
lineup and Kyle Tucker bolstering it as
well along with the return of Alex break
Michael Brantley getting a breather on
this Wednesday now it's time for the NBA
game of the week poll presented by
YouTube TV who's gonna win today's game
royals Astros chime in on that and
taking the pitching match up factor in
all the stats and things that you need
to to make your pick when we come back
we're gonna have a special guest join us
Kendall graveman of the Houston Astros
that's coming up next in the pregame
show
[Music]
runner on the go and the throw a little
bit oh in time how about that Castro
gets his first caught stealing of the
year
there goes the runner
and another guy throw down Gerard Dyson
caught stealing Astros have not LED in
this game
let Miss Diaz will try and change that
here with the bases loaded and nobody
out
there's a line driving to center field
that's down for a base hit into score is
curiel and the Astros take their first
lead of the game it's in the 10th it is
now four to three
swinging a Miss odorizzy now with seven
strikeouts matching the total he had
against Seattle in his first start
against the M's this year
third strike Raleigh throws it on the
fastball that's now eight strikeouts for
odorizzi hands over the head in the wind
up the one two swing and the best got
him on the curveball Seeger down on
strikes eight punch outs from McCullers
[Applause]
RBI single as Wilson crosses the plate
it's an even dozen for the second
straight game 12-nothing Astros
s you are watching the MLB game of the
week Live on YouTube pregame show
presented by YouTube TV
foreign
case for a special guest only special
guest and he's a special one at that
Kendall grayman of the Houston Astros
joining us here on ballpark cam Kendall
Great to visit with you thanks for doing
this first and foremost as a pro ball
player I know you guys travel quite a
bit you're used to going around seeing
new places but Kendall outside the show
circuit we've hit up your Medias of
Social and we see that you too like to
get out and travel and head out the
outdoors so tell us your favorite spot
away from the game
uh we went to the Grand Tetons last
off-season and it had to be one of my
favorites but uh we go to my wife and I
go to Eleuthera Bahamas every year we've
gone seven years in a row and that's got
to be a special place for us it's not a
place where there's a lot of resorts so
we got to know the locals and some
something that's really near and dear to
us is the Bahamas nice that's really
nice can can we go there with you next
time please no I'm kidding yes Kendall
you're having such a good year man your
era's sitting at a just over one which
is really that means you're nasty boys
can you talk about what it's been this
season why you've had so much success
yeah for me
um the development of the slider that's
uh paired uh really well with the Sinker
before that when I was a starter I had a
sinker and a cutter and everything was
kind of similar
um and to me the slider has really
changed the game for me to righties and
to lefties to be able to throw that I
think you've seen betting average from
myself go down and the era has
definitely going down and to throw 15 20
pitches in an outing and let it rip has
been pretty fun this year I love hearing
about that side the between the lines
stuff Kendall and I've actually followed
you since you were back at Hale state in
2013 so to see your kind of growth and
development through the show has been
pretty cool to watch but it's not just
the on the field stuff I think most of
the time most fans forget about the fact
that ball players are people too and you
were the face of the trade deadline in
terms of humanizing you guys as pro
athletes
look I know your focus right now is
getting out for the Houston Astros
how much time did you get give yourself
to kind of sit with the emotions of
being traded from a place that you
wanted to stay or is it something that
stays with you and you want to keep with
you every time you go on the bump
yeah
um there's I I'm somebody that I like to
express emotions I think for people to
be vulnerable is
um it's huge we don't get that a lot of
society today and just to be able to
show those emotions and express it it's
something I think fans gravitate towards
and I don't ever want to hide that so I
mean it was sitting at the house that
night in Seattle the place I was renting
with my wife and daughter after the game
knowing I was playing for another team
there's a lot of emotions there kind of
a sleepless night and it's something I'm
blessed to play this game for a living
and I hope people understand that
outside of the game we're always trying
to perform on the field but we have a
family and we have a lot of things that
go on and I just I love that aspect that
I'm just the same as the person sitting
in you know section 22 in a game and
we're just humans just like you with the
ability and bless to do what we do for a
living and thankful that fans show up to
watch us play yeah man Ken I've been
there before I've getting traded from
Cincinnati uh after eight years there
it's Hey listen to human beings you make
a lot of friends in this game and you
get you get connected to the city so I
understand those emotions you're with
the guy that I've gotten to know really
well over the years who I think is one
of the best managers in the game one of
the best guys in the game in the history
of baseball how about Dusty Baker like
how is how has your relationship been
with him so far and what has impressed
you the most about Bank
uh he's been awesome uh just to be able
to get to know me and hey we were
talking yesterday about myself but I'm
eight hours short of a mechanical
engineering degree and he was interested
in that and
um hey we started talking about he was
gardening and stuff he he Gardens at
home and my family had a garden when
when we were growing up and
um just uh an outstanding person in his
speech as a testament we went to the
Negro League Hall of Fame together when
we were in Kansas City and it was
something that I'll cherish forever that
moment to be able to spend with him and
explore the history of of baseball and I
think we've become close over the past
couple weeks being here and that's a
testament to him and what he does is a
player's manager and he cares for people
and you can see it day in and day out we
talk about human beings Dusty is one of
the best my favorite in baseball in
sports to be sure Ken before we let you
go you're still trying to get to know
all the humans in that Astros Clubhouse
and you've got a big one coming back in
Alex bregman can you speak to his return
and maybe the juice that's supplying the
clubhouse early
yeah quick Story I played at Mississippi
State when braggy was a a freshman and
he made an error and it costed them a
game at LSU and it's an hour or so after
the game the lights are still on and he
has a great assistant hitting him ground
balls and from that point on wow I've
always seen him
um the work that he's put in the
preparation and the energy and the
passion he has for the game it's a big
boost for our lineup it's somebody that
I've always enjoyed the battles but I'm
glad that he's on my side now and get to
watch him play on a daily basis that's a
story right there that's that's amazing
that's Peak bregman right there a Breaky
bomb salsa you got to try that as well
Kendall now that you're wearing the
Astros uniform thanks so much for doing
this man you're one of our favorites to
talk to in the game stay healthy stay
blessed and we'll do it again down the
road good luck brother thank you guys
appreciate it thank you
foreign
[Music]
friends it's time now for our creator
Spotlight and we are shining it on the
sports gaming Universe 260
000 Subs on his channel it's that's not
his name it's Matt Meyer okay so let's
introduce The Man Behind sports game
Universe Matt Myers joining us now and
the first thing I notice
that is not the work on your channel
which is incredible in in all sports not
just Major League Baseball you know
playing the show also Madden 2K and
previewing you know daily contests and
showing fans what actually might happen
in real life I noticed the jerseys that
you're wearing you have the twins behind
you because I know you're born and bred
Minnesota but you're wearing a Red Sox
uniform can you explain what is
happening right now
yeah I know it's a little strange to
American League clubs and all that but
uh yeah my love for both goes way back
um born and raised a twins fan here in
the in the Twin Cities but
goes back to about the well right about
the 86 World Series and uh just
identifying with uh the curse of the
Bambino and kind of latching onto that
fan base and their and their pain and
that that quest to finally uh break
through and get that trophy so it would
happen years later but uh but yeah I
latched on them and that only became
cemented with my first uh road trip out
to Fenway and
just knew that was where baseball was
supposed to be played I was used to
games in the Metrodome see a whole lot
of outside baseball especially in the
majors and that just blew me away and
I've been going back ever since love it
at Fenway well look we've talked before
about how I'm a White Sox fan but we are
still going to be friends despite the
White Sox twins thing despite that
absolutely that hatred between the two
fan fan or franchises and fan bases I
haven't immense respect for the
Minnesota Twins and I wish that I had
the chance to go see a game at the
Metrodome because I've always heard
stories about how loud it got in there
so I appreciate you kind of painting
that picture for me and others who have
not been there as for the Red Sox it has
not been the second half that everybody
in New England and Red Sox Nation was
hoping for what has gone wrong are you
still keeping the faith that the ship
can be righted
definitely Keeping the Faith you got to
keep the faith um I think pitching has
gone wrong mainly pitching's been really
tough the bats are waking up they woke
up against the twins last night but I
mean how many games can you count on out
slugging and winning eleven to nine
you got to have that pitching I know
people are really excited Chris sales
back but he can only pitch one out of
every five days and
everybody's getting a little bit nervous
about Matt Barnes closing out games here
I I know they're kind of losing the
faith in that so I think it starts with
the bullpen and and the pitching in
general to to stick with this and and
the Yankees are on the streak 11 in a
row now so it it's looking like a
looking like trouble but yes definitely
Keeping the Faith I'll say this the Gen
Z of Boston Red Sox fans they don't know
the pain and the suffering that you came
up in so this is a rough Swoon is
nothing compared to what you've
experienced in your life as a fan now
let's talk about the contest that we're
about to see on the only game of the
week Live on YouTube Houston and KC the
Astros have what a four and a half game
lead in that division but they have
Oakland who you know they're struggling
right now but the A's have some magic
one September Comes Around and then the
Mariners have this magic this year do
you feel like the Astros are going to
hold off both
I do actually feel like they are and I
think that's mainly because of
experience you know they've been there
they've got a lot of guys on the roster
that have done this before and isn't it
today that Alex bregman is supposed to
be back this is this is huge for them I
think that's just the right time to get
uh bring them back if he can be his uh
his normal self then that's going to be
a huge boost and
I really like what the Mariners are
doing and Oakland's always seeming to
make that run but I like Houston to hold
them off let's talk about another big
story in the show in real life not just
the show that I know the sport gaming
Universe specializes in but Miguel
Cabrera reaching the 500 home run
Plateau one of the greatest hitters of
all time right-handed or left-handed and
it's been a privilege to watch in this
last generation now everybody's thinking
about who's next who do you see as the
next current big Leaguer to hit 500.
oh man there's so many good ones but for
me it's got to be Vlad Guerrero Junior
yeah 36 homers this year he's already
got 60 at age what is he 22.
I mean you gotta lovecast he's Junior
you gotta love Soto but for me it's Vlad
it's got to be gladi I think that's a
strong pick I know Nelly Cruz is the
closest but he's you know he's getting
up there along the two not saying Nelly
can't do it you watch some break for the
twins against my White Sox primarily
um so sad to see him go yeah I know he's
he's one of those Clubhouse guys
wherever he is he's he's a game changer
and the Razer hoping that he could be
the piece that puts him over the hump as
the reigning pennant winners let's end
on this snow your most favorite cherish
memory as a fan of this game of baseball
Matt
oh so many I mean the the 2004 World
Series with the Red Sox finally breaking
through was great but before then I got
to throw it back to 91 and the second of
the the two twins uh World Championships
which I wish I would have cherished a
lot more being a young teenager back
then I kind of felt like that's
something that would happen a lot
uh certainly certainly not but uh I was
at game two personally that the whole
series was just gut wrenching the whole
time in the in the best ways
um and the twins came out on top but uh
I was there for the uh for the herback
and Gantt uh yeah Infamous play at first
base and uh Ken herbeck was my idol
growing up so I mean he he fell off the
bag there's no other way to put it he
fell off the bat that's all I got to say
about that Matt what I will say John
smoltzer is somewhere in the building
right now I'm I'm gonna leave this
conversation this part of our
conversation out of my conversation with
smoltzy but in all seriousness that
might be best yes for everybody in the
building not just me and all series is
great to link up with you albeit
digitally Again Sports gaming Universe
subscribe to Matt's Channel on YouTube
along with again 260 000 others and you
can get the best of the gaming world and
hopefully we can link up in real life
down the line Matt
absolutely this has been a pleasure
thanks again to Matt and there we see
now wait a second he shaved
what
that's a problem I have issues with this
oh I'll have a little break to collect
cut his hair too didn't he had long hair
no
here's Hunter Dozier oh
to left field that one is long gone
Hunter Dozier
oh tester
oh oh baby Nikki Lopez that looked like
that was dropping that was a little
doinker trying to sneak in there but
Lopez got a great jump and there's a
looping line drive to center field that
will knock in at least one Taylor with
the throw home it's a good one and they
got it
and sharply Lopez from his knees oh he
got him got him what a play
that ball is struck well deep to right
and it is
okay Lopez's first home run of the year
did I say the Royals won't beat you with
a long ball Jose Altuve base hit left
field
McCormick coming around the throw to the
plate
unloaded a cannon shot from Left Field
[Applause]
salvi's stretching here during the MLB
game of the week Live on YouTube pregame
show presented by YouTube TV
time now for picks to click presented by
bet MGM Sean Casey you're in the hot
seat oh fans watch and want to know your
thoughts on some potential plays here on
this Wednesday afternoon let's start
with this game total runs between the
Royals and Astros eight over or under
eight you know what uh I'm gonna have to
say with this one right here with it
with the lineup with bregman coming back
I'm going to say it's going to be over
eight today oh I just feel that way man
there's a couple hot guys in these
lineups
um minor this history versus guriel
there could be a three-run bomb involved
here so saying over 5.4 runs per game
for the Astros 4.1 runs per game for the
Royals different ends of the major
league Spectrum but that doesn't matter
you add them together and then you get a
number that's over eight over under six
and a half K's for Lance McCullers Jr
punches over under for six and a half
K's you know what I'm gonna say it's
going to be under today I think my
colors is gonna you know pitch well but
they're gonna put the ball in play it's
gonna be under six and a half his he has
struck out just food for thought seven
plus and nine of his last ten starts but
the Royals
pretty good and when it comes to
limiting case how about
some of Lance McCullough's Junior's
counterparts in the American League Cy
Young Front Runners I mean you have
Lance Lynn who's the betting favorite
right now you have Garrett Cole behind
him you have shohei Otani there as well
done there's the MVP no doubt that's it
you know what that's why it's
interesting because people are saying
well he's the MVP because you look at
his offensive numbers and then you look
at his pitching numbers well why is it
not the same conversation from the other
standpoint look at what he's done
pitching right and also look at what
he's doing hitting I'm not saying
otani's would be just something we've
never seen before I almost I almost feel
like him pitching and hitting you could
put him and say oh yes young for what he
has to do to get rid of that as that
type of player I think for me Lance Lynn
having the 2-2 era you know doing what
he's been doing all year long he'd have
to really fall off I think to not win
the cyan I'm with you I'm with you and
he's just a beautiful specimen of a man
and a perfect fit on the south side of
Chicago let's go to another game in the
central but in the National League
Cincinnati Milwaukee big series the Reds
now in a postseason spot they've been
great but the Brewers have had a
Stranglehold on that division seemingly
since their first series coming out of
the
break
you know the Reds
do you know how many runs they're going
to score today three and a half over
under Reds runs not total in this game
just Cincinnati just Reds runs yeah you
know what I'm for some reason I'm gonna
say over
um I know they've had trouble against
Woodruff and he's pitch well I think his
last few starts he hasn't been as sharp
and the and the reds are swinging right
now so I'm gonna say they're gonna go
over three and a half
um he's I don't know if for you kids out
there he's a big deal
[Laughter]
they got some they got some Thunder yes
they do so those are picks to click
presented by bet MGM now let's see your
poll results we asked you the question
who's gonna win today's game Kansas City
or Houston and 67 case wow they did not
care about the Royals record against
first place no they know bregman's back
uh you know and they thought he had a
beard like you and I did but he doesn't
that's why it was six to seven with no
beard it's like 55. I'm totally changing
my vote no beard so we have Scott Braun
on the call in between Jeremy Guthrie
yes and Jeff Blum Brett Dolan reporting
as well and you know both yes three and
Bloomer yeah well blumer and I you know
I played against Bloomer live well who's
with the Astros I was with the Reds
obviously we played against each other
in the central a lot but he's great does
a great job Guthrie does a great job
great job our boy brownie does too so
this is a great he does a great job of
just being Jack just just does a great
job
do you have a oh we have a tweet we have
oh we have some some breaking some
breaking Twitter news ah okay James
click going Sean unfiltered on Sports
Talk 790 that Justin Verlander will not
return at all this season for the Astros
Dockers doctors direct America Dockers I
don't know I don't think great shooting
or wears Dockers but doctors recommended
not the best move for his recovery well
you know what you know what about that
playing with Verlander I you know he
wants to come back yeah and like try and
maybe get back and get back now this
season help them with the push back to
the World Series and I think the doctors
are coming out right now to say huh
let's pull the reins back let's not get
your hopes up come September we're
letting you know late August season's
over and I think for JV that's probably
the play he wants to be the Brady of
baseball right he wants to pitch forever
and so I think just as tempting as it
would be to join a potential World
Series run with the Astros right now
taking it safe in Houston for Justin
Verlander I like it in case you know I
love you thanks so much for hanging out
with us on the only game of the week
Live on YouTube pregame show presented
by YouTube TV enjoy the ball game down
in the juice box
[Applause]
[Applause]
together
we're in downtown Houston and I'll use
Dusty Baker's words on how Casey has
played his Astros they're pushing us and
we're not punching them well last night
the Astros smacked them back with
dominant pitching and then they're gonna
finish up the season series right now
this is the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube presented by YouTube TV we have
the Kansas City Royals and Houston
Astros for a Wednesday matinee at Minute
Maid Park in Houston Texas
let's go hello everyone watching
worldwide on YouTube I'm Scott Braun
along with former Royal Jeremy Guthrie
and former Astro and current Astros TV
analyst Jeff Blum and also this is the
Renaissance Man I mean we're talking
before this game starts Jeremy's like
yeah I took a stop in Kenya on my way
over here I mean he's gonna go through
his entire life and everything that he's
seen we're excited to have you it's all
about the warthogs Scotty stay tuned
that's a sneak peek of what you'll get
from Jeremy and Jeff is going to let us
know about this Astros team that's in
first place pretty much all season long
as we check out the postseason picture
and that extended thanks to a loss from
Oakland yesterday and it's kind of
interesting to see Seattle and Oakland
going ahead and Seattle putting that
loss on the Oakland A's and allowing the
Astros to create separation but it's
been tough to do against the Kansas City
Royals where the Astros only two and
four in six games already against the
Royals yeah this Royals team has played
them tough we'll get to them in just a
moment let's start with Houston's
offense specifically why are they such a
pain for opposing pitchers they have
developed an idea here where they're
gonna go out and not Chase outside the
Zone when they do not change outside the
Zone it forces a lot of pitchers back
inside the zone and some of those
pitches end up being mistakes and what
they do when those mistakes are out over
the plate they end up getting the barrel
to it but it's very impressive to watch
them go out there close to a 270 average
and almost matching it with runners in
scoring position and these guys are
extremely proud of these numbers
considering that stigma that follows
them around to all season long it's
intimidating when you go through the
lineup card one through nine and let's
highlight Houston's Magnificent Seven
yes some teams have one or two
superstars the Astros are loaded Jeff
and it starts with the man at the top
and it does they've lost George Springer
who was their leadoff man in years past
they were wondering how they're going to
fill that void the All-Star and MVP Jose
Altuve has done it wonderfully and of
course Captain consistency and Michael
Brantley is going to continue to put up
great at bats getting this guy back
today maybe a little bit of a game
changer down the stretch when this
offense has been struggling but Jordan
Alvarez this should be a sophomore here
only played one game last season yet he
is continuing to put up big numbers 280
almost to that 30 home run range and
then Carlos Correa who really wants to
go into that free agent year with big
numbers yeah he has had a really nice
year both on offense and defense Julie
gurielis on another planet this year in
the way that he's changed his offensive
profile Kyle Tucker is back he made a
quick appearance yesterday in the
Outfield but now he's back in the
starting lineup for the first time in
about a couple weeks and then there's
the Kansas City Royals led by their
all-world catcher Salvador Perez he's
been great for years Jeremy your former
teammate though is also stepping up his
game especially on offense this year and
we know what he brings defensively well
you know they signed him to another
four-year deal in the in the spring this
year and he has come out with this
Reckless abandon he is a guy that wants
to be involved with everything he's
leading the young staff he continues to
be fantastic behind the plate having
another Gold Glove type season he's up
there in Cotton percent stealing he's
thrown out 13 and 32 Runners the most in
Major League Baseball and uh he is just
a force back there he plays every day he
blocks everything speed up and he keeps
going and he's doing it offensively this
year with career highs and home runs
33-81 RBI this guy has just retooled his
swing working with Coach uh hitting
coach Terry Bradshaw and he is
Relentless he's aggressive he's right in
the middle and he does everything he's
the heart and soul he's tough to pitch
against statcast powered by Google Cloud
okay fastballs he handles them like many
others but non-fast balls too he's got
14 homers off non-fast Falls this year
adding to his career-high 33 and that's
when he's been at his best when he came
up he was known as a guy that could hit
it to all Fields there's a period of
time where a lot of hitters start to
pull and I think for him the past couple
of years he has gotten back to work this
bread and butter is and you see the
results let's appreciate it on Pace to
be the fifth catcher the sixth catcher
to hit 40 home runs in a season we
should appreciate the fact that this is
one of the best seasons we've ever seen
offensively from a catcher and he does a
great job handling the Royal staff but
that Rose pitching staff is going to
have its hands full because the
Magnificent Seven does have their
seventh man he's back Alex bregman has
missed the past couple months and he is
in the lineup today Brett Dolan has more
for us Brett well thanks Scott there has
certainly been a question that has been
asked around this Houston Astros fan
base over the last two months what is up
with Alex bregman and when can he be
back in this lineup today is the answer
Brickman finally activated you go back
to mid-june it was a quad injury that
has disrupted his season trying to leg
out this double play bouncer you'll see
him pull up lame obviously in some pain
and he hasn't quite been the same since
Franklin has had multiple rehab
assignments with AAA Sugar Land
yesterday back at Minute Maid Park able
to put the finishing touches on getting
back and healthy taking some ground
balls and Dusty Baker happy to have him
activate it so between the hamstrings
and the quads it has been a problem for
Brigman because his team has had more
plate appearances out of third baseman
other than bregman with the legend of
Diaz filling in so admirably at third
base now Kyle Tucker was also activated
yesterday so Dusty Baker has his full or
top seven bats in the lineup Jose
urquidi had a rehab assignment last
night with AAA Sugarland he's getting
closer so this offense and this team
that has been so good this year starting
to get all of their weapons back for the
stretch drive now Dusty did say he's
going to bat bregman sixth rather than
at the top of the lineup he feels like
if he has to take him out late in the
game maybe something pops up he doesn't
want to completely disrupt the top of
the lineup but again this offense
leading in so many categories we'll have
their top seven bats back with Kyle
Tucker activated bregman back so they'll
make that push for the stretch Drive
having all of their pieces at the Avail
of their manager Scott
gregman and Tucker in the Astros host an
aggressive Royals ball Club it's all
free to watch worldwide on YouTube today
we'll deliver lineups in first pitch
from Houston next
one out and the batter will be Salvador
Perez
salvi drills it to deep left field and
adds it into the Crawford boxes so it's
his 33rd home run of the year
Taylor comes in to score it's an RBI
double Rivera stops at third the Royals
lead is 3-1
and he swings and drives it to left and
that's going to find the Gap and roll
all the way to the wall and the Royals
go in front seven to one how about this
triple for with Merrifield
here's Alexis Diaz
on the ground Lopez a diving stop and
the throw gets by the first baseman
O'Hearn two runs will score that ball
hits our center field Taylor on the move
and watch this one Bounce Off the Wall
RBI double Carlos Correa it is four to
nothing swinging a Miss that's a good
change up one of his finest outings of
the year he is gonna get a nice hand
when he heads to The Dugout
ball game over Kendall Draven a one two
three ninth a four hit three pitcher
combined shutout
[Applause]
this is the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube presented by YouTube TV watch
live TV with unlimited DVR and more
YouTube TV try it for free we're
bringing it today unique features you
get them every week right here bringing
you closer to the game than ever before
and we're cruising through our 20-plus
game package this year on YouTube tell
your friends easy to find us youtube.com
MLB join the three million plus who
subscribe to the MLB YouTube channel
also a brand new feature we rolled out
last week who can personalize your
listening experience more on that in
just a moment we have starting pitchers
to match up Jeremy Guthrie it's the
veteran Mike Minor against Lance
McCullers Jr who's been in his crime and
thriving this year well you know what
it's uh he has invented himself a new
pitch he's got a new toy out there and
he sure loves using it against the
writings that is a slider he's been
fantastic he's already made he'll make
his 22nd start of the year which is a
career high today and uh he's been
fantastic it's a career season for him
at 27 years old the 321 era is the best
that he's had in his career and this is
Mike matheny's Royal starting lineup
card presented by YouTube TV Whit
Maryfield plays every day and I mean
that literally Nikki Lopez has had a
really nice bounce back season Salvador
Perez having the best year of his career
Andrew benintendi's gonna clean up nice
pickup from the off-season over from the
Boston Red Sox Hunter Dozier is at first
base today Carlos Santana is still
sitting with a hip issue Rhino hearning
right Michael Taylor in his speed and
Center Emmanuel Rivera making a name for
himself lately over at third base and
cam Gallagher will do the catching thank
you
okay a little more on Lance McCullers Jr
with our pitcher breakdown presented by
YouTube TV this is their top guy yeah
you know what you obviously got drinking
he's an anchor but Lance McCullers has
been around now feels like forever broke
out in 15. he can be the ace and if he
pitches like that today and continues on
he's gonna get his career high in
Innings he needs to be that guy for the
Astros moving forward I said sweep the
leg he's aggressive he's like the Cobra
Kai he'll come in at you and he's going
to throw a sweeping slider to the
righties wipe you out no mercy for uh
from a colors today and spin you're
gonna see a lot of breaking balls curve
balls to the lefties sliders to the
righties
coming out with Maryfield pitch misses
low and in and we are underway Live on
YouTube to a global audience today the
Royals matching up with the Astros
Kansas City at 56 and 69 on the year
they've won seven of their last nine
Houston checking in at 74 and 52 Whit in
the air right to the shortstop Carlos
Correa for out number one
[Applause]
it's got a pretty good looking defense
behind him too all year I think that's
one of the more underrated components
you know what that defense is so good
that we've heard free agent pitchers
talk about signing with the Houston
Astros because of the defense behind him
and it has been since June 16th that
we've actually seen a fragment Correa
Altuve Yuli guriel in that starting
lineup behind a Astros pitcher so a
great luxury to have those guys behind
them because you talked about Jeremy
Lance McCullers having that great
Wipeout strikeout type stuff but he uses
a high ground ball guy also which keeps
this defense on their toes well that's
the thing in his last start it felt like
he was O2 to everybody and that's
indicative of a guy that's confident
pitching into a lineup that if they put
it in play he knows the players behind
them are going to make the play for him
and so you know they had 15 straight
games about an error I think that ended
just two games ago and that's what he's
dealing with so you get electric stuff
with good defense yeah the stats really
back it up out to above average which
looks at the entire defense has them
number one in baseball at the moment
there's the Fielding percentage you were
talking about
same guys in there almost every day
which helps that Court that's been here
for a while now Lopez makes contact
diving stopped by bregman he's back
you know who's gonna find him right
quickly he's a shortstop over there
yeah he had to take a little slice of
Humble Pie sign it with the Houston
Astros but he knew when moving to Third
Base he was only going to make this team
better but right out of the shoot Nikki
Lopez is tested testing him and as much
as we talk about Alex bregman and what
he brings to an offense you see what he
can do defensively also
complete player uh just an incredible on
both sides of the ball and certainly
they're happy to have him back
now it's Salvador Perez with nobody on
and two outs here in the first also for
bregman he had to get up quickly because
Nikki Lopez can fly unlike Nikki Lopez I
know he's a little bit of a throwback in
this dip and drive era that we're living
in but I like his game
well he and wit have been uh the really
the straws that have stirred the offense
for the the Royals recently in this run
on base a lot stealing a ton of bases
um six last week against the Astros and
and even you see that ball hit to
Brakeman hard hit ball
the Royals as a team are a bit of a
throwback they're aggressive
they make contact they certainly know
how to run and they've been doing that
pretty frequently against Houston in the
past week I thought it was great to talk
to Mike Matheny because we all have
these assumptions when we see when we
see how teams are put together but Mike
Matheny said this is specific to
Kauffman stadium and where they play
they rely on speed and being aggressive
and putting pressure on defenses
well that was part of the big recipe in
the in the run in the mid-2010s right in
1415 is run produce the runs they're
they're 27th in home runs in the league
so they're not going to pound you out of
the park although they can do it they
hit five solo home runs last week in
Chicago in a game but generally speaking
they're going to get guys on not strike
out a lot and uh and run
you're looking at one of the most
aggressive hitters in baseball and he's
taken a few pitches now to ride up to
count it's a full boat here
that's Ball Four
so far a line out of ground ball and a
walk and then some odds courtesy of bed
Edge MGM putting up the strikeout total
at six and a half Jeremy you're the
pitcher you start is he going over or
under well it's a great challenge here
right you got a team that makes a lot of
contact against a guy that's got his
career high and strikeouts over a
strikeout printing 144 already this year
um
I like I like the approach of the Royals
I take the under wow Jeff you going the
other way oh yeah of course I am
that's on the ground right side it's for
Altuve and the side is retired so Perez
is stranded no strikeouts yet in the
first but I'm sure there's plenty of
swinging Miss to come from that man on
the man we'll get to the bottom of the
first and intro the Astros lineup
Runner goes pitcher swung on and missed
throw it a second tight Lopez goes throw
to third it almost got by Diaz oh tester
oh baby Nikki Lopez looked like that was
dropping that was a little doinker
trying to sneak in there but Lopez got a
great jump
to ground ball up the middle that'll
find Centerfield and the Royals have
their first base running Lopez goes
pitch taken through by Maldonado skips
away and Nikki Lopez now 14 for 14
stealing bases this year
that ball has struck well deep to right
and it is Nikki Lopez's first home run
of the year it's sharply Lopez from his
knees oh he got him got him what a play
oh my goodness
the ground balls into center field
that's base hit number three for Nikki
Lopez and not expecting Rivera to even
run yeah and now it's stroked into right
center field beautiful job so that
stolen base ends up being huge for the
Royals Nikki Lopez has two more hits
[Applause]
[Music]
if you were with us from the beginning
we went over the Magnificent Seven it is
almost complete today the only man
sitting from that group is Michael
Brantley just a routine day off your
Astros starting lineups presented by
YouTube TV all two days in there Diaz in
left field today griel Alvarez Carlos
Correa at short and there's the big man
we highlight Alex bregman his first game
since June 16th he missed 59. he's back
Kyle Tucker back in the starting lineup
for this team as well fouled by Myers
and Maldonado going up against the
veteran the one veteran in the starting
rotation for the Royals our Scouting
Report presented by YouTube TV this is a
rotation of a bunch of young guys Mike
Miner is not one of those he's the
veteran they brought him in for a
two-year deal he's their leader he's
more quiet in nature but he's got to go
out there every five days every six days
it is now just put an example get deep
into the game he works on the corners
he's successful there Mike Matheny said
he pitches well up in the zone which is
different than some of his younger
pitchers and runners in scoring position
has been a challenge for him this year
so he needs to do his best to leave him
stranded out there work through some of
the trouble he's going to have with guys
on base he starts Altuve with a pitch
that misses just a bit above the Zone
although Jeff you should be careful
because Jose Altuve can handle an
elevated heater it's amazing how he goes
up the ladder so to speak and gets some
of those pitches we've seen him on his
tippy toes over the years get base hits
we've also seen him Elevate and drive
him out of the ballpark around neck High
it's incredible not many players can do
that I think about David Fletcher of the
Angels he's one that will go after the
high pitch it's really in a weapon to
have in a game where pitchers are
working up there as much as we've ever
seen all too they smacked one foul
[Applause]
he's got some work to do still lead off
home runs and Astros history two pretty
good names in front of him yeah very
good names and Altuve constantly adding
his name to that franchise history book
but yeah he's got ways to go in that
lead-off spot
a little flare and caught grabbed by
Nikki Lopez and shallow left for the
first out
and that's what Nikki Lopez does it
interesting he came into the season as
their second baseman his job to lose
injuries to uh mondassi moved him to
shortstop and now he's in contention for
a gold glove this year making plays like
this every single day
that's a leg plate too that's just
getting a good jump showing the footwork
getting good speed and still able to
stay with it it was a great play
he's a gold glove candidate you can see
the ads above average this season
measuring his defense a comprehensive
stat he's top five among infielders
I got two pretty good shortstops in this
ball game today
fleets all over the diamond on both
sides
here's one LED means Diaz who did some
work filling in at third base for
bregman swings through the off-speed
pitch for minor but Diaz has been on
fire since the All-Star break hitting
337.
that was after he went on the injured
list with that broken hand after being
hit in Toronto where he was tearing the
cover off the baseball
oh
there it is since coming back from the
IL Dusty Baker calls him his secret
weapon
I don't know how much of a secret it is
not in Houston that's for sure
pulled to third Rivera across the
diamond to God
good pitch there by minor couple of hard
pitches inside and on the hands looks
like he's got good sharp command these
first couple of hitters uh working both
sides of the dish well I think that's
one of the more interesting things too
because in this day and age of everybody
Max Velo 95 plus you've got a veteran
like Mike Minor who's still not afraid
to get to that inside corner cut it a
little bit and tie up some right-handed
hitters
it's got to open up the outside corner
quite a bit too right it's all about
that it's all about Miss get their
timing off mix and match it really
doesn't matter how hard you throw if you
can mix it and that's what Mike Miner's
done you know he's he's been strong his
whole career he had a great year in 2019
um last year struggled a bit and this
year has been one of the more consistent
lefties uh making every one of us starts
but still trying to work through here
and give the team a chance to win and be
that example for the young guys could
change up right there
yeah in 2019 an All-Star finished top 10
in Al Cy Young voting with the Texas
Rangers
you areas that tick high this year but
he's eating up innings for a young team
33 years old start number 207 of his
career today
I think he Trails just uh Robbie Ray for
left-handed starting pitchers Innings
pitched this year with his 141 so
exactly what the Royals were looking for
I mean sure they like you know get some
Get the Era down but he's doing what
they need him to do and he's consistent
he's getting better and stronger here
Yuli guriel has been unfazed with two
strikes this season
and he stays alive
thank you Lee is one of the better
right-handed hitters in the league just
because he pulls his hands in so easily
really leads with that knob
that love is set up too it reminds me of
Julio Franco how he's kind of
porked in there with his back towards
the pitcher
he's 10 for his last 20 having a huge
home stand
and he whips little Chase minor picks up
the strikeout and sits down the side in
order we've completed one no score from
Houston Texas on YouTube
[Music]
Carlos Correa leads off against Carlos
Hernandez in the first pitch Correa
belts it deep to left field and You Can
Kiss It Goodbye over the bullpen Carlos
Correa gives the Astros a 4-3 lead
that Ball's hit hard in the left field
and there you go it's down for a hit
that could be extra bases Correa takes
the turn benintendi's throw not in time
here's the 2-2 pitch swinging a line
drive into right center field that's
down for a hit though Hearn is over from
right to get it man Correa is on with
his second hit of the game 1-1 and
Correa drives it out to Right Center
deep racing over is kelnick on the
warning track can't get it
tearing for third base Brantley he's
around third and coming home there will
be no throw it's an RBI triple for
Correa and it's a one-nothing lead for
the Astros
Arizona sharply hit ground ball through
the hole between short and third Correa
two for two
[Music]
that ball rocketed into center field
that'll be down for a hit altube
aggressively turned second kelnick drops
the ball so Correa is going to get into
second base Al tube going first to third
but then Correa gets the extra 90 feet
[Applause]
[Music]
top two in Texas Dusty Baker leads the
Houston Astros group and he is inching
closer to an exclusive Club Jeff we're
not invited
you are I'm gonna say it's a very
limited group
goes back a long way 2800 wins is pretty
amazing you got to be able to be
sustainable Connie Mack at 37-76 but
these are veteran guys a lot of these
managers you do see on this list I feel
like when you get comments from players
who have played for them they have been
players managers helping these guys out
along the way with experience not only
playing but also as managers but that is
exclusive group that Dusty is aiming for
2000 win Club he's getting there
1966 on The Ledger right now in his 24th
season at the helm
Jeremy we were not invited it looks like
a lot of fun in there playing pool
hanging up on the bar I was invited
until I made my one start for Dusty
trying to get him one win closer and uh
he withdrew the invite after the ninth
earned run that I allowed in the first
inning and uh
yeah we mentioned it to him when we said
hello right we tried our best to ruin
his day but what a what a great guy to
play for you know
[Applause]
and some other MLB Milestones that we're
keeping an eye on Miggy just hit his
500th now he's looking for 3 000 hits
Kimbrell close to 400 saves in his
career and he's having a career year
really a big comeback season for Craig
Kimbrel and now a dangerous weapon on
the American League side I'm sure the
Astros aren't thrilled if they have to
see them in the postseason yeah not with
the White Sox we know how that matchup
went no five I hate to remind him of
that but Kimbrell definitely adds
another element with Liam Hendricks out
there in that Bullpen and allows Tony
larussa who's already on that 2000 win
this list to go out there and get more
with the options he has but it's amazing
to me how fast Kimbrell's got to that
close to that 400 plateau and I had the
luxury of sitting in the seat right here
watching Justin Verlander go out there
and get his 3 000k on his 300th
strikeout in 2019. so these Milestones
really mean something these guys and I
think they mean even more considering
the way the game is being molded and
shaped for starting pitchers and even
closers
2-2 from McCullers Dozier through the
vacated right side he's got a base hit
second base runner of the day for Kansas
City so we've set it all up
Milestone wise and now we need help
our first poll question of the day it's
right on your screen your mobile device
your computer wherever you're watching
which potential career Milestone are you
most looking forward to Dusty's 2000s
win Mickey's 3000th hit Max Scherzer at
3 000 K's or Kimbrell 400 saves that
he's chasing
you can vote now
poll is open we'll close it in about an
inning or so get involved
well blumber what you say is you know
you got these
these records that are over sustained
careers and things are changing so
dramatically with using bullpens more or
just all this the way the game is played
the way it's evaluated and so these
records may become even more and more
rare I agree to accomplish yeah that's
why it felt really special to watch
Justin Verlander go out there and get 3
000 strikeouts and 300ks in a single
season because he's still a part of that
old school mentality where I'm going to
give you seven and you're going to have
to drag me off the field
but uh I agree and that's why I think
that some of those pitching Milestones
or even the 3000 hits you know are those
guys going to get those opportunities
because Major League careers are being
shortened
I guess I don't guess I know because of
Analytics
on most guys don't play every day
anymore
yeah it's the amount of opportunities
these guys get
there's that good change up from the
Kohler's got a lot of depth a lot of
life to it runs in the mid 80s off the
mid 90s fastball and he'll use at any
point in the count just destroys the
lefties with that pitch really only uses
it against the lefties but it is uh it
has become a great pitch for him
he used it often with the depth you're
talking about last time around against
Seattle when six Innings gave up two
runs one walk eight strikeouts in a 12-3
win last week
and he picks up a strikeout his first of
the day
about six and a halfs in real Jeopardy
if the change uh in the curveball are
going to be that sharp for him all day
over and just trying to battle him right
there with two strikes and not much you
can do with that one born in on the
hands
and that's what you were talking about
with left-handed hitters he will use
that curveball a little more frequently
in those two strike counts but it's a
nice weapon to have that change up early
in the count to get that swing and Miss
to get ahead he looks so comfortable
with the change up too it looks like a
pitch like a fastball where he can throw
at any count and it's misses down most
times and so it is a weapon that lefties
are gonna have to think about all day
long well and you can speak to the
importance of how good a change up can
be when you have a good fastball and you
don't change that arm velocity you don't
change that release Point how deceptive
that can be the great equalizer is what
they call I mean yep it's you can get a
real sense for it when you play with
your kids when I tell my kids a change
up they have no idea what's happening
but the bat flies out of their head like
why did I why did I let go of the bat
the pitch was in the middle and it's
because they start to swing they realize
there's no ball there and things get all
funky and so it's just you're right the
deception on it a change up I feel like
is if I was a young kid
what pitch would I want to develop
fastball with arm strength as a young
player and a changeup because it's fun
too it's fun to make people look foolish
on a pitch that's straight a curveball
everyone Ah that's a big curveball but a
change up to like what just happened
why'd I miss that pitch
Michael a Taylor fouls that one back I
didn't think about that big league
pitchers going up against their kids I
was just saying can we dig a little bit
deeper on the psychology of this I want
more on that but first statcast 3D
powered by Google Cloud the Arsenal for
Lance McCullers Jr he's got the full
menu and it's been working for him this
year there it is any pitch anytime and
it's really got the chance to make him
that Ace that they believe he can be
got our YouTube creators hanging out in
the live commentary section there's the
one two to Taylor he Rings him up
two down and made the cuts head the
development of the slider has been huge
for lance2 adding to our conversation
yeah that's a pitch that suddenly has
become maybe his best weapon oh and
that's what I want to ask Jeremy about
because we talked about how Lance
McCullers has been on the stage now
since 2015 and when he broke in he was
just fastball curveball and he was going
to go out there and Telegraph and tell
everybody my best pitch is my curveball
and still get guys out then that change
up comes into the mix he messed around
with the cutter a little bit had the
Tommy John and when he came back he was
looking for a pitch to get right-handers
out and in this spring training in 2021
really developed that slider and it's
been
it's been deadly to right-handed hitters
but what is it like for a pitcher a
couple of years into his career to
developed that extra pitch and be that
effective with it let's just say this
you can't go down to Nordstrom and pick
up a good slider in the men's department
and so more people would do it right
absolutely although they're pretty
expensive as you might imagine so yeah
to develop a pitch on his own no less
yeah it's his motivation to go out there
and develop the slider and in such a
short time become such a weapon
right back to a great Athlete on the
mound as well McCullers Jr impressive
second inning after the Dozier base hit
through the right side strikeout
strikeout and Lance McCullers Jr with
the glove to finish off the Royals in
the top of the second
look like a ball
right all right all right
I got one two three four five six
it's the wallet again until I bend
so you know and baby we got some good
moment and back moment and this you know
remind me that I'm pretty good I think I
see some
Maybe daddy Molina have it too some some
guys you know yeah
and I see and that's pretty good thing
to do and now you guys I got my stuff so
I think that's how I get to this I got
my God gloss and there they are
so one two three four five hopefully
most common guys I played Mariah because
you know that's how he talked to a
second base so the girl should be in my
Ryan so that way I pulled the star my
left arm you have any plans that like
what if you feel the whole arm up where
are you going to go I'm a big boy so I
gotta play in the room for that hahaha
Right Here Right Now the MLB game of the
week Live on YouTube presented by
YouTube TV watch live TV with unlimited
DVR and more YouTube TV try it for free
and also fans watching the game of the
week now have their choice of listening
experience so you're just gonna click
the gear icon in your player choose
audio tracks you can select the primary
broadcast that's us or take your pick of
the Home and Away radio call so you can
just switch back and forth have fun with
it all audio is seamlessly integrated on
your favorite devices so you don't miss
a minute of the action
Scott Brown Jeremy Guthrie Jeff glum and
Brett Dolan joining us in just a moment
Mike Miner back to work in the second
against Alvarez Correa and bregman
making his way back to the starting
lineup
first it's Jordon six foot five to
thirty-ish
Big Time pop
living here in Houston over the past
three years getting a chance to come to
a couple of ball games I have seen some
absolute Moon Shots by Jordon Alvarez
that I know one of them has not landed
they saw that one but this guy is just a
dangerous young hitter I imagine if he
continues to improve and as he gets more
and more experience and I completely
agree with that he is still learning the
game and learning what pitchers are
doing to him yet he is in his sophomore
season hitting 282 with the amount of
Pop That Jeremy's talking about and he's
hit upper tanks with easy ease here and
he put one up into that Ultra Club in
right field beyond the right field pole
that had to be in the air for about 35
seconds it felt like
but he's truly special and once he
figures out how to inside out some of
these tough pitches and going to the
Crawford boxes here at Minute Maid Park
it could be scary
it's got leverage in the count
and take a pitch down the pipe you know
we've talked a lot about McCullers mix
the same thing for minor he can throw he
throws four pitches for you breaking
ball slider change up fastball moves it
around and so he's gonna have to use
that same repertoire here and throughout
Alvarez is three for nine with a homer
and a double
against Mike Minor
[Applause]
in Washington blumber have you found a
hole at all in Alvarez's swing if you
were pitching to him that you might go
to you can stand him up up and in and do
the old school hard in soft away because
sometimes that slider away from
left-handed pitchers he will chase down
and away
and from a right-handed pitcher
sometimes that down and in slider but he
has taken some pictures that have been
close off the outside corner
takes a pitch on the outside corner
might have missed by a bit he's shaking
his head that is strike three second of
the day for Mike Minor and let's go down
to Brett Dolan hey Brad hi Scott you
know Nikki Lopez has had a unique year
and really last couple of weeks this was
a guy who went 72 games without making
an error when 464 events without hitting
a home run but this took place last week
he's from Naperville Illinois a family
of Cub fans went out Saturday got three
base hits and then he took his
girlfriend and soon to be fiance Sydney
got engaged apparently with the young
kids it doesn't count if you don't have
a videographer on hand so they did so
congratulations to Nikki and Sydney it's
been quite a week for this throwback
type of player in Nikki Lopez thanks
Brett that's a perfect day what'd you do
yesterday and three hits and engagement
no big deal at Wrigley Field in his own
backyard yeah
that's a big lead proposal right there
that's a smart player yes I mean Carlos
a couple of shortstops making some very
smart moves because Korea proposed after
the 2017 World Series Championship Mike
could you imagine if you propose it
after an over day there's no chance no
chance she accepts she better have good
hands because that ring might be coming
in hot
that ring has some bling too
showed up the highest building
percentage in the family after that yep
well done Nikki congratulations
gregman coming up after Correa
good pitch there backing him off we'll
see a little bit of that maybe a little
bit of same strategy you talked about
against Alvarez coming hard in here
opens up everything for him on this next
pitch
so I'll get Yuli guriel after coming
inside with a backdoor curveball
this time the fastball misses in
you know going back to pitching to the
kids you show them two hard fastballs in
like that I get some bad swings
Dash will take some terrible swings
after two hard heaters and
goes there again off speed and Carlos
Correa Works a walk
nice support in the lineup today for
Carlos with Alex bregman hitting behind
him he's in the six hole for now he's
back foreign
just a little bit yeah
quad hamstrings soft tissue injuries
past couple years really you said it's
been a physical and emotional roller
coaster but he feels better than he has
in the past couple years and goes after
the first pitch golfs went in foul
ground Rivera called off by lope has a
little bump and he's got it don't mess
with the shortstop and you just got
engaged too
well Alex tried to Ambush that first
pitch coming back off the injured list
I have I have nightmares about ambushes
2009 A-Rod came off the DL oh no way um
after you know a little bit of the the
Scandal the challenges he had
I'm talking to Chad Moller I'm like
where do you want to start him you know
I got the first game with him off the DL
you know let's go hard in you know he
has bad speed he won't be able to catch
up 98 on the black it was straight no
movement and it's in the left field
stands right now so
um you know not a you get ambushed
you're on both ends of it I was on the
other end the old the aisle ambush
so for bregman it's his first game since
June 16th Kyle Tucker was activated
yesterday he appeared in the last half
inning in right field but hasn't been
the starting lineup since August 13th he
was on the covet IL he tested positive
he said on the trip in Anaheim just mild
symptoms and he's back in there so the
lineup really starting to get itself
intact for the stretch run for a first
place ball Club in the AL West
but on the covid IL the day after he hit
his first grand slam of his career
a little good a little bad
he's young he's actually activated
yesterday for Chas McCormick who hits
the IL for a hand issue
I would say a unique stance
unique swing all the way around
there's a lot of questions on whether or
not he'd be able to get to the inside
pitch but there's a reason that Kyle
Tucker is here is because he is a very
good pure hitter and even though that
swing is unique he's been able to make
it work for him but you could probably
speak to this too Jeremy when you see
that arm bar that lead arm kind of bar
out a little bit kind of gives you the
idea or the impression that you can beat
him inside
foreign
to remind you of anyone
I know I've been told that he reminds a
lot of people of who Ted Williams was
the moniker that everybody gave him when
he was coming up through the big leagues
very similar swing and a very similar
stature also kind of thin frame but yet
provides a lot of power
makes contact into left Center Taylor
running over a little stop camp and
record the out to end the inning
so we had the Correa walk bregman's
first at-bat in about 60 games Astros
nothing to show for it after two no
score
[Music]
with another Drive will it be number two
of the night easily number two when you
play 15 years next to somebody you you
just grow accustomed to he's doing what
he's supposed to do every single day
every single night all right well back
one in the dome a three-run Dinger it
was the guy in the lineup that you
didn't want to face at the end of the
game that's for sure
[Applause]
it's just fun to watch from afar but
then again when you're part of it as a
teammate and watching this guy do this
every single night it's a great seat to
have
it
the man just did a lot of things on the
baseball field you know he didn't have
the fastest speed in the world but he
was a smart base runner Bagwell steals
it he's a 30-30 man
Astros in the first full-time first
baseman in major league history
[Music]
ground out to a lance
we're in the third Lance McCullers
Junior going up against 9-1-2 for Kansas
City who almost witnessed a No-No from
Chris bubitch on August 21st this past
weekend he was dealing and there was a
34-minute rain delay that kind of halted
things a bit he had the No-No into the
seventh and things unraveled a bit but
ultimately produced just a
Dynamite start six and a third two
earned runs career-high nine strikeouts
is going to join us for this half inning
and before I say hello to him YouTube
creators you know what to do in the live
live game chat a few questions you have
for Chris bubitch we'll take them we'll
relay them over to Chris himself who
joins us Chris thanks so much for the
time how are you today good how are you
guys doing
we're doing fantastic really good and
but not as good as you of course over
the weekend at Wrigley take us through
that entire experience really from start
to finish because you had to deal with
some mother nature-ish adversity
although I heard it never actually
rained maybe there was just like some
lightning warning or something going on
there yeah so definitely a little
interesting but um throughout the whole
game uh pretty good Rhythm right off the
bat and just kind of rolled through you
know uh once you're in it as a pitcher
you're in a good Rhythm like that you
know you don't really think too much
about anything you just focus on execute
in each pitch and the results kind of
take care of themselves and then yeah at
the end of the sixth inning the sky got
really dark
um started to get really windy and I
noticed that there was some kind of rain
in the forecast and the ground screw was
getting prepped to cover the field and
they put up the uh the notification I
think on the on the scoreboard that
there was lightning in the area so they
were going to Halt it for that but yeah
you're right there was never actually
any rain it was more about the lightning
I think more than anything else but it
is what it is and uh that's baseball and
that's Mother Nature so things we can't
control sometimes pretty amazing that
you had the opportunity to do that and
really feel at what point during that
game did you realize it and was it a
little more special doing it in a place
like Wrigley Field yeah for sure
honestly my goal as a pitcher I mean I
don't want to give up anything anytime I
go out so I I honestly I know from the
first inning that you know nothing's
happened on the hit column yet but uh as
you go on you know I really wasn't
focused on that and then you know get
that little bit of delay and then kind
of start to think about it maybe a
little bit but yeah especially that was
my first time in Wrigley too as a fan or
a player or anything so getting to do it
at a place like that as historic as uh
as Wrigley is just was an incredible
experience
hey Chris this is Jeremy Guthrie here
for uh Stanford alumni with you yes sir
good to help you on yeah yeah go Bears
go Bears here we go here we go you can
have the ax okay you play for the ax in
football you can have the ax we'll keep
the World Series runs going exactly
um you know
not too often a player gets to take a
no-hitter that deep into the game and
you're early in your career
yeah that I haven't you know this is my
really my first full uh
full full first full crack at a Big
League season you know last year I was
up but um obviously with the shortened
year didn't really get the full
experience but this year kind of going
through the ups and downs of a normal
full season you know it's I've gone
through my bumps this year but you know
I've been fortunate enough to make some
adjustments and be able to
to hold my own and pitch for a pitch as
well as I can but to be able to do uh to
have a star like I I just had you know
everything's kind of clicking and it was
kind of ironic because of the start
before that it was probably my worst
start of my career I didn't make out of
the second inning got hit around pretty
good but uh just be able to bounce back
like that is uh you know something I
pride myself on and you know that's
that's how it's going to be sometimes in
this game sometimes you just don't have
your best stuff and you just got to
grind through it and find your find your
way uh through your starts and through
your outings
well I really I appreciate what you say
there you're coming off your worst start
of your young career and that shows such
great resiliency to come out and have
that type of game and really everything
for you was working the breaking ball
the change up was just uh dialed in the
fastball even had a little extra umph
maybe a little bit of something from
that previous start for you what is what
what do you consider your strengths as a
pitcher when it comes to those
individual pitches yeah uh you mentioned
the change up that's probably my bread
and butter
um
went Maryfield is toast at third nice
throw from Martine Maldonado I mean this
team can really run not easy to catch
with Maryfield hasn't happened very
often this season he had the one out
double and then caught stealing for just
the third time this year he has 37
stolen bags second best in baseball
yeah he can he can still bags pretty
easily but you mentioned yeah the the
bread and butter has always been my
change up
um
you know it's I've been hurt on a little
bit this year leaving too many you know
kind of elevated middle of the Zone but
you know when it's working it's working
and then being able to to add the
curveball to the mix
um as good as it's been especially
recently and then moving the fastball
around I'm not gonna you know blow
anybody blow anybody away with uh with
Velo or anything like that but just
moving around the fastball obviously
having a good changeup helps that
fastball play up a little bit but that's
that's really my game you know mixing
and matching I'm using the change up
especially I face a lot of right-handed
hitters and you know when I'm going
through lineups there are a lot of
righties in there well we didn't have
much time for you Chris here I'll sneak
one in real quick before we hit the
break from Sports gaming Universe
pitcher player you looked up to most
growing up just the name Clayton Kershaw
nice I love it well quick inning there
Chris we really enjoyed the combo let's
do it again soon okay thanks for the
time appreciate it guys thank you thanks
Chris Royal starter Chris bubitch with
us as the Royals strand well eventually
had Maryfield added third no score for
your mid three
he just smokes it
forget about it
great baseball right there and that one
's good that ball is crushed
and he's gonna do it
strike three
that was a great play
[Music]
I talked about his Fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
something like this is what they came
for
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
there oh boy
uh-huh sure I believe you
oh sick nobody know here's the Royals
nobody
nobody
tell him wait he's miked up all day in
the Hit YouTube show play lad will have
even more of that beautiful content and
we'll have much more for you from to hit
wit the two-time All-Star the second
baseman he plays every day for Kansas
City and he's our man with the
microphone today on YouTube Mike Minor
here in the home third against Myers
Maldonado and Altuve do up for Houston I
really love how we make up the players
each week you just get a little flavor
and it's Unique from each player but the
conversations that Whit Maryfield has I
mean he's got jokes
oh he's good
plays hard out there all the time
obviously has a good feel for the
personalities of the guys around him on
Mickey Lopez saying oh you're adding the
Flair to it when it it's pretty Max
effort type catch but he's messing with
him a little bit
for our YouTube viewers ideally what
you're looking for is a guy that forgets
he's miked up oh that's when he gets
really good
kind of like it goes around him forget
that he's miked up yeah that's what you
really want kind of like a broadcaster
forgets he's like Mike though we're live
that's for O'Hearn
Myers is retired Maldonado coming up our
first poll is complete the potential
career Milestone you're most looking
forward to Mickey who's really the man
of the moment just hit his 500th home
run now he's chasing 3 000 hits and he
eats up most of this pull 47 percent say
we're looking for Mickey
I think it's a good one to look for
3 000 hits is a unique threshold to get
to and then to do it with the power that
he's already mad he's already matched
with 500 home runs pretty incredible
stuff
one of the best right-handed hitters of
all time and probably one of the better
dudes to talk to on the field I mean
he's a great conversation and friendly
as heck one of the questions I always
get who did you fear the most who did
you have a good success against and
Miggy doesn't fall into either of those
I didn't fear him I'd have great success
either but one of the most fun guys to
pitch against
um you know he's one of those guys he's
complimenting you on your pitches when
you throw a good pitch in the dirt he'll
look good too much nice pitch and he
took a nice take and you know someone
reached out to me the other day said did
you give up any home runs to making and
of course I and every other pitch that's
ever faced him that's a long list but
but what uh one of my greatest memories
was him in Kansas City in 12. he secured
the triple crown and he came off the
field our fans you know great fans in
Kansas City gave him a standing ovation
and he gave me chills like you know
we're on the top step clapping for him
and so yeah the 500 is big and to see
the fans here voting for three thousand
it is fun to applaud Mickey he's fun to
move yes very easy to root for yep
props to the fans north of the Border
too in Canada same thing for Mickey I
mean really did an excellent job with
the Ovation for him the appreciation
of what he's done for this game
Maldonado smashes one for the Crawford
boxes and Beyond
Houston's on the board first thanks to
maldi his 10th of the season
well he got his fastball ahead in the
count middle middle and I didn't miss it
it's probably feeling pretty good after
cutting down Whit Merrifield a third
base and all of a sudden he's back at
the plate and he does get that pitch to
drive 10th home run of the season for
Martine Maldonado
how many times do you see it guy throws
out a tough base runner at third and
hits a home run to the Crawford box yup
great play on the field feeling good at
the bat at the plate Let it Fly
he's five for 13 in his career against
Mike Minor
top of the gauntlet Jose Altuve who
popped out first time around blumber did
you know ahead of time guys that you
were successful against oh yeah
yeah I didn't have a chance to well my
list was a little bit shorter than most
guys so I knew exactly who I could get
after but uh there were certain moments
in my career where I knew I was going to
be starting with a particular team in a
particular picture on the mound that's
pulled down the line if it's fair it's
um it's a foul ball
probably was going to hit off the wall
and deep left he didn't hook it so much
Jose Altuve now with two strikes against
him but suddenly
the Astros seeing Mike Miner now second
time through the order feeling it later
[Applause]
this one's pulled on the ground for
Rivera
two down we did see the full arsenal
already
first time through from Mike Minor it's
not like he was just riding one or two
pitches I mean the Astros really make
you work and we're seeing that evidence
second time around where they can really
punish you now you know you think back
to some great lineups that you faced
that's the grind of the Astros you can't
come in here and establish fastball and
just work it and save your breaking
balls for the second third time through
but he's had to work through the first
time he's got to work through the second
and the third if he gets to it so
um you know Hallmark of a good hitting
club like you said
Diaz goes after the first pitch
and that's Mary fields and that's the
inning Martine Maldonado in the nine
spot strikes big and he's done it before
against Mike Minor nice success against
the Royals starter and he Powers up in a
huge way off the facing behind the
Crawford boxes admiring
Houston cracks the ice first it's one
ZIP
[Applause]
[Music]
heart is palpitating yes
oh two from minor to Tim Anderson and
minor
yeah that was
that was a pinata swing from Tim
Anderson if there are fun-sized Milky
Ways falling out in Kansas City we know
why
[Music]
[Applause]
but it drops in Fair territory another
2-2 to Brinson Brown ball to Third
shift out of the box frustrated Spike
has been into the ground and crossed him
up he's gonna come back and catch his
legs
file back it's us oh got it yes
I wonder if I can get this you did it
what do we got I can't believe it
oh whoa no way we caught that moment no
way look at him like
foreign
we're into the fourth and we're checking
out some unique components of ballparks
across the country we like the train
here in Houston it was just on a ride
after Martin Maldonado went long that's
really cool have you ever been in the
pool in Arizona either of you you have
Jeremy I have oh yes I shagged from the
swimming pool out in Arizona and I
caught a Fly ball from the swimming pool
that's epic yep right in the middle of
batting practice the Wright photo looks
back uh forget who it was I was like is
that Jake that's out on the swimming
pool
roof was open it was a perfect storm
yeah Jeff have you been on the train out
there I have not been on the train our
Sideline Girl Julia Morales has been up
there and she was up there for I think
two home runs so she got to ring the
bell and do the whole home run enjoyment
process with the train I have not but I
have been on Bernie Brewer's slide and
didn't like it one bit I'm not a Heights
guy but getting up to that thing and the
uh the platform it's on is a graded
floor so you can see through the bottom
yeah I'm not doing that again I'd stick
to the Coca-Cola bottle at Oracle yeah
that's why it's more friendly yes
because I too have been on the Bernie
Brewer side and the fact that he just
swings on it and launches down yeah you
know you were probably calling like
myself just like I was [ __ ] on the
rail the entire way everybody was
laughing at me
Salvador Perez unloads on that pitch
from Lance McCullers Jr almost the same
spot as Maldonado he goes big both
catchers on either side with home runs
one a piece that's number 34 on the
season for salvi he muscles up well
we've talked about it in the pregame he
is on Pace to become just the sixth
catcher to hit 40 home runs in this
history game I mean consider that for a
second
and just crushed it laid right into it
got his pitched didn't miss it
you know what I think is most impressive
about Salvador Perez is we see that
fastball up over the plate that he gets
to
is the fact that he's doing it at
Kauffman Stadium that is not a hitter
friendly ballpark you really have to
drive the baseball to get it out of
there and we saw the spray chart in the
open he's not just doing it to the pool
side he's doing it to Center he's doing
it to write just a remarkable hitter in
what he's been able to do and adjust
like you said his swing to this modern
day game where everybody's pumping 95
miles an hour you're so you're so
correct on that to do it in that
ballpark it was a luxury for me as a
pitcher to be there for as many starts
as I as I got to make in Kaufman but
he's doing it to all parts and then
talking with him yesterday I got a
chance to see him he talked about just
the the way he's worked with the hitting
coaches and he's tireless you have to
understand he works every single day in
the winter when he had Tommy John's
surgery in uh in 2019. you better
believe he was working on everything and
he comes back into Sam Hinton like he
has the past two years it doesn't
surprise me but two Bay plays a nice opt
there from benintendi and puts him away
one down in the fourth you saw salvi
already with the instant dig me video
look
I'm just checking out the tablet to see
how far it went
give us blumber what was our stat cast
numbers on that thing what was our angle
and our exit below the exit dealer was
101.9 The Distance was 379 so Martin
Maldonado actually beat him he hit his
394. counts the same obviously but if
we're really breaking things down well
he'll be in the weight room an extra 10
minutes if he hears the broadcast
would you be surprised if I said it only
got we would only get out of 28 of 30
ballparks really yeah it's always a fun
one too it would not have gotten out of
Globe Life field or PNC Park
new Texas Rangers stadium up north Globe
Life Field
they do say I heard a broadcast not too
long ago and they said that most
spacious left field is out in PNC in
Pittsburgh yeah you haven't had a chance
to play there I did play there okay
because it is pretty but I hit the left
center field Gap I hit my double that
game to right field oh smart hitting you
know what you're doing
or did you just get beat
I closed my eyes and swung and there was
a noise and then I looked at right field
and he took two steps in slipped and
went over his head for my second career
hit beautiful so it's beautiful
not much of a hitter helps your Ops huh
that's how you hit big league pitching
kids close your eyes and swing
let's get back to pitching the kids
that's right
mccollers has two strikes on Dozier who
keeps his at-bat alive
we've talked about this slider that
McCullers has been throwing and he
throws it 50 of the time to right-handed
hitters and so you know Full Count he
struck out a guy earlier on the Full
Count slider he's going to throw it at
any point in time but it's just a
sweeper and it just it just disappears
for the right hand and hit her a lot of
times
foreign
how incredible is it to implement a
pitch in the middle of your career in
spring training and suddenly it's your
best pitch that very same season as
statcast powered by Google cloud is
hooking us up with some of the elite
numbers from the slider and look at
Dozier go another hit same spot as he
did in the second
Great Piece of hitting right there not
not trying to do too much with two
strikes and that's what the Royals do
they want to put into play they want to
force you to make a play and uh that
slider left up over the plate so it's a
little bit easier for him to do than one
of those sweepers off the dish away from
him
but uh but you're right
inventing pitches and there's some guys
that are really good at helping like
James Shields is one of my favorite
teammates he was a guy that could help
you develop a pitch and he did iTune in
2014 he helped me throw a cutter which
was really helpful down the stretch for
me and it was a pitch I went from never
throwing to a pitch I threw maybe 10 to
15 times a game and so you know if you
have the mindset and you know these
pictures we're athletes and so you can
learn things mid-season or off season
and do big things and so mccollar
certainly and you look at him he's got
the build comes from a rich lineage his
dad played in the big leagues and so you
know it doesn't surprise me they can
learn it but you're still impressed by
the fact that it's become such a good
weapon for you
initially pitching coach Brent Strom
said hey it's a new toy let's not get
carried away with it and then eventually
you watch it over a few starts you're
like go for it do whatever you want I
think that's exactly how I played out
they're like hey it'll be kind of cute
to throw it out there every once in a
while because you know you take Brent
strong at his word he's not going to lie
to you at all he's going ah it's just
kind of a new toys tinkering with and
all of a sudden it was Wipe Out the
first couple of starts and then he just
got on that thing and got a better feel
for it and it just became devastating
but to hold hitters too
139th batting average overall on that
pitch throughout this deep in the Season
22 starts in says a lot about what he's
able to do with that pitch
it would be nice to add a pitch into
your repertoire that you are going to
give up hits on so he's already an
All-Star and then you the All-Star adds
another pitch for a hitter you know when
you first saw Lance you could go okay
I've got
Runners going and he is out
Maldonado did it again
he catches Hunter Dozier this nicknames
the machete cutting Runners down 12th
time this season salvi's done it 11
times on the year we are seeing a true
battle of catchers behind the dish a
strike him out of O'Hearn and then
gunning down Hunter Dozier going after
second base the Royals like to go after
bases as much as any team in baseball
but today Martine Maldonado has their
number
hooray with the catch and the tag
Fireball review in the live game
commentary section put it best
showing off to
off
today
[Music]
anyone who met Sandeep dollywall during
his 10 years with the sheriff's
department will tell you he was one of a
kind he was Houston's First Sikh Deputy
worked Around the Clock during Hurricane
Harvey
and even went to Carlos correa's native
Puerto Rico to help win a devastating
hurricane hit there
knowing that he helped people here in
Houston after Hurricane Harvey and
knowing that he helped people in Puerto
Rico after Hurricane Maria that was the
main reason I wanted to go and uh show
his family my respects and and be able
to meet them in late September the 42
year old was murdered making a traffic
stop soon after Correa asked the
sheriff's department if he could visit
dollywall's family I had three kids and
uh I just wanted to go over and say hi
and and make sure that they knew that
they had this city support we did in
return they gave him
perspective you're like wow I'm going
over four I'm complaining about it and
there's a lot of people out there that
have it a lot harder than me I mean so
it makes you appreciate more what you
have and it makes you it makes your
perspective a little different
[Applause]
one per side bottom four in Houston
Texas Michael a Taylor and the Kansas
City Royals back on defense Mike Minor
on the mound and Yuli guriel Jordan
Alvarez and Carlos Correa do up here in
the home fourth Julio for one with a
strikeout
it's the two catchers striking big
Maldonado and Perez solo home runs
that's the story and that is smacked and
twisting foul
also the arms so far today from the
catchers unbelievable right really nice
power arms accurate arms behind the
plate
Brielle up the middle there's Mary field
well clearly after last last series in
Kansas City where they ran you know
Castro I think had a couple uh a couple
of uh yeah but you know the Royals ran
successfully last week so clearly
they're much more prepared and so we
gotta we gotta shut down the running
game which for the Royals really puts a
crink in their offense but they're
they've made some adjustments they have
and you know what was interesting about
that series that they had in Kansas City
in those four games Martin not only
caught two of those games Jason Castro
caught the other two I'm not sure what
the reasoning was behind it but I think
the adjustment in this series at home
against Kansas City knowing go ball
there it goes Jordan Alvarez
muscles up it's 2-1 Astros
26 on the year Flex
[Applause]
that's the scary part of Jordan Alvarez
in this ballpark
even though it looked like you fought
that pitch off it still jumped off the
bat at 107.3 miles an hour so that was
pretty much a laser beam out the left
but if this young man can figure out go
into left field in this ballpark it is
frightening
well you you start doing things like
that and you start thinking about people
like Big Poppy who exactly you could
just you just could take any pitch he
wanted to left field at Fenway but to
try to bust him hard in which is a great
comp it's a great comp so I mean early
in his career but but if he can continue
to learn to do that and Trust in left
field here at Minute Maid you're right
the amount of damage he'll be able to do
well I think the trust is a great word
for trust in those hands let that ball
get deep because I think David Ortiz may
have had a little bit of an issue with
that also but once he figured it out
his next level All-Star DH for the rest
of his career Correa pulled ball gobbled
up by Robert he's done a nice job at the
Hot Corner
when left on left you've got to keep
that front shoulder closed and yard on
Alvarez actually has better numbers as
far as batting average is concerned
against left-handed pitching this season
but a lot of it is because he keeps that
front side closed for so long and his
head stays so still you can see him
right there just reenacting keep that
head still keep the weight back and when
you recognize let it go it's not that
hard guys just do it just like this
that's what he's telling them you just
need big broad shoulders keep them
Square no big deal anyone can do it yeah
just be nice to walk up there with an
adonis-like frame and be able to do that
bregman second at-bat of the day
he liked the first pitch back in the
second popped out in foul ground
not sure how our YouTubers are on
listening on this game but I'm a big
shoe fan and I'm noticing something
right now with gregman did he switch
shoe companies
because I'm seeing black and he always
wore White
and I have the Adidas I'm not sure
yeah look he's got so he's got Nikes on
right there's an old Huaraches and uh
those things look like Old Faithful oh
those look like Bagwell they got those
out of bagwell's uh line back in the day
yeah um which tells me he's probably
switching to Nike and they haven't made
him a beautiful custom one yet
um and so maybe he's wasted a matter of
time but that's interesting because I've
always you know I always pay attention
to sneakers so we got this day and age
too in the in the game there's so much
personality these guys are able to go
out there and have different shoe colors
as opposed to when we were playing oh
yeah
you could have been wearing pink shoes
and the whole thing oh man
bregman hard contact right center field
and he's in business
it's a base hit with two outs in the
fourth
it's got to feel good for Alex getting
back on the board
[Music]
it's got to be the shoes
and one of my favorite was was to make
Customs you know there's there's custom
fleets there's guys that paint them up
all different uh guys around the country
that'll paint them my favorite though is
to send them to to get a spike put on a
shoe I've done that a couple times did
you do it as well well I was playing in
Montreal and wearing a normal Spike on
the quote-unquote turf they had up there
was miserable okay so I sent in a couple
of pair like basketball shoes with my
spikes and they attach them to the
tennis shoe how did you find the guy to
do that because it took me a couple
years to figure that out there was just
somebody internally in our equipment
room who knew of a guy that knew of a
guy and being on being playing on the
surface we were at more guys were doing
it so the information was a little more
available no it's so fun because then
you can it's a lot easier to customize a
shoe and put a cleat on it than it is to
customize a cleat which is what all
players want you know you always want
your player Edition and they're just so
few of them yep and so uh yeah that's
why I see the black shoe it makes me
think he's probably waiting for his
player Edition and so he's wearing a
little I'll be curious to ask him
because he has earlier in the year he
had a white shoe a little more flash to
it but these seem like a little bit of a
throwback the alternative is we just hit
him with the bus he's still an Adidas
athlete and he's wearing the Nike shoe
and everything else and he's going to
come out for us so that's the
alternative high risk High reward today
on the broadcast yes
that misses wide to Tucker a ball in the
strike
sure his agent is trying to get one of
our numbers right now
[Laughter]
my Nike reps me on the back the Adidas
reps are trying to would you wear
bluntly everything anybody who was
giving I was taking I wasn't able to
make the choice
and I knew guys that would do that would
black everything out
gloves especially a lot of guys blacked
out gloves and switched to Rollins or
Wilson and Mizuno or so many options as
far as yeah but they'd black him out
once they kind of made some change there
so yep anyway sorry Alex if we're
getting in trouble but welcome back nice
piece of hitting right there
and Kyle Tucker's back he flew out to
center field first trip
I mean Dusty said about bregman I just
don't know what he's going to look like
we haven't seen him in a couple months
well he looks pretty good
looks like he's back
miners 2-1
it's two and two well if the baseball
gods are watching this game there's
going to be a ball in the Gap right here
and you're gonna have to see him run
first to third first to home see if he
can test that thing those are always
going to be the questions how well does
he go first to third can he score from
first
and then it's going to be how when he
wakes up tomorrow how does he feel
tomorrow
all great questions
a question he's been asking on social
media is do you like your salsa spicy as
well or do you like it hot or more mild
what is this salsa called Frankie bomb
salsa break bomb salsa
yeah he got together with a restaurant
from his hometown in New Mexico
at their version of salsa approached him
and said hey I want to put my name and
my label on this thing what kind of
adjustment can we make I think it's
tequila infused if I'm remembering
correctly
I have enjoyed
I have enjoyed Brady bomb salsa it's
quite nice
tequila and lime there you go
he's moving and he'll head back to First
that one's fouled off by Tucker Jeremy
Guthrie is not just your analyst today
he is also your marketing specialist
well you've been I know Jeremy's been
impressed with what Alex has done on
social media yes yeah well I they gave
so I'm here because Jeremy ifelt called
and said I can't make the game there's a
YouTube game would you like to do it so
there was no other Jeremy available
there was no other Jeremy available but
he gave me three weeks heads up and so
I've just been reaching out to all the
companies trying to see where I can get
a cut you know for this broadcast so I'm
I got a few more that we can better and
move if we can force a few more in here
we're going to be good off goes bragman
and Tucker is down on strikes to end the
fourth
some highlights for the Astros in this
inning bregman with the base hit is
first since June 10th but before that
your Don Alvarez going deep and giving
Houston a 2-1 Edge
shut your eyes and be ready to bail out
if that can't intimidate you nothing
can't I can remember talking to players
in other teams before they talk about
how players get jriitis you saw a lot of
cases of Jr itis you know if somebody
woke up with a stiff neck and somebody
else had a fever or a cough or something
like that they didn't want to be out
there big guys I mean Hall of Fame guys
they didn't want to play they took their
days off when J.R was pitching
at six eight and over 250 pounds Jr was
in fact an imposing presence on the
mound
and there was something else just a bit
scary about J.R Richard but he is so
strong he's got the he's got the most
ferocious handshake uh that I've ever
encountered he's just got Mammoth hands
as a PR guy at the time we had him had
him pose for a picture I think holding
eight or nine Baseballs in one hand he
has eight he put nine balls in his hand
thinking he went like that and we took
the picture made a poster out of it once
we saw that everybody tried to see how
many balls they could hold in their hand
and I think I could hold three or four I
don't think I could hold seven golf
balls in my hand
I had two pitches
fast and faster at my best I can throw
it through a car wash and never get it
wet
[Music]
hey each week we're giving some love to
our YouTube content creators featured in
our live game commentary section they do
a great job in there today our creator
Spotlight Shines on Sports gaming
universe and you can see specializes in
sports video game simulations I watched
a few this past week you know what games
going on he'll tell you how it looks
simulated MLB NFL NBA NHL so we say
hello to him first pitch swinging it's
Michael a Taylor and he bounces out one
down quickly in the fifth let's check in
with Brett Dolan hey Brad hey Scott it's
been a tough year for Astros Legends
they lost Jimmy the toy Cannon win then
Bob Watson the bull passed away but most
recently back on August the 4th James
Rodney J.R Richard passed away now Dusty
Baker said I did not have a lot of
pitchers that were friends but Jr was
one of those and he also called Jr the
toughest guy he's ever faced now Dusty
had one home run against Jr but
basically one of them every three times
he went head-to-head he struck out
against it and he joked it felt like J.R
was throwing from 50 feet when everybody
was thrown from 60 with those long arms
and long legs and just a quick aside I
saw Jr back in April in town he was
working with some young pitchers 10 11
year old kids that were excited to be
with him and guys that took everything I
had not to walk up to these young men
and say do you realize when he was at
his best there was no one better and
there certainly wasn't anybody more
intimidating than Jr
one of the all-time greats in being
around him having him inducted in the
Astros Hall of Fame and getting a chance
to talk to him everything that Brett
said was correct
gotta love the game and he loved being a
Houston Astro but the stories that
surround him are what are really
impressive Nolan Ryan Enos Cabell and
some of these other guys that are around
the organization really tell some great
stories about J.R Richard and then every
once in a while we show some video and
we watch guys like Reggie Jackson swing
themselves into the ground trying to
connect with some of the stuff that Jr
had was really remarkable
you know what a line he was one of the
best pitchers in the 70s
Lance McCullers Jr picks up another k
for his fifth of the day Lance has
people spinning into the ground right
now he does
you can make a case he is one of the
best pitchers in the past half decade
maybe that doesn't get as much attention
because of the Innings pitched workload
he did miss some time with Tommy John
surgery after 2018 he was out all of
2019 but the era has been south of four
in five of his first six seasons in The
Bigs
you know the moment I first remember is
the that series that great series the
Royals played against Houston the ALDS
in 2015 and he pitched game four and he
pitched he pitched for masterfully
because they took a 7-3 lead into the
eighth but uh he was so sharp and and to
do it in that moment trying to advance
to the LCS in a you know as a rookie you
could tell he had he had some swag to
him he had confidence and he had and he
had the tools to back it up
fastball in there to cam Gallagher at
95. I think the legendary kind of you
have to see it to believe it on YouTube
moment is 2017 ALCS he Chucks 24
consecutive curveballs to close out the
Yankees and send the Astros to the World
Series it's a roller to Correa and he's
got Gallagher
three up three down it's a nine pitch
inning for Lance McCullers Jr in the
fifth in cruise control Astros up by a
run
all right
foreign
[Music]
key on the mound tonight Royals in
Cleveland nice to have you with us
in there strike ball
drinky drinks at home and a swing and a
miss got him with a fastball and down
goes after and that's three strikeouts
I miss and that's the inning swing and a
miss he struck him out
swing and a miss by sin TSU Chu he's
down on strikes crack up another
strikeout for drinking a swing and a
miss by Peralta so drinky with 10
strikeouts in the first five innings
pushing to the crowd
truck him out and a new season High 11
strikeouts
call strike three that's number 12 swing
and a miss he got him so now Zach is one
away from tying the Royals record
all strike three and the inning is over
what are you going to miss got it Zach
adds his name to the Royals record book
with 15 strikeouts
[Music]
listen to MLB's podcast to hear the
latest analysis from insiders across the
league and exclusive in-depth interviews
with baseball's biggest stars subscribe
now at mlb.com podcasts the MLB Ballpark
app will complete your next visit to the
ballpark buy and manage game tickets
redeem offers access exclusive content
and much more download the ballpark app
today
we are in Houston Texas this week on
YouTube
MLB's YouTube channel easy to find us
free all day long Royals ass shows
anywhere you're watching
Houston two Kansas City one all homers
so far today solo shots Mike Minor
matching up with Lance McCullers Jr
minor back on for the home Fifth and it
begins with Jake Myers
here's a rookie who was not highly
touted 13th round selection in 2017.
and this year he was not a top 30
Prospect in the organization according
to MLB Pipeline and he said I'll show
them
look at him go so far in his first month
in The Bigs he's been great
he has been great he actually swung
himself onto this big league roster by
doing so well in Sugarland he picks up
another knock
lead off man aboard for Houston
[Music]
it took work too Jeff it was listening
to Julia Morales on the Astros TV
broadcast the other day say worked on
strength added 10 15 pounds of muscle
timing exit Velo getting the ball in the
air more because he's a guy who knows
how to make contact and it's all coming
together for him right now
timing couldn't have been better for him
either you know he the reason he's here
is he basically forced the trade of
their everyday center fielder and mile
straw going to Cleveland where they
picked up Philip Mayton and put him in
the bullpen
but with Chaz McCormick going on the
injured list with the hand injury is
allowing this young guy to have the
opportunity to go out in center field
and prove his worth and he's done a very
good job like you're saying Scott not
just with the batting average but he's
actually put up some pretty good
production numbers
I like the swing short compact I agree
nice and quiet but there's plenty of
thump behind it
25 years old he's on from Maldonado who
homered in the third
from Omaha Nebraska
College World Series City
foreign to Maldonado you know what's
great about Jake Myers being from Omaha
Nebraska going to the University of
Nebraska Jake's father was the assistant
coach at the University of Nebraska when
Darren erstead was a football player and
baseball player at Nebraska and
eventually when Jake Myers was attending
the University of Nebraska Darren ersted
was the head coach of Nebraska so
there's some strong ties between the
ersted family and the Myers family
just a little bit of History
full circle it's amazing
well Donato in the air got under this
one
benintendi racing in to make the catch
let's finish up our second poll let's
see how everyone did I'm curious on this
one I wonder which one won we're looking
for
what you think stands out and some of
the best ballparks in the country Astros
fans showing up hey Jeff
that's what I like to see a lot of Astro
fans watching this game there's some
good ones around the league but the
Astros home run train
pulling out to a big lead
I think if it would have specified blue
water fountain in Kansas City it might
have got more votes
hey Brett what else do you have for us
on Jake Myers who's on first well I had
a chance to ask Jake today about playing
for Darren erstad and blumber does it
come as any surprise to you that Jake
said Darren was by far the most intense
person he's ever been around
that does not Shock me one bit
Darren herstead
I was here in Houston with Darren ersted
and was towards the end of his career
and
ersted myself Mark Loretta and Brad
Ausmus we were the utility guys we were
the bench guys
and we're getting ready game one
and Darren ernstead tears a shoelace
tying his shoelaces he's not in a
starting lineup
and it's just son of a
and he snaps and I'm going I look up and
I'm like are you okay Darren what's
wrong man he's like my shoelace broke
I'm like why are you breaking your
shoelace tying up for a game that we're
not probably not going to be in the game
until the fifth or sixth
he just turns beat red doesn't say a
word go gets another pair of shoelaces
and I proceed to watch him lace up his
shoes
veins were popping out of his head he
was in full Flex mode as he cinched down
each and every lace before he got to the
knot it was unbelievable he was a great
teammate loved him
one and two dial tube so did he have bad
memory maybe a shoe fell off when he was
like I was wondering yeah so he's got to
tighten him extra I wasn't about to peel
that scalp off I'm gonna let him deal
with that by himself plumber keep in
mind he said once his wife and him did
not talk for three days over gimme putts
on the golf course oh wow there you go
three days no
OK station over an argument on whether
or not they could take that putt or not
I've seen Darren putt
I could see why he wanted the Gimme
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's one and two in Altuve
this is Miner matching up against
Houston for a second consecutive start
he lost last week five in a third three
runs went 94 pitches he's at 71 here in
the fit
what's the loan loss for Kansas City in
that four game set last week
that's the one weird thing about this
first place ball club in Houston
the Astros
have at times sunk down to their
competition just to be real and we've
seen that evident especially when facing
the American League Central this season
they played much better against the top
of the division versus the bottom
foreign
that is a foul ball it's it's really
been one of the tough things to explain
too because
being able to call the Astros on a
nightly basis you know you start to see
what's going on you see things unfold
but you're always trying to pick out
what they could adjust or how things are
happening
and the numbers aren't that much
different from wins and losses it's just
a matter of when those hits are being
got against them they lost some games
early on because the bullpen was unable
to secure some victories but now it
should be a little bit different but for
whatever reason they just have not
been able to put down some teams that
will have that sub 500 record they
played extremely well against teams
above that 500 record but what I heard
of stat the other day about the Kansas
City Royals playing 18 and 15 against
first place teams that's saying
something for the future of Kansas City
I was just going to say that on the on
the flip side of that equation yeah the
Royals have played well all year long
and I know a lot of that's been against
the White Sox they've played very well
against a very tough White Sox team but
four and two now against the Astros and
looking to take this one again to to
take this series
it just it speaks to their resilience
this is a great club with great
leadership which and uh and salvi and
guys like Mike Minor these are guys that
have been around there they understand
the game and they take a real
professional approach
Pro a b from Altuve now working a full
boat but we showed you Kansas City 18
and 14 against current first place ball
clubs
and I would say some of it has to do
with the brand of baseball that they
play it stands out at this point
no I completely agree you know there's
two different Dynamics at play here as
far as offenses are concerned and that
the speed and aggressiveness and the
pressure that the Kansas City Royals put
on defense is it's a lot of fun to watch
the Astros do it a little bit different
way with high on base and high slug
I'm loving this that bad this is the
ninth pitch this is eight coming up
and you see minor making great pitches
and trying to get this double play
because the Royals have turned a lot 123
double plays and you can see them
working for it mixing and match it in
and out
it's in the air
well he missed up on that one but he got
the result he's looking for getting a
tough hitter out there did you watch
Whit Maryfield by any chance
he was watching altuvet
the faltuve is not running to first base
I bet you with Maryfield drops that and
tries to go for the double play heady
player heady friend you've got to be
able to do that but I was watching Whit
he was staring down Altuve
I love it he's talking to him now or
he's commuting to communicating over
there great news he's miked up today
yeah that's beautiful can you hear us we
should ask him about that I wish
I didn't get the pleasure you know to to
be around him a whole bunch but just
watching him he's fun to watch and he's
just a grinder uh thinks the game plays
the game hard every single day
here you go blumber yeah he's taking a
peek at the runner from home play
because if Altuve is not running and
he's gonna be like ah he's like dang it
didn't fall for it which is yep
some fun players like that Miguel Tejada
is one that reminds me of a guy that's
always kind of thinking and
wanting to do the you know the smart
play
Diaz flies out to benintendi so no runs
for the Astros in the fifth they're
clinging to a one-run lead over KC great
season series that wraps up today
between these two
[Music]
we are ready for baseball it's the 2015
World Series
[Applause]
[Music]
up two games to nothing
the Royals hope to go up three games to
one over the Mets
that's in the right field that Ball's
gonna get down
the Run scores
[Applause]
[Applause]
the Kansas City Royals a chance to
clinch their first championship in 30
years Runner coming home and Hosmer
scores to tie the game
swinging a line drive facing left field
and the Royals lead 3-2
strike three call it's over
they've done it the Royals are World
Series champions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I really get the best jump but huh I
said I didn't get the best jump there
but I've gotten worse jokes I should
have gone first one but I thought he
might inside move yeah true
words from Whit Mary field who leads off
the sixth he loves going after Third
Base he does it better than anyone in
the sport he's always talking baseball
Jeremy I actually know him pretty well
called his games in the Cape Cod
Baseball League when he was with the
chathamays and you could see the term
that I think summed it up even back then
for him when he was playing in South
Carolina
baseball player you know the definition
of just someone that does a little bit
of everything always talking about the
game and that's why we're fortunate to
have him miked up today for us on
YouTube
he's one for two with a double
I think it's great you know being able
to call games on a regular basis is a
lot of fun but being able to do these
YouTube games and be able to expand that
that that variety and that audience a
little bit and get guys might uh is
really special and they picked a great
one in Whit Maryfield because you're
going to hear you know he gets thrown
out he's going to be disappointed but
he's going to talk about why he got
thrown out what happened on that play
and gives those fans maybe a little more
insight into what he was thinking
and he's played in 433 straight that is
by far the longest current streak
it was interesting what uh what Mike
Matheny said before the game too that
just
you know
he's never asked for it he just grinds
he still can he shows he's so well
conditioned that he can endure the 433
and he's productive extremely productive
day in and day out down on strikes
McCullers with his sixth K of the
afternoon uh-oh up here we go we're on
that threshold let's get that bed MGM
line going again just to remind everyone
six and a half is your number and I'm
also looking at the pitch count there it
is for Lance McCullers at 71 that means
he's got some fuel left
he's highly efficient but how about the
fact that he got Whit Merrifield to
swing and Miss on that slider kind of
speaks to how good that pitch is because
wit doesn't strike out a lot
big big sweeping slider and it's hard
too you know it's it's sweeping across
the dish I don't know how much lateral
movement it has but you know yeah
multiple feet it looks like and it's
still in the upper 80s when you were
pitching did you think angles because
it's a hitter I'm just thinking he's a
right-handed hitter how do I attack that
slider do I let it travel and hopefully
I can stay on it and go the other way or
do I try and get out in front of it and
try and get in front of it and clip it
but in order to do that I've got to get
so far in front of home plate that it
almost puts me in a terrible position to
even attack that slider as it continues
to move away from it
you're probably given us too much credit
we're just trying to fill ones that move
a lot and miss the strikes that's what's
crazy though I love talking about that
because I want to you know I wish I
would have known that back then because
I gave I gave pictures all the credit
I'm like dude this guy is filthy and now
I'm sitting up here and being able to
slow the game down a little bit and see
things like that and I switch hit too so
I luckily didn't have the opportunity to
face some of these sliders so I always
imagine how how some of these hitters
would attack that well I think that's
what you know he's he's starting it on
the dish and clearly the hitters are
seeing it on the dish because they offer
it pitches that are ending up well in
the left-handed batter's box and so
that's what you're ultimately trying to
do is you're trying to put it in a place
that looks tempting and finishes out of
the Zone look like a strike out of the
hand and there's certain times where
maybe you're a head in the count and you
do want it to be at the bottom part of
the zone so they don't and so it's not
necessarily swinging a Miss But A guy
uses a good slider to get a double play
so maybe you're behind and they kind of
like you know what I want this to be a
hittable Pitch I don't want them to
swing and Miss but I want them to get a
little piece and not hit it hard and so
there are different things you might
factor in that way
dribbler foul
with Lance though I just I mean it just
has so much big movement you'll see the
ones that that he doesn't finish off
super well hang out in the zone and he's
getting he's got a couple outs on those
and the other ones are just swing and
Miss like they're they're there's
Wipeout type sliders for him and not a
ton of depth which you know a lot of
pitching coaches will work with you on
getting that depth but if it's going to
move that much laterally you're probably
okay yeah clearly
all six strikeouts today from breaking
balls yeah we said at the starter that
would be one of his keys right he's got
to spin it which he always does and he's
been consistent with that yep and it's
changed his pitching profile he used to
be a reverse splits guy he was better
against left-handed hitters
now he's better against right he's the
slider has been the difference of course
that's fascinating when I saw that I
mean it's not fascinating it makes sense
that he's tougher on righties now but to
know how tough he was on lefties in the
past and he still is there's still been
you know hitting 247 or so coming into
the game against him
it just that's a nice rapid form to be
able to to attack lefties that well and
have that much success a base on balls
for Nikki Lopez Salvador Perez big bad
hitter in the three spot for the Royals
homered last trip and Whit Maryfield
said this
it's like Barry Bonds now he just walks
in his homers
sounded some kind of special huh I never
caught so I don't know like
what it feels like
August 26th with your legs but I imagine
they're pretty heavy
I bet your manager can answer that
question he was talking to Mike Matheny
who was buying the dish for a long time
let's look at the same thing he's
talking to the perfect guy Matheny
catching a ton of games in his career
this guy salvi I mean he is he says he
is as advertised
um 13 14-15 lead baseball and games
caught and like Matheny said refuses to
come out that was one of Mike's concerns
he said coming over he's like how am I
going to manage a guy that never wants
to come out and he had a lot of practice
with Yadi and congrats on his new year
his new one-year deal that you know he
knows about guys that want to play every
day but that's that's who salvi is and
he wants to play every day and then he
said something interesting he said when
he doesn't play or he's not maybe he's
in the DHL like today he still talks to
The Catcher And still talks to the
pitcher that's the epitome of a winner
and of a teammate and a guy that is just
you know who he is
he's a leader he's a great Ambassador
for the sport
plays off a tough pitch but
Mike Matheny just cannot say enough
great things about Salvador Perez a
former catcher appreciating what he does
and he said recently sometimes guys in
markets like this Kansas City kind of
smaller city-wise in the country for a
baseball club they don't get the credit
they deserve
he's number three on the Home Run board
in the American League
yeah he may not go out and get the
national credit that he deserves for
what he does especially for this team
but when you go around the league and
you start talking to guys inside the
game of baseball he has probably got the
one of the greatest peer reviews because
he is such a great player
statcast powered by Google Cloud he's a
seven-time All-Star 2015 World Series
MVP how many parks does it leave 28 you
said out of 30. yep not getting out of
Globe Life up in Arlington and PNC Park
in Pittsburgh
otherwise it was a sure thing
especially here in Houston oh yeah left
field is the spot
Lopez is on salvi takes that one nice
stop by Maldonado
Brett how awesome is Salvador Perez for
Kansas City on a yearly basis well they
love him
and dollars when he was 16.
16 something that got my attention a
couple of days ago he said the most
special thing to watch is the joy he
plays with Lynch said I think it's super
important and a lesson for young guys
like me to see him and know the game's
supposed to be fun
you need the guy that keeps things light
and often it might be your best player
because things are easier for you and
they're having another great year yeah
salvi strikes out there's seven for
McCullers
[Applause]
salvi knew it too he knew it was coming
wanted to try and uh
yeah it was so big it couldn't even
reach it because he's batted well
against the breaking ball this year and
uh just couldn't identified it but
couldn't lay off it couldn't hit it yeah
I mean he he got his with the Home Run
Lance got his with the strikeout right
here on that slider
and that thing can move it moves a ton
and like Jeremy was saying about the
velocity the way it comes out of the
hand it's 87 to 89 miles an hour at
times and it looks like it's jumping out
of the hand like a fastball and if you
don't pick up that spin quick enough
you're not going to take good swings at
it
want to know to Ben and tendy what makes
it extra special to me is that he can
quote Miss with it I've seen quite a few
right over the plate and hitters are
still like nope
well some of those ones you're talking
about that he messes with it almost
looks like he's throwing it at the
right-handed hitter it locks him up and
by the time they lock up and can't pull
the trigger it's breaking back onto the
plane
it's fun to watch
it really is and when he gets in a
rhythm with Martin Maldonado behind the
plate and the ball is coming out of his
hand the way he wants to
it's just a matter of how long before he
strikes a guy out
he got an interesting battle right here
two outs they might put the runner in
motion Lopez is 18 for 18 on the year in
stolen bases and his rookie year last
year only oh for five and so he clearly
he's he's made some adjustments in in
starting to put into action and running
a lot lately
popper
Correa called off by nope he's got it
little tube fakes me out
that'll complete this Lance McCullers Jr
is still on a roll mid six 2-1 Houston
[Music]
gorgeous evening for baseball here in
Minute Maid Park the Astros opening day
and it's 6-1 St Louis Astros have lost
seven in a row Lois scoring team in
major league baseball 15 and 30 is an
ugly start and that's a big hill to
overcome
[Applause]
this game tied 6-6 in the bottom of the
18th inning
[Music]
[Applause]
this ballpark is just ready to erupt
they're down to run one run away the
pitch
lead four to two in the air left field
it pulls his
you know what every single guy in our
ball Club says this is the way it's
supposed to be that game is gone let's
get on to the next game
and the Houston Astros are going to the
World Series for the first time in
franchise history
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's all about you on the MLB game of
the week Live on YouTube we give our
viewers the power to vote for which
standout performer is going to receive
the YouTube player of the game trophy so
stay tuned we'll have bowling options
later and then we'll hand out some
Hardware in the post game show
immediately following the conclusion of
this one in Houston yeah your name goes
on the digital plaque but also on the
actual trophy itself and the players
love it I mean you got your name
engraved it's real comes in the mail and
it's coming up later
early candidates I would say Lance
McCullers Jr Jordan Alvarez as the
deciding Homer at the moment for Houston
Maldonado also with a long ball it's 2-1
Astros
here's Julie guriel
I've been dying to ask blumber about
the transformation of Yuli guriel's
hitting profile you know always a guy
who knows how to make contact all of a
sudden he's spitting at pitches not that
one but it will drop Fifth and into the
seats for a ground rule double
perfectly placed by Julie
so I'm not sure you could throw it out
there much better
[Applause]
and Julie appreciates it jumping into
the stands just a leisurely stroll into
second base doesn't have to use those
old man Wheels to get out there to
second base but yeah he's been very good
he's also been very good at going the
other way this is a little extreme just
sneaking it inside that right field line
in scoring position for Alvarez
number 26 on the season came in the
fourth inning
it's the first runner in scorn position
for Houston today
and this is one of those keys at the
beginning has really been challenged
that has minor this year with runners in
scoring position and so bearing down
here making a good pitch he's been
pitching great you know worked around
aside from the Home Run that's something
that's really hurt him in the two solo
shots but
see if we can keep making making pitches
he has been and uh get something to get
out of this in here
hey bummer what's the difference with
Julie how is he suddenly taking pitches
in his
mid-30s deep into his career
he's he's just kind of gone to school on
the Astro program and you know coming
from Cuba he was paid to be a hitter and
the reason he was with the Houston
Astros was because he was such a good
hitter sprayed the ball all over the
ballpark just got a little little too
aggressive with the swing and would
chase out of the zones not see a lot of
pitches early on in his career here in
the in you know Stateside playing in the
major leagues but really made a couple
of adjustments to his swing just being a
little more upright getting both eyes on
the pitcher seeing the ball better but I
think he started to watch some of the
guys in the lineup the altuvees the
correas the Alex bregmans who laid off
pitches outside the Zone took the walks
when they were given to them and
recognized that when they started to lay
off some of those pitches pitchers had
to get back in the zone and they were
having more hitters counts so Yulie made
it a goal of his in spring training to
be a little more selective it paid off
and when he started the season took his
walks and when he got mistakes he was
hammering him and of course when you try
anything you want to have success doing
it and he had success early on and he's
just run with it and put himself at the
top of you know hitting uh batting
average leaders boards the entire season
that's the thing you'll produce more
walks when you're taking those pitches
outside of the Zone but you'll also
improve your quality of contacts more
often than not because they're swinging
at pitches that you can do damage with
yeah every time he watches set in a new
personal season record which was a lot
of fun to watch
I heard he had some helpers too like
Carlos Perez who went over things and
said you know what would help you just
take a pitch here and there you know
that you can make contact with anything
literally anything
Gallagher and minor wanting to get on
the same page here obviously a big
moment uh that home run earlier by by
Alvarez only the second home run allowed
to a lefty by minor all season long he's
given up 24 uh to right-handers or 23 to
right-hander sorry so obviously Alvarez
tough at bat tough hitter they want to
make sure they're on the same page here
for this big situation
back to minor
well that's a nice result right there a
little 50 foot one hopper doesn't move
the runner
that's a good meeting
Kim Gallagher must be pleased too hey I
said something good absolutely you know
what and you get you give credit to
those catchers because they do see so
much and they are so good I always
respected the veteran catcher that's
been around and knows the hitters and
certainly Gallagher and salving everyone
else in this game seen that type of
Veteran catch him
well being able to trust your veteran
picture too to keep that pitch in a
position where the hitter will get tied
up
one gone for Correa into Center
Taylor will Glide over and make the
catch tagging up his guriel and he's in
there
Taylor's not an easy guy to run off oh
no that's not that's a gutsy play it
leads the league in uh in put outs right
it's from center field he had a couple
of big throw outs in that series back in
Kansas City at home plate
[Applause]
he had one in this series I believe what
was it Monday
yeah you talk about picture velocity
Michael a Taylor is a guy that can get
him below 90s every once in a while too
[Applause]
[Applause]
third a B for bregman today
a lot of the Royals fans will think you
know and remember a lot about Lorenzo
Kane and the kind of the plays he used
to make day in and out and hearing what
Rusty has said about Michael a Taylor he
says you know what it may not be as
flashy but as breaks as reads his speed
his arm wow maybe maybe as good if not
even better than Lorenzo Kane with the
way he's played for them this year
that's a huge conflict it is it really
is nine Outfield assists and you're
right most among center fielders
man a few words but he's talented
fits the Kansas City style well yeah I
think so I think swing wise has been
working to find the swing this year but
defensively he hasn't let it impact that
one bit
I can only imagine what the
communication has been like over the
past couple months between Alex bregman
and the Astros front office and coaching
staff on his anxiousness to return to
this lineup does he like Baseball Jeff
he absolutely loves baseball
he is a guy that if there is optional
batting practice he is taking betting
practice he hits on the field every
single day
and you know a brief conversation with
Dusty earlier in the week when Alex was
out here working out and trying to
figure out the time frame kind of pulls
you off the side Dusty says this guy's
texting me every single day
you know it kind of surprised me a
little bit but it really doesn't when
you think about Alex but he said that he
was getting a text every day he's like
skip I'm ready I'm ready when can I get
back when can I get back and here he is
today's the day 3-1 plays off it's a
strike
[Applause]
out the Zone but announces defense there
haven't been too many pitches up in the
zone that I've seen called frequently
enough to be consistent
but if you're Alex maybe it's another
opportunity to drive in a run
and Miner continues to go right I mean
trying to go inside there 3-1 hitters
count he's still going inside and he's
been successful with that today
he's shown all of his pitches in this a
b
good life on the fastball right beating
the temperature enough right there yeah
beat us in that mystery Zone where you
just you're like I gotta fight this
pitch off yeah and you're hoping you're
falling off instead of put it in play
really has the option here he can go
with the he can go with the fastball in
again and go slider in yep we've seen
him try that a couple times on the full
count as well today
and see what the call is and he's got
that base open also with Kyle Tucker
left-handed hitter on Deck too
but I think he's pretty confident with
his stuff
and on the hands and behind the netting
we'll do it again
have you talked to bregman at all about
the way he chokes up you know I think
young kids or anyone that watches and
it's kind of unique in that he's a small
guy looks like a regular-sized Batman he
chokes up on top of that yeah I think he
enjoys bat control uh he's also a guy
that commands his own but he has talked
about some of the adjustments he's made
since getting the big leagues and one of
them was getting on the plate and
thinking about elevating to the pull
side
so I think the combination of getting on
the plate choking up allows him to use
that Barrel a little more effectively
eighth pitch of the a b is smacked to
left
[Applause]
to left on back and it's off the top of
the wall
Alex bregman's back in a big way with an
RBI double to extend the advantage it's
three to one
well I think Mike Miner knows about that
Barrel as well was trying to stay off it
inside pounding them in Pounding them in
that one just didn't get quite to where
he was hoping and credit Alex bregman
for uh you know making the adjustment in
the at-bat and getting the getting the
barrel to that one
you're right he did take advantage of a
pitch it may be caught a lot more of the
plate than he wanted to but at the same
time Alex had seen a couple of pitches
up a couple of pitches in figured out
the adjustment he needed to make in his
swing to get to one of those pitches
unfortunately he guessed right on the
fastball and got above it to be able to
drive it yeah I like your point there he
saw it enough times that obviously had a
much better chance to catch up to that
last one and uh you know big run right
there for the Astros
first RBI since June 13th 15th double on
the year scores guriel
[Applause]
foreign
first pitch swinging Kyle Tucker going
for center field Taylor back at the
warning track to haul it in
Todd retired some loud contact from the
Astros in the last of the sixth and one
run to show for it it's 3-1 Houston
[Applause]
[Music]
oh there we go baby deep left center
field
Splash and it's over
799 right over the middle he knew it way
before anybody else did and that ball
wasn't walking that had backspin Galore
and it ended up getting wet
there goes wit and it's swung on and
belted deep left center field and gone
10 years to the day that he made his big
league debut
oh there you go Darren
enjoy
Shelby has two home runs tonight he adds
to his career high
and the Royals have the game at four
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
three for Houston one for KC 7th inning
action on YouTube in Houston and our
third poll question of the day here on
YouTube easy to participate it's right
in front of you on your mobile device or
your computer which Royals Prospect
would you most like to see get the call
this year I mean with Junior M.J
Melendez Nick Prado and Jackson Co are
four top 52 technically prospects in
Major League Baseball Kansas City has
something special brewing in the minor
leagues look at six of MLB pipeline's
top 100 prospects are in this
organization right now first pitch swing
in Hunter Dozier to Carlos Correa and
there's your first out in the seventh
Brett Kansas City doesn't have the
record to show for what they've done
this year they've played some really
really tough games against top level
competition but this is just the
beginning of the next winning window
that should be coming for Kansas City in
the next year or two well there's no
doubt about that Scott in fact Baseball
America has Mike matheny's system in the
Kansas City Royals as number three at
Double A Arkansas this year Northwest
Arkansas I probably saw Whit Prado and
Melendez play about 20 times and this
crop is outstanding everybody knows
about Bobby Witt Jr a power hitting
shortstop MJ Melendez is tracing the
minor league home run Crown this year
and a quick aside by the way he's
chasing Griffin conine the son of Jeff
and Melendez his father coaches at FIU
his top assistant is Jeff conine so the
two guys in the same office have their
two sons competing for the minor league
home run Crown but this is a little bit
different September in the sense that
these AAA teams are going to play the
entire month rather than being done on
Labor Day the guys there's a lot of
excitement about what's coming next for
Kansas City
I know Hearn rolls over one Julie's got
it don't ask the Royals front office
about who's coming up next because I
know the fans are screaming if you
follow the Royals for Bobby Witt Jr to
come up he has been nothing short of
their expectations uh they say a very
mature hitter hits for power strong
athletic and so there is a definite
yearning for him to be up but you see
the infield you see that's what I was
just going to ask you where you move
some of these guys and that's a question
I'm sure that uh you know Dayton and the
great uh front office of Kansas City has
asked way more than they want to have to
answer but a good problem to have it is
a good problem to have and that's not
even you don't take into account too
much of the pitchers you know they've
had four starters all drafted in the
first round of the compensation run in
2018 pitching a lot of innings for them
this year and so the future is very
exciting and if you're a Royals fan of
baseball fan what's coming up for them
to build on top of what you see on the
field right now gets people very excited
item that's a credit to everyone over in
the organization what they've done
to add single for Michael a Taylor
Rivera I'm fine if they just kind of
hang out for a little bit Yeah you want
them to marinate longer marinate ripen a
little bit yeah I'm good well you think
about you know those projections for the
Astros and they put you on Sports
Illustrated and they predict the year
and uh and the Royals came through that
Astros team that was rebuilding so you
know maybe on the flip side here the
Royals are looking at the average very
soon there's a team that's a finalized
product and they would like to you know
flip the script again and bring it back
well it's interesting you said because a
lot of these guys being drafted within
the organization that's I think one
thing that's kind of stepped up in the
last couple of years for front offices
is going out and drafting well in the
past it's been all we'll draft some guys
hopefully they turn out but the Astros
did such a good job of drafting you've
got bregman Correa Altuve
Jake Myers these guys you know Kyle
Tucker where you have that good Core
group of guys that you've drafted
developed and nurtured all together and
then you spring start sprinkling in the
free agents all of a sudden you've got a
contended team and it's so easy to
draft after the fact right why don't you
take this guy or that guy and so the
amount of pressure that's on these
organizations truly to Scout and all
that goes into that to grab them and
these this is an example right here
these five guys and they still have
Jackson Kolar who's in the top 100
drafts draft uh top 100 uh prospects
down in AAA but these guys are are
contributing and we're starting to see
him turn the corner really this past
couple of weeks they have pitched
phenomenally and they're growing a lot I
had a chance that road trip the Astros
took to Kansas City to watch Carlos
Hernandez Lynch and singer back to back
to back
I was sold that's a one through three in
most rotations for me and to see them at
24 25 years old really impressive but
it's good to see them cutting their
teeth too getting the experience now
not about you know not a bad situation
the team starts off first place on May
1st they find themselves with the best
record in baseball clearly surprise more
fans than it probably did them I think
they came out with that kind of optimism
but then the struggle and go up and now
a season that you know for some may look
at and say oh it's a Lost season you
know they're fourth place in the
division but they're gaining The
Experience that's going to pay huge
dividends next year and moving forward
yeah they had the league looking out for
them 16-9 to start this season they did
drop 11 in a row but they bounced up and
down this year
well you can go ahead and let the White
Sox run with it for a season yeah but
then you start you start making
adjustments because it's pretty obvious
the White Sox were making a very strong
push and a lot of the anticipation in
the central was to have the Minnesota
Twins pushing
but it ended up being you know with all
the injuries Minnesota had it ended up
with Chicago running away with it
it's a good competition for these guys
to experience and hopefully learn from
and build on moving forward
gotten a Miss from Emmanuel Rivera
McCullers had 97 pitches
here's your AL Central White Sox have
the comfiest lead among first place ball
clubs it's 10 games
could be the last pitch from the Astros
starter
Christian Javier getting warm
we'll do it again
that referral is going to make him work
for it
a couple of Sliders back to back there
behind on the count 3-1 swinging a Miss
Full Count swing and a foul tip so he's
got him in swing mode here you can
expect him to probably expand that
slider if you can get that big one to
sweep off the plate here
almost exclusively sink or slatter
against right-handed batters
doesn't make it easy
it's a filthy pitch 3-2
missed right out by Ray Rivera right
there sees it down
pretty good job of seeing that pitch
down and not going after it extend the
ending here and put a little pressure on
on Dusty as to whether he'll stick with
him
um
well Dustin probably doesn't want to run
out to the mound Lance McCullers is a
guy that is accustomed to throwing over
100 pitches but it's usually a pretty
unique conversation we sometimes we've
caught Lance where he's like just stay
in the day let me finish this inning you
know Lance is very Lance loves going out
there and finishing these innings
reminds me of a museum in that video of
Detroit giving a joke
Tori back it's a pretty boy let me
apologize
I'm sorry Mike I realize you're going to
finish this one but you love that in
that heat of the battle in that moment
that's into Gallagher
well as he reaches 100 clearly the arm
gets a little more tired a little bit
less sharp with those sliders so big
chance right here for for cam to try and
get one that's in the middle of the zone
and do some damage
it's chat time
not Dusty though it's Brent strong
I just want to go over things number
nine hitter cam Gallagher facing a 1-0
count McCullers is at 100 pitches the
season high for him is 111 and while we
have a moment with Maryfield take over
what do you think of Lance McCullough's
Junior today
foreign
[Applause]
ER doesn't doesn't do that at all it's
just straight across
we think the same thank you wit
sometimes just stating it simply says
enough
how does he look up there how is he
how's it that's a good slider yeah
right-handed hitters look out
oh got one right there yeah
need those sometimes don't you
yeah you definitely need those
not too many pictures I've seen give it
back you know blue not a Sprite not a
strike it's
Taylor's singled with two outs Rivera
walks now Gallagher takes another pitch
he's taken all three it's two and one
in reality which one would we rather
have called a strike there probably that
one because he executed that when he you
know wants to be rewarded spot he was
attacking yep he wanted to be rewarded
but uh nonetheless
this is rare he's used all four pitches
against a right-handed him yeah he threw
a couple of change UPS early in the game
both of them missed down you know where
they weren't factors into the at that
but enough to plant that seed in the
hitter's head going oh man what was that
the Gallagher lost one foul
all right so what is the option here do
you go back to the classic slider
against righties
that's a big pitch right here
two two count you know he hasn't been
hurt on the fastball either so it's one
of those things the slider clearly he's
getting more tired they haven't been
sharp the last two at-bats this fastball
still has a great life great location so
it's kind of which one do you want to
which one do you want to die by which
one are you willing to give up uh you
know get the guy out on
[Applause]
when I say that I remember like in
certain at-bats I would be thinking it's
like I I don't want to go back to the
dugout
having thrown a pitch that I wasn't sold
on you made a mistake yeah you want to
get beat by your best so so if his
slider is his pitch and he throws a
fastball and he gives up a hit and he's
not going to be able to live with
himself with that then he's got to throw
sliders until this at-bat's over
but you know both are fantastic pitches
so it's like he can from our perspective
he can choose whichever one his
perspective he's sold on one right now
[Applause]
didn't get the chase on that one
[Applause]
I said did you see Maldonado on the tip
there just flushing the right forearm
they didn't even give him a b he just
went right back to the next pitch
mccollers wants to keep the flow going
only the third Full Count of the day for
KC against him and we'll do another okay
well there you go y'all are doing a
great job battling because he's getting
the heater now and the slider and he's
he's 95 so the velocity is still there
late in this game too that was actually
a really good pitch 3-2 down Great Piece
of you know Fighting by Gallagher right
there because he's gonna need something
up in the zone that he can drive yep
just get in the Outfield nice line drive
somewhere out there
[Applause]
shocked the world with the change up
here oh man yeah that's the boulder
Gallagher would swing himself into the
ground on that thing here we go ball
four
yanked one and that loads up the bags
for KC
that'll do it
and who's the happiest guy walking back
to the Dugout right now the guy that
identified that slider is a good one he
says I wouldn't mind taking my chances
maybe against someone else yep
that guy's with Maryfield and if he says
anything good we'll have it for you he's
miked up and he's gonna face a new
pitcher for Houston so McCullers leaves
with quite the jam here two outs bags
full of Royals in the seventh
foreign
[Music]
the ninth inning somebody said whoever
catches the last ball everybody pays
them 25 bucks
White
two outs to go
I thought it was a hundred
[Laughter]
everybody asked me
what did George say to you before that
last bat or antibiotics like came up and
he came up to me and he said listen when
you get this guy out I want to be the
first guy don't go running anywhere I
want to be the first guy to grab you
man Sly against it and it's coming to me
and I'm like this is this really
happening
the ball went up and I knew it wasn't
out
so I was ready to jump into his arms
right then and he basically gave me that
no it hasn't come down yet well we want
to make sure that Motley caught it a lot
of pressure catching that last out to
Motley
[Music]
foreign
world champions
[Music]
Google cloud is helping to power
statcast with massive amounts of data
points to reveal new insights taking you
deeper into the game than ever before
Google cloud is the official Cloud
technology of Major League Baseball
pressures on Christian Javier the 24
year old will enter the mix here
replacing Lance McCullers Jr who held
Casey to just one run but don't close
the book yet six and two-thirds five
hits seven strikeouts four walks he's
responsible for all three base runners
and Jeremy you know this feeling you're
out there watching and you're going
please Christian give them the good
stuff oh absolutely you are and I know
both ends of it clearly right but you
want to be he's just out there saying
give me anything first pitch something
swing I know that's why I always always
thinking I just wanted the first guy to
swing at the first pitch because it was
usually an hour to get him to do it but
in Javier in the start of the year as a
starter and so I don't know how many
Runners he's inherited throughout the
season but I can't imagine this is the
most comfortable or or you know familiar
spot for him to jump into
he's actually only inherited two Runners
on the season so this is a unique
opportunity for Christian Javier
goes after that first pitch it's headed
towards the wall the Crawford boxes
first pitch Grant slam with Maryfield
muscles up and the Royals jump in front
5-3 KC just right
if I'm the pitcher I didn't want him to
swing at the first pitch anymore but
what what a gutsy swing by Whit right
there comes in the Hearthstone righty
and just takes him deep
and it goes back to the previous two
at-bats those two guys working at Cam
and uh and Rivera to work the count
against the tough slider and extend the
inner and now the result no that that is
a typical Astro inning where they work
at bats get base hits put Runners on
create traffic create stress for the
pitcher that was just a great up app by
Whit Merrifield who's a high contact guy
against a guy who doesn't throw him
doesn't have a high strike percentage so
he guessed fastball he guessed out over
the plate he got it and the biggest
thing is don't miss it
turned on a two inner third right there
running hard at him and another guy that
chokes up you know a little bit like
Greg you're right and generates a lot of
power
[Applause]
home run number nine on the season for
wit
wow what a shot
gastros might be calling to get a police
escort for the team bus for the Kansas
City Royals and make sure they get out
of here as soon as possible
they've already won the season series
they're up four games to two this is the
last yes the last matchup of the Season
between these two teams take a deep
breath
I mean you're right though and cowboy
Jeff in the game commentary said
cold-blooded that's how Casey has been
against Houston this year Dusty said the
other day they don't feel like the
softer part of the schedule
foreign
strike three Nikki Lopez spikes the bat
but you should be pumped for his
teammate
with Maryfield with the bases loaded
takes advantage first pitch from
Christian Javier to the Crawford boxes
let's stretch Royals snatch the lead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
middle the infield is back hoping to
turn a double play and conceding the
tying run Corners are in
Altuve drives one two left field Marco
look at it that's gone a walk-off slam
Jose Altuve
are you serious wow a walk-off Grand
Slam for Jose Altuve wins it in the
bottom half of the 10th
Jose tries one deep to left field but
Castro looks up you've got to be kidding
me
again a three-run home run for the
second time this year against
maybe the most improbable comeback in
the major leagues this year unbelievable
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tomorrow
thank you
[Applause]
MLB Originals season 2 is Live on
YouTube with new episodes every week see
your favorite players and learn more
about the game you love on youtube.com
MLB
and compete for cash every game with MLB
Quick Pick presented by pet MGM makes
seven pregame picks and compete to win
restrictions apply see rules and enter
at mlb.com
quick pick the pendulum has swung
two outs Bases Loaded KC with an
excellent sequence after cam Gallagher
walks three straight reach for KC in the
seventh top of the order with Mary field
blast off
Grand Slam it's 5-3 Royals and now
Gerard Dyson will come in as a defensive
sub
we're in the bottom of the seventh Dyson
replaces O'Hearn
and Domingo Tapia will take over for
Mike Minor
Miner kept his team in the game he did
he pitched phenomenal he did exactly
what he needed to do he got hurt on a
couple long balls which has been a
problem during the year but he went in
and out he did what he had to do and uh
hit you know the hitting picked him up
Whit's first home run by the way in 47
games breaks a 47 game Homer let's
streak
welcome back to the gun show wit
I'll tell you what the Astros gave up
the Homer Luis Garcia gave up the home
run to Nikki Lopez to break a long
homerless streak and now Whit
maryfield's on that list
I was Lopez's first of this season last
week on Thursday
it's not part of his game Myers
watches a pitch sail away 2-0 from Tapia
this man can bring the heat
average is 98 miles an hour on the
four-seam
and on the hands Myers that's well done
[Applause]
hey let's take you back August 19th
remember this I do remember that it was
a breaking ball from Luis Garcia
and he took it down and in and launched
it that was pretty impressed with the
fact that he did it at Kauffman Stadium
he assume would be some of these other
ballparks maybe Camden Yards or some of
these short porches in right field but
he got big in a big ballpark
it's actually what threw off his game at
one point Mike Matheny has spoken about
this a couple times this year the
comeback effort from Nikki Lopez after a
very down 2020 and some struggles in
2019. Mike said you're looking at launch
angle and exit velocity and hard hit
rate and he said Nikki that's not your
game
you know you can be a classic throwback
player and it is actually a breath of
fresh air in our game and so he does put
the baseball on the ground a lot
face hits sack buns stolen bases Elite
defense
[Applause]
see if that's playable for Gallagher
looking for it and it's in about the
sixth row
[Music]
I had not seen uh Nikki Lopez play
before last week and I've been impressed
on the field what I've heard guys say
about him in the clubhouse too is a
great guy well liked works hard
um just a real likable young player as
well so he's having the success on the
field but he knows how to how to handle
himself in the clubhouse which just can
fits so well with this club and you
mentioned that I mean
I think this is the time blumber to
bring up the fact that Jeremy Guthrie's
been all over the place it's a
well-traveled individual next to us you
can give lunch recommendations in Kenya
in case you're stopping by
this is one of the few stops along many
you've had how was it you know it was
that was my dream was to go to Africa so
we spent three years here in in Houston
um working as missionaries for my church
and we weren't we didn't leave Houston
like I didn't leave Houston at all yep
for three years so when my wife says
where do you want to go
you earned it I said we're going to
Africa and we're taking the kids and we
went to Kenya eight days saw cheetahs
which was the ultimate I found a new
favorite animal like I said at the
beginning yeah you need to explain that
a little bit more just you know it's one
of those guys you look at the warthog it
sounds nasty it's amazing
and you learned so much about him on
these Safaris
you know for example who knew that
Pumbaa means stupid
if you saw the body on these warthogs
these these chiseled legs really yeah
stocky legs but quick okay what do they
hunt
they hunt after leftovers I believe okay
yeah they want leftovers I do that too
yeah
it's in that refrigerator I don't waste
a morsel
Maldonado lifts one deep left does it
have enough
it does not
[Applause]
benintendi makes the catch
long Fly ball out and it's the first
here in the seventh
aiming for the right spot blommer yeah
he did that
maybe a little bit off that label as he
got two got in on him a little bit it
looked like an off speed pitch it backed
up a little bit he had to pull the hands
in but you're right and pulling the
hands in almost launched it to the right
spot out there trying to creep into the
Crawford boxes
remember he took the foul ball off his
arm in the last half inning
the true catcher
almost popped another one over the wall
he has
home run number 10 back in the third
inning now we flip it to the top of the
lineup card for Dusty Baker in the
Houston Astros Altuve followed by Diaz
josezo for three
[Applause]
tilapia has been one of their more
reliable relievers this year era in the
low twos and I watched some Pitch the
other night throwing bowling balls 99
ball an hour oh [ __ ] and when I say
bowling ball heavy with movement that
just one of those things just destroys
your bat we've seen a lot of Sliders
today but that fastball is heavy and it
was hard
that's why it's interesting to me to see
his strikeout number it's 16 Innings
only 15 strikeouts still a guy that's
trying to figure it out
but that high velocity
tough to compete with that yeah he'll uh
he'll keep working he'll figure it out
when he does obviously you'll see those
numbers jump even more maybe work
himself even towards the back of the
ball oh you're right
ties up Altuve there yeah 97.
just doesn't look like fun no heavy run
when it's down it sinks a bunch
yeah he's been great for him and
obviously pitching the seventh inning of
a game a two-run game he's someone that
might Trulia obviously a trust very much
[Applause]
he reaches 4-1 right side Maryfield to
scoop the throw and gets the added first
Myers over to second with two gone in
the seventh
whole question
on the Royals prospects whole answer
obvious Bobby Witt Juniors who everyone
wants to see in September
top three Prospect according to MLB
Pipeline and he passes the eye test too
I've seen him in person a few times he
is special I don't really know the
weakness for Bobby Witt of course we'll
see everyone gets exposed at some point
in the big leagues but so far in the
minor leagues
he looks like the ideal shortstop
good drafting by the Royals it's going
to start to pay dividends as it already
is with the effort they give there on
their on their scouting and
I know they're very excited for him
reminds me a little bit of a Matt
weeders
in terms of the excitement When leaders
came up they actually announced it a
week in advance so that people could buy
tickets and it overshadowed there was
two debuts by come up a couple of our
starting pitchers the week between the
announcement really and his debut and
they were just after thoughts you know a
couple of young starters came up and
made starts and it was just all about I
think they might have done the
bobblehead on this first day wow
today it's a lot of pressure that's in
the air and that's gonna fall and score
a run for Houston Here Comes Myers he's
in there on the RBI not for let me Diaz
to make it 5-4
thank you
never underestimate the value of a guy
like let Miss Diaz
we actually got a mistake slider that
backed up maybe middle in a little bit
Diaz did a good job of fighting that off
yeah he did
in a lot of the pitches that we've seen
this thing have been left on the inner
third the fastball and the slider and so
maybe that's one of the things you know
that right now a challenge form is is
getting it over there to the glove side
because if you throw enough pitches
inside obviously these hitters are going
to get the bat to it eventually even if
it's a jam shot like that was he didn't
hit it hard but he hit it hard enough
he is a talent he actually played for
the Cardinals came up with St Louis so
he was managed by Mike Matheny he knows
what he can do
Diaz riding a six-game hit streak
probably going to see his playing time
decrease a bit as bregman's back but he
is full of confidence
yeah you know what the Houston Astros
are big on some of the health analytics
also so they have they like the idea of
giving guys days off and with Alex
bregman back it kind of gives them the
opportunity to use a guy like a lead
Miss Diaz to go ahead and give Carlos
Correa a day off get Michael Brantley a
day off in left field give Jose Altuve
and Yuli gorilla day off so I would
imagine here in the near future you're
going to see him move around the infield
a little bit as they massage Alex
breaking back into the lineup
that's a nice luxury to have yes clearly
have a guy batting over 300 and think he
may have reduced time but we can move
him around yep good place to be
again arm side there so you know if you
can get it down he has a chance right
now to get that last out but he's just
gotta gotta admit more patient get the
hand out front and be able to finish it
down in the zone even work at glove side
if possible
live game commentary section is booming
right now Sports gaming Universe can the
Astros battle back
inside again to Yulie and the fumble
says here they come
later things here at home for the
Houston Astros can be exciting
how good has this season series been
I mean if you're a fan of baseball and
you could pull up seven games throughout
the course of the year to watch these
seven would be incredible
[Music]
3-0 to Yulie
not Landing the Sinker right now no and
then I I felt that in my early in my
career was very tough for me to get
glove side
so you'd always have the catcher you
know pointing your left shoulder to come
out and say Hey you know don't try to
throw it too early it was one of the
challenges I had is trying to trying to
overthrow it early and I couldn't get
that hand out front where you can really
finish on that outer third of the plate
and so you know some adjustment
hopefully he can make it here and get
those pitches where he's aimed where he
wants to get it blown away where the
glove is right there's a good adjustment
right it's not it's not a strike but
that's a that's a nice pitch moving in
the right direction yeah that's a good
pitch 3-0 count okay we had some
troubles there he's not gonna get a
chance to work on it today but but
something they're good to see the
adjustment from a young reliever doing
that Mike Matheny is going to make a
switch
after the Royals put up four thanks to
the Whit Mary field Grand Slam in the
top of the inning one run back from
Houston and now two on Jordan Alvarez
with a home run in his pocket today Rich
love lady is coming in
seventh inning action what a series
between these two this season the drama
continues in a moment
[Music]
there are few moments like it
moments that compare to arriving here
and despite all of us going to the same
place
we all come for different reasons
some come for the sights
the sounds
some come for the bombs
some for the bonds
some come for passion
some come for the place
we all come to be part of something
bigger than ourselves
and regardless of what you come for
there's a ticket for you Astros season
tickets
for the h
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this copyrighted telecast is presented
by authority of the office of the
commissioner of baseball may not be
reproduced or retransmitted in any form
in the accounts and descriptions of this
game may not be disseminated without
Express written consents foreign
Park
Astros had the lead for a majority of
this contest Whit Merrifield changed
that with his Grand Slam swing in the
top of the frame now bottom seven one
run in and potentially more here huge
spot for Richard Lovelady to enter the
only Lefty out of the bullpen for Mike
Matheny
you can see Diaz and guriel aboard
it's Jordan Alvarez one for three with a
home run today first pitch fouled off
it's a great opportunity for uh for
Richard here you know they've had Jake
brents doing a lot of The Late Late
ending relief appearances the
left-hander who went on the IL a couple
of days ago and so I love ladies pitched
great this year a chance right here in a
big moment to pick up his team pick up
his uh his teammate here he pitched on
Monday against Houston two-thirds of an
inning ahead of strikeout
no runs against him there's a 12 pitch
appearance
[Applause]
same spot Alvarez fouls it off and that
strikeout was Alvarez that he came in
and got in his last outing
foreign
yeah that's what's amazing about Jordan
he digs in you just say oh he's a big
Thumper big Joey Gallo Mike Stanton type
but he's a guy that goes out there and
really takes a lot of pride in keeping
that average right around 280 Plus
but for a young hitter to hit
left-handers as well as he has so far in
his career is really impressive
the homered off Mike Minor earlier who
is a southpaw
[Applause]
good take right there by Jordan yeah
that's a good pitch right there O2
something he could swing at could offrat
no chance he's gonna hit it anywhere
and sometimes a young hitter like Jordan
will expand a little bit trying to fight
that pitch off but did a good job of
holding his ground
[Applause]
[Music]
he's got a lot of sweeping ax on his
slider as well almost that pitch was
more middle and he still almost got
jammed a little bit on that because of
the way it just swept across on him a
lot of movement
he uses it 48 of the time
[Applause]
one two
open space left field nope it's Tracked
Down by Ben and Tandy
nice jump on that baseball from the
royals left fielder one of the best in
the biz at the position love lady comes
in and does his job
there he is
Royals play good defense they hold a
one-run lead through seven
[Music]
he is a throwback
Blue Collar type player he always seemed
to have dirty pants and ripped knees and
the hat was pulled low with pine tar on
it and he had pine tar all over his Bat
and
look like he should be filmed in black
and white
if you look at the numbers are
phenomenal he stole 50 bases if 50
doubles 20 homers
who's on base 40 of the time he was
it was a it was a spectacular player all
right the crowd is up one away from the
3 000 hit Club and I knew that big was
going to get 3 000 hits if you
just finished I don't think there's any
secret there it is
well he tried to stretch out but we
didn't quite make it and he's gonna be
out
bad move with my hand by the way you can
tell him I said that
3 000 career hits and all all as an
astro you know the 3 000 hits here at
home this is what it was supposed to be
like the fans have been unbelievably
great to me and my family and I just
love you guys thank you he's my baseball
icon at Houston and he spent his whole
career in Astros uniform from the day he
was drafted until the day he enters Hall
of Fame
[Applause]
thank you
Big Buddy
call it let's go
let's go baby
[Applause]
did someone call that in the KC Dugout
it's let me tell you something there's
never been that bat with the base of
loaded someone doesn't call it but kudos
to the ones who they who did do it
someone had faith in Whit Mary field
Salvador Perez on the first pitch from
Javier in the eighth
drives one to Diaz
there's your first out in the inning
I like wit pumping up his teammates too
and he crosses home good A B you helped
me out thank you
it's exactly right and that's that's the
brand they played recognize every
contribution matters right because when
you think when you're a team that just
lives and dies by the Home Run or
something then it's just about the guys
that hit the home runs but that that
home run doesn't even happen without
those two Outbacks
great recognition from one of their
leaders
Andrew benintendi made the last out in
the half inning right before this
Houston was putting the pressure on
Richard Lovelady comes in and gets
Jordan Alvarez to fly out
Houston shutout KC yesterday 4-0 Royals
won on Monday seven to one
foreign
look better than 56 and 69
is it just me for the seven games I've
seen yeah I've watched a lot of KC
versus Houston over the past week and
part of that has been the young pitching
starting to Blossom because during some
of their slumps they went through
Growing Pains that's a roller for Julie
and those are going to happen and that's
why they go out and get a guy like Mike
Minor in exactly what he did today is
what they've what they that's all they
ask of them you know go out there give
us a chance to win a good quality start
today six Innings three runs and so he's
an anchor but they have to see someone
do it they have to see someone take the
ball every fifth day even if the era is
higher than he wanted to be even if the
results aren't where they where they
have been and so that's that's the
importance of a guy like Mike especially
with all the young pitchers around him
we were talking about quality starts
early this morning are they still cool
I got them in really cool well Jeremy uh
you know he brings up a good point what
is a quality start because if you say
it's a quality start sick and
technically
statistically it's six Innings three
earned runs or less now 300 runs over
the course of nine innings is a 4.50 era
so maybe that's not something you want
to carry to the arbitration table but
Jeremy brings up a good point in the
sense that if you do go six strong only
give up three runs guess what you're one
swing away from opening this thing up
and winning a ball game so I think
that's where maybe the the quality means
more in the sense of quality that it
gives your team a chance to fight back
or stay in a game and create the
opportunity to win
and I think that's probably like to
blomer's point I think that's probably
where it comes from if you're down by
three two or one runs you have a chance
yep you're one swing away at all times
if the situation presents walks in a
home run away that's that's where you
want to be and being I've never heard of
a pitcher rolling out 30 quality starts
and finishing the year with a four or
five era and then see what the
arbitrators would say what would the
club say about a guy that throws up 20
even you know 29 quality starts and you
have a four a 4.4 would they appreciate
that as much as the name quality start
indicates interesting it would be
I I know Mike Matheny would appreciate
it and so would the team when they know
their guy's gonna go out every day give
them six plus and be in the game I think
every teammate would take that and Bank
on it
[Music]
and I think at this day and age when
you're so concerned about Pitch counts
how many innings how many times I faced
a lineup when you do say quality start
the only reason I like it is because it
says you've gotten to that six inning
threshold or further and I think that's
a big deal because it backs up so many
bullpens it allows you to use your
bullpen in more appropriate ways and
keep them rested and keep them useful
Christian Javier freezes Hunter Dozier
nice tidy nine pitch inning from the
Astros reliever
last of the eighth coming up
[Music]
Shelby thanks for hanging out with me
today thank you for having me if you
didn't play baseball what sport would
you play basketball you can hoop
what is your favorite away Stadium to
play in Minnesota he knew it was gone
and it's into the upper deck loves
Target Field any field I have 19 homers
I'm gonna like that one yeah
do you have any pre-game rituals or
superstitions anything that you do I
don't think people want to know that
I gotta be honest with you enough that's
why we're here guys okay who is the most
competitive guy on the team
I am you I knew it I knew it I just like
you want to play high and get everything
that happened for that game
[Music]
the MLP game of the week Live on YouTube
is presented by YouTube TV watch live TV
with unlimited DVR key plays and more no
cable box required YouTube TV try it for
free I love it I've got it we would like
to take this opportunity to recognize
the great Mike Brady thank you Mike
today's low Third Base camera operator
he's working his last baseball game this
afternoon we'd like to thank him for
everything he's contributed to the
Houston Astros in his 31 years of
working with the team he's still going
to be commanding that thing for football
and Rodeo but Mike cheers to you
absolutely great job Mike great having
him around does a phenomenal job down
there in a great spot
nice view to watch a ball game pretty
strong yeah
well Richard Lovelady did a phenomenal
job in a tough spot down there for the
Royals I'm going to turn it over to uh
to Josh stalmont who I've been excited
to I'm actually one of the relievers I
have wanted to see in person with that
electric arm he has
got the flow in the back too
yeah he brings fire
he'll need it Correa bregman Tucker do
up for Houston you go oh it must be what
two three four in the lineup no it's
five six and seven that's the Houston
Astros for you
yeah working their way back to full
strength
does create a unique Dynamic for
pitchers to go out there and try and get
through some of these lineups
it's been a lot of fun over the years to
watch these guys play and then trying to
understand how much postseason
experience these guys have actually
accrued since that 2015 season has been
incredible we've actually reached their
way onto some of those leaderboards in
the postseason but I think it's really
helped them late in some of these ball
games even during the regular season
two and one to Korea how can it not I
mean you look at a spot like this
and you can look back on experiences
that were a little more pressure packed
45
000 of their favorite fans in here
facing the best of the best in the
postseason and coming up in big
situations what I love about these guys
is they love the spotlight they want
each guy wants to be in that position to
get that big hit
[Applause]
many of them have done it that is true
and then when they reach free agency if
they're not kept they're highly coveted
example a George Springer now with the
Blue Jays
yeah that was a tough pill to swallow
for Astro fans losing a guy like George
Springer but Jose Altuve stepped in and
done a great job at the top of the
lineup and then we get a chance to see
some young guys out in center field it
was Miles straw to start with and now
it's guys like Jake Myers and Chaz
McCormick
and you're not able to see a guy like
Jake Myers in this lineup and start in
center field on a pennant chasing team
unless you have
The Magnificent Seven that we talked
about where you've got some protection
through that lineup where you don't have
to lean on a guy like Jake Myers
I say B from Korea they're going to make
stomach work
there's Myers
I mean
if you're someone like him and you come
up to this team I'm sure you're just
picking everyone's brain all day long
tell me what I need to do to be like you
and you can say that to almost anyone
else in the lineup and it would be a
great combo
and that's another thing about this
Clubhouse they are more than welcoming
there's no hierarchy in there they want
you to come in help produce and they
will help the help Jake Myers acclimate
in any way they can great at that yeah
Correa sets the table second free pass
for him this afternoon
on base percentage leaders to lead off
Innings Houston does it better than
anyone in the American League
AC number three on that board
that's why Dusty Baker almost always has
a smile on his face and he's a happy guy
in general but he takes over a team that
can really swing the bat and then not
swing the bat when necessary true
he said it in 2020 when he got when he
got a hold of this ball club and
understood the situation we had a chance
to interview him on the radio he said
I've got the keys to the Ferrari he goes
just a matter of letting them continue
to put the pedal down and go bragman
goes center field Taylor tracking back
warning track got it and Correa will
stay at first
and some nice swings today from Alex
bregman first game back in a couple
months
I completely agree there's some
positives even though that ends up being
a fly out to center field he barreled it
up and he's done a good job of driving
the ball to center field got that base
hit earlier going the other way you can
see the face of Alex new he hit it to
the wrong part of the ballpark
he might have even said why
why did I go there
well I'm sure the American League West
pitchers are taking note they know he's
back and they know they'll have their uh
their work cut out for them with another
electric bat in the lineup
[Applause]
[Music]
this man can swing it too 22 home runs
this season for Kyle Tucker
activated yesterday and he goes after
the first pitch so stamon walks Correa
and then ragman hungry early
same with Tucker
you see stamon using a lot of the
curveball and talking with some of the
the Royals
I think for a lot of their young
pitchers last year what happened with um
with uh the off-site where they would go
and work it gave
pitcher's a chance especially some of
the younger pitchers to work on other
pitches like stalmont throws upper 90s
over 100 I think he had the most pitches
over 100 or numerous pitches over 100 a
couple of seasons ago
but last year he had covet and so he had
to work his way back into it spent his
time
throwing a lot of those practice games
while he was getting back into shape and
he's really developed a lot of trust in
this curveball which gives it just makes
that fastball that much more of an
important pitch and the velocity started
to come back for him I think he's
reaching the upper 90s again although
early in the year he was more in the mid
90s which you know
sounds like a nice luxury to be right
down and be I'm only in the mid 90s but
when you're used to pitching with a
hundred it does make an impact on your
approach
[Applause]
one out one on for Tucker
I mean that is a sharp curveball yeah
off of an upper 90s fastball so you know
didn't get the call there not sure what
we're looking for good take yeah
that's one of those ones as a hitter it
buckles you and you go oh my gosh call
it a ball call it a ball yes that's one
of those ones when they catcher checks
the third base umpire on the swing I'd
like the third baseman to check the home
plate umpire on the on the width of that
pitch right there was that was that wide
check the home plate on part on that
pitch because that's a pretty good pitch
right there that's a nice swing going
the other way Kyle Tucker keeps the
train rolling parade a second
thank you
[Applause]
it's a pretty good swing on 97.
but it's also a fastball
looks like it's tailing away a little
bit of a two-seamer at 97 but Kyle does
a good job of just shooting it the other
way and continuing this inning
oh and nice Little Weapon Off the Bench
this afternoon
Michael Brantley will climb in
[Applause]
he's on deck so he'll hit
and if Jake Myers can create some action
here for Houston one out Myers is two
for three today
takes one down Broadway
now there he is you know I think about
another one-liner from Dusty this season
he said we're not the Big Red Machine
but maybe we're the orange wagon or
something
I think you need a more Fierce name for
this offense when brantley's coming off
your bench
let me see what he's trying to do down
here in Houston but yeah I would agree
maybe something a little more dangerous
orange Ferrari sounds better that would
be great
that's in there
[Applause]
assistant on the Zone but that looks
like it was a strike it's just that we
saw a pitch earlier in the same spot
I changed you about a little bit for
Kyle Tucker if he would have got that
pitch called on him
foreign
Tucker on
for Jake Myers
O2 to the rookie
we saw that graphic earlier third
amongst relievers with the strikeout
with the curveball so clearly a pitch he
likes to go with he's got him set up for
anything at this point if he can execute
a fastball
oh my gosh it's probably not going to
put a great swing on it if he can get it
off uh get it to the edge either in or
out but he's really got him set up for
anything with all of these breaking
pitches he's been able to throw for a
strike here and Scott Barlow who
is the KC closer du jour
kind of unexpected
and he's been really effective in high
leverage spots
the Royals organization loves this arm
Josh stamant
[Applause]
there's a fastball to speed things up
sometimes in two strike counts he'll
he'll hear hitters say I'm going to try
and hit off the fastball that just gives
you the idea mentally that you're
sitting on that fastball so your mind is
getting ready for 97.
and if he does come at you with a
breaking ball or something off speed
hopefully your hands are in good enough
position ready to fire sometimes you can
lose that lower half
where it's kind of rushing at the
fastball but if the hands are back and
you get a mistake up in the zone you
still have the ability to
put it in play or try and find some open
space out there
searching for his third hit of the day
he strikes out
big strikeout right there for him
curveball backed up a little bit on him
on the inner third end up being a good
thing nothing tougher to hit than the
backed up breaking ball 100 it's not
something you go out there and teach but
when you get it
effective more often than it's not yeah
match-up of the day
and it looks like it's going to belong
to Barlow
Mike Matheny coming to the Mounds
Michael Brantley is going to pinch it
for Houston
Here Comes Barlow
most likely going for a four out save
this afternoon
big time Big League match-up and a tight
series between the Astros and the Royals
make fun of me
heart is palpitating yes
[Music]
[Applause]
it makes a catch and
adds a little bit to the end Ukrainian
judge is not going to give him a high
score for that
Simba was warming up when he came into
the game Watch the left of your screen
Simeon
if only these guys could loosen up and
have a little fun
they they like to have fun
foreign
out of play falls down at home plate big
swing smile on his face slip to the
ground after the big cut oh you don't
see that very often oh what is that
it's a mantis praying for a rally that's
an alien he's still got his buddy with
him on his hat out in center field and I
can't call it a rally praying Madness or
alien or whatever the heck I called him
before but I've never seen anything like
that
[Music]
thank you
the heat is on for Scott Barlow taking
over for stamon Scott Braun Jeremy
Guthrie Jeff Blum Brett Dolan watching
the action with you today worldwide on
YouTube
Carlos been the man in the late stages
for KC era in the two and a half range
eight for 13 in save chances 74
strikeouts on the year in his 60 Innings
and oh welcome to the game to face
Michael Brantley
pinch hitter in the nine spot this
afternoon for Dusty Baker's Houston crew
and brantley's actually in a really rare
chilly spot in the season three for his
last 30. no extra base hits
I don't know Jeff law of averages
Michael Brantley there's Correa who
walked to start off the eighth
two batters later Tucker with the base
hit
here we go
now this is an extremely nice weapon for
Dusty Baker to have coming off the bench
three years now four years with the
Houston Astro three years with the
Astros hit 300 every single year
and coming into this game the top two
hitters in the American League are Julie
gariel and Michael Brantley and Michael
Brantley up until that streak that Scott
was talking about was well in the lead
as far as batting average is concerned
in the American League but a big spot
for him against Barlow
looks like he's handled pinch hitting
pretty well in his life too
[Applause]
will mix in that slider he'll mix in her
curveball with a good fast ball you know
the Royals have really handled Michael
Brantley well this year yeah he just has
the one hit against him in six games and
so they you know this is a much deserved
off day for him and now he has a chance
to step in but Barlow will mix and match
with the Curve and slider and try and
see if he can't get something to
soft contact we saw him on Saturday
against Chicago over the weekend the
Royals swept the Cubs Barlow picked up
his eighth save Brantley center field
he's in business
perea rounding third and we will tie
this game up at five with the Brantley
RBI knock
what a back and forth affair with these
two
we see Michael Brantley come through Off
the Bench today for Houston
[Applause]
when you open up Webster's Dictionary or
whatever dictionary you're using and you
say professional batter it's gonna it's
gonna show you Michael Brandon he is so
calm and so under control and is so
quiet at the plate
that it doesn't matter the velocity it
doesn't matter the break it just matters
where you're going to put that pitch and
the ability to get the barrel of the
baseball he is like
not too many hitters in the big leagues
who can roll out of bed and get the
barrel to the baseball he has been such
a luxury for the Astros that have in the
top part of their lineup
he's that steadfast free agent that has
really solidified this lineup for the
Houston Astros he has been an absolute
blast to watch in this uniform because
for so many years going through
Cleveland you're going oh man here comes
that Michael Brantley guy again
he is a professional hitter I can only
imagine you know having this as much as
they see him in the central what it
meant to those pitchers to see him leave
yep because he is just that consistent
never tries to do too much but he lets
the hands work if he needs to pull a
ball he can take him deep into the
stands but uses the whole field
and he's a great luxury
what a great job by Dusty in this case
to give him the off Bay yeah and give
him a chance to come in in a moment like
this changes the rhythm of where he's
been every you know the four or five out
bats a game just break the Rhythm it's
actually a really good call
I think it's a great call
they're on the corners for Altuve Sky's
one
benintendi
searching there it is
side retired we are tied at five thanks
to that man Michael Brantley off the
bench clutch
[Music]
welcome to this little Interstate
squabble otherwise known as the 1985
World Series
[Applause]
John Tudor delivers and he swings and
missions
[Music]
and
the Cardinals leading four to two well
this is a Cy Young performance tonight
for saberhagen 2-2 got him the Kansas
City Royals rebound and beat the
Cardinals
yay
played the world series three games
Danny Jackson has just been brilliant
and Kansas City here we come again
a little swimmer to the right side
Laurel races over to cover the throw
doesn't get him looks like he's out I
don't think there's any doubt about it
[Applause]
he scores we go to a seventh
to Motley for the title
the Kansas City Royals are the 1985
World Champions
[Applause]
[Music]
knotted up at five we are in the ninth
in Houston Texas there's only one place
you can watch a house tour from Whit
Mary field and take a boat ride with
salvi the Royals YouTube channel new
videos every Thursday at 10 A.M visit
youtube.com Royals And subscribe today
and watch exclusive content on the
Astros YouTube channel head to
youtube.com Astros and follow the Astros
today
we're following both
and they're putting on a show
Brian Presley is the man in the ninth
for Houston
Scott Brown Jeremy Guthrie Jeff Blum
Brett Dolan pleased to be with you on a
Wednesday afternoon to a worldwide
audience hanging out with us today on
YouTube Jason Castro is going to take
over behind the plate
Dusty Baker pressing the right button
in the eighth
inserting Michael Brantley in the nine
spot he comes through with a base hit
here's Gerard Dyson
former Jeremy Guthrie teammate bounces
out
fun to see Rod out there got 10 years in
the major leagues this season
a 50th round draft pick of the Royals
and one of those guys that very easily
could have been you know taken someone
else and now have a 10-year career be a
part of some some obviously big teams
and some big wins stepping in right
there and you know good to see him
yesterday how often did he let everyone
know that he was selected in round
number 50.
how many people passed me by you know I
heard a great story yesterday from JJ
Piccola he said when I came down to
drafting them there was two folders two
players
and the Royals had had planned to draft
another guy looked through it and said
grab a different folder and said this is
the guy I'm going to go with and to be
in Dyson and so in a guy that you know
obviously had to work his way up from
the bottom of the totem pole to the
major leagues and did so and uh just a
great story it's a great baseball story
about guys just working hard persevering
and making it through what's the game
with the briefcases
uh Deal or No Deal or No Deal take that
one right lightning fast
so is Michael a Taylor and turns away
from a fastball from Presley almost hit
him
I love hearing stories about guys
getting that 10-year plateau
it means so much to the player
themselves in so many different ways
obviously it helps out the family
because their pension kicks in but at
the same time to be able to play for 10
years in this league at this level
says a lot about the perseverance of a
human being because there are guys that
are Elite and have all the talent in the
world but then you have the Gerard
dysons who will go out there and scratch
for 10 years I absolutely love it when
those guys get to that they should be
recognized and should be honored uh in
what they do because when you go through
the dugouts and you go through the
clubhouses and you tell or you meet
somebody Gerard Dyson meets somebody in
five years they go hey are you playing
the biglies he goes yeah 10 years
everybody's head turns they go what 10
years that's that's a serious amount of
time
and he's a guy in talking with him
yesterday I said you know what I'm on
the other side of it this will go away
it's here you've played 10 consecutive
years in the major leagues been to the
playoffs you know multiple times this
will go away every day you have a chance
to touch someone's life to make an
impact on a young player so no matter
what's happening because it's time he
hasn't played a ton this year so I can
imagine you know what that's like for a
for a veteran
but every day you have a chance to make
something impact someone's life
and it's going to go away who knows how
many more at-bats how many more games
how many years he has in this league but
be grateful for every single one of them
absolutely go make an impact every day
he's always been able to run out of
baseball with the best of them his speed
has played for a long time
that's what speed do yeah yeah that was
his famous quote to Dayton Moore I
believe years ago that's what speed do
he's fun to be around he is
2-2 on Taylor
[Applause]
did he go no
Michael a Taylor tried to steal home
yesterday I just wanted to sneak that in
there if you were watching yesterday's
game
Luis Garcia does not have the quickest
delivery on the planet and that was put
to the test but he rushed it
and Taylor was toast
I think that just helps to tell the
story of why the Royals are so fun to
watch
Taylor up the middle it's going to be a
tough play for Altuve and you will keep
it towards him but Taylor will reach
basic for Michael a Taylor
I think Jose was well aware of that
speed as well as he's running to his
right in the center field trying to
field that ball left to the back no less
I know but he's ranging away from the
bag but he's trying to get back to throw
to
but when you know a guy has speed at
home plate and you're trying to make one
of those great plays you know that there
is so much pressure on the exchange from
the glove to the bare hand and if you
don't make that exchange there's really
no chance it would have taken a
miraculous perfect play from Jose to
make that on Michael a Taylor
and that's a veteran too right Jeff that
knows if I make a bad throw Taylor's in
scoring position we're in trouble 5-5
game in the ninth it's a really good
point
number eight hitter Emmanuel Rivera
Rivera is new to the party first career
home run on Friday it was at Wrigley
Field
his first career hit was in Boston at
Fenway so he's just racking up the
classic ballparks with milestones
here in Houston on Monday we saw him
deliver his first three hit game in his
career
I know he's a few home runs away but
does he have a little bit of a look like
Nelson Cruz or my my am I seeing
something wrong here
you're saying with swinger with the face
yes that's what I'm saying the swing
looks like it that's a good place to be
too
yeah it would be
and to be doing it until you're 41 42
years old with damage it's impressive
wow
if they start calling him baby Nelly I
think he'll take it
there's Taylor on first
oh one from Presley
all just off the plate but no it's a
swing
first base up Todd tischner
yeah Ryan Presley was a guy who came
over from Minnesota and Brent strong got
his hands on Ryan the whole reason they
traded for him is because of the spin
rates everything was the spin rate it
was the fastball it was a curveball it
was a slider but since he's come over to
Houston he has been
in that setup role and moved into that
closing role where he's really kind of
taken off
but the slider that he throws at 90 to
92 miles an hour is absolutely
devastating and he just snaps it off
that outside corner so you see the
swings like you just saw
from Rivera where you kind of get the
idea oh it's a fastball and as soon as
they start their swing they try to hold
up and they just can't because there's
so much sharp break on that slider
he has been so good for this club he's
been amazing and just so locked down for
them and interesting to hear that
perspective of how based off of a spin
rate they say this is someone we can
work with and clearly they've been able
to help him and he's been able to help
himself
there it is I mean it's just a second
now watches are so good it is and
everything about him is power the
fastball is a power Fastball The Slider
we just talked about was a power slider
he throws that power curveball
everything is Max effort he gets so much
out of these pitches but it's amazing to
see the movement
and they were searching for that closer
they weren't sure if Ryan Presley was
going to be the guy that was going to
really take control of that end of the
ball game but he has done a great job
just a brilliant pickup a few years ago
I mean a few years before that the
Astros signed up Charlie Morton thanks
to some spin rates that they enjoyed
great Point too that worked out
that's a strike to Gallagher
you got strikeouts from the breaking
ball since 2018 Ryan Presley leads the
pack
thank you
[Music]
I'm gonna give Cam Gallagher the most
underrated a b of the day there's not
necessarily A YouTube trophy for that
post game I think at the moment with
maryfield's probably believing that
charge but back in the seven
two on two outs Works a walk against the
McCullers knocks him out of the game
Javier comes in Maryfield on one pitch
blasts the Royals to a grand slam and a
5-3 lead at the time the Astros have
battled back
and now Gallagher will pull that one
foul left side
yeah with Maryfield you know you benefit
because you get the guy on base but it
knocked you remember the previous at bat
where we had Whit Merrifield miked up
and he just stood in The Dugout going
that was a good slider he didn't have to
face that Slaughter we know that there
was a little bit of fatigue with Lance
but at the same time Whit Merrifield
didn't have to have that slider in the
repertoire he could go up against the
guy that he's facing for the first time
and Ambush him like you were talking
about Jeremy and he got a hold of one
yeah
one of those things all because of great
at bats yep exactly
Ryan Presley straightened up cam
Gallagher with a fastball that's in
there
he'll look back on the tablet on YouTube
and say okay good call
Ryan Presley shrends Michael Taylor at
first
showing off the full display this
afternoon in the ninth and giving his
team a chance to walk it off
[Music]
foreign
I came up in 76 it was a big Powerhouse
that's
the Royals go to the World Series our
thing was we never brushed ourselves off
you knocked me down I'm gonna get right
back up all dirt everything man because
I'm gonna let you know you're not
intimidating me it was an aggressive
game back in those days you didn't have
guys trying to avoid the tag or or stop
and go back to first we just ran over
the guy
and try to prevent a double play from
1976 to 85 the Royals made the
postseason seven times and won two
pennants culminating in that
Unforgettable 85 world series title and
during that stretch they were led by a
future Hall of Famer at third base we
drafted George in
1971. when I saw him as an 18 year old
kid for the first time I realized we had
somebody special
Georgia department is not just the
greatest player in Royals history he's
one of the greatest players of all time
great hustle great heart great grit and
also the seeming ability to come through
in the clutch every single time
[Music]
he was one of those unique hitters that
don't come around very often if you
challenged him or if there was a task at
hand he always came through
[Applause]
back and forth battle with the Royals
and Astros today five per side bottom
nine the Astros have 35 games left 15 at
home 20 on the road they're off tomorrow
and then their trip is nine games three
in Arlington Three in Seattle and three
against a San Diego team that's been
scuffling a bit lately you can see
September three through five is when the
live and interleague match up against
the Padres led me Diaz will start off
the ninth year for Houston tie ball game
Scott Barlow is back in there
[Music]
all right
Diaz guriel Alvarez and then the next
three after that are no fun for
relievers either
[Applause]
Point early
[Applause]
[Applause]
and if you're Mike Metheny you're
thinking no lead off walks please we did
the Nationals last week with Dave
Martinez talking about now a very young
group that's kind of turning things over
and that was their number one rule for
their young relievers no lead off walks
pump those pitches in the zone
isn't it funny every every post-game
interview you hear whether you know if
the guy didn't do well he'd be first
pitch strike I didn't get the first
strike over and it just creates so many
opportunities for the hitter to take
control of it bats
Diaz
Twisted one foul well you're both so
right to get ahead is the most
underrated thing that a pitcher can do I
think I think guys go through their
whole careers in fact I talked to a
friend the other day he's like I wish I
just would have known the power of
strike one it's amazing isn't it yeah
you think about trying to mix and match
and make the perfect pitch you don't
really need the first Perfect Pitch just
throw a strike a lot of times they put
it in play they do you a favor anyways
if it's first pitch in play you know yep
let's play the next guy
[Applause]
strike three big punch out for Barlow to
start the ninth against Diaz
big out there and this is you know this
game is shaped up to be this like Mike
Miner's last start back in Kansas City
it's the finale of that Series where it
was a little bit back and forth tied up
in the end the Astros went on to win it
in Extra Innings but Barlow in here
right now trying to extend this one
and he's been good for me you know I
think
I think he Scott he's given them a
chance to work multiple Innings which is
a nice luxury to have when your starter
can throw more than just the one inning
and so that's that's obviously something
they tried to work with in the eighth
inning try to get him out of that and
weren't able to do it successfully but
you go right back with him and a good
start to the ninth especially when you
don't have a break they're playing in
Seattle tomorrow
that's a tough tough Roadie yeah
go from Arlington to Houston and then
hop on that Charter for a good four and
a half hours to the Great Northwest it's
a serious trip for Kansas City
the Astros want them to be well rested
though Seattle is suddenly as much of a
contender in the division as Oakland
they're only a game behind the ace
there's not something America it really
is I think they're sticking up on a lot
of people this year of course but
clearly for real at this point in the
season well it's unfair for Astro fans
to watch the Seattle Mariner match up
and then watch them away from playing
the Astros because the Astro is
absolutely obliterate them
especially here at Minute Maid Park
where I think they're right around 20-2
in this ballpark in the last couple of
years
but it has been remarkable to watch him
go out and beat some other teams and
compete and now only be one game behind
Oakland after playing a great Series in
Oakland
I love the parody this year I think
we're gearing up very great great
playoff run let alone the actual
playoffs themselves
is the season series with the top two
teams for now in the AL West
asha's leading it 9-4 over Oakland yeah
they've played well against the other
two that are in contention at the moment
in the division yeah it's been pretty
amazing just to see that discrepancy as
far as runs per game
and it's been testy at times you know
it's actually been a lot of fun over the
years to watch the the Astros play well
within the division that's where they've
really made their Mark and earned the
ride over the years except for last year
where they lost out on the division to
the Oakland A's but
playing 19 times within your Division
and being able to play as well as they
do is
where you get it done kind of an
underwater swing there from Gary alley
wants it back he's down on strikes
in between
that was that Slaughter you talked about
it sweeping looked like it stayed on the
plate and kind of surprised Julie a
little bit well he checked his swing
there and you know you know you know
Gallagher wants that call right having
just punched out on the not the same
pitch but the same location so he does a
nice job to get the Umpire a chance to
level the score in his mind I'm sure
[Applause]
[Music]
Jordana Alvarez
downstairs he has four home runs in his
last six games
I love the point you made was it two and
a half hours ago plumber this is really
his second season
last year was a shortened gear anyway
for everyone and he didn't play for most
of it
he had some health issues with both of
his knees tried to play through it only
got one game under his belt before he
went on the injured list
in the off season had surgery on both
those knees
came into spring training a little bit
lighter A Little Bit Stronger
but having that lower half I know a lot
of people assume that a lot of upper
body strength goes into hitting but if
you don't have that lower half it makes
it that much harder
he has been able to run he's been able
to play left field and obviously Drive
the baseball so it's great to have him
back in the lineup
24 years old and it's Kansas City
just a leisurely swing going the other
way
107.4 miles an hour off the bat
easy pop in the fourth
and that is well struck on the ground
and the Astros have a two out base
runner in the ninth
doesn't that just look like a handsy
swing sometimes well I mean consider the
link he has right there they're working
them away the whole at bat breaking
balls back door and he goes out there
and just wraps all the way around it
barrels it through the I don't even know
if there was a hole in that area but he
somehow found a hole in the shift
and barrels it right through there so
you know but not but again to your point
like not a panicky swing not like not
necessarily trying to pull per se but
but getting the head out there and
pulling it and also knowing that one
swing you could end this ball game but
he took a tough pitch down and shot it
back up the middle
balance and whenever you see a hitter
balanced that put that makes a pitcher
really nervous when you start throwing
pitches that are bending from the back
door starting out of the plate and
they're on balance taking easy swings
they're throwing it hard in they're it
just balances like an eye test for a
pitcher makes them very uncomfortable to
see a hitter balance through different
swings on different locations
past the Baton to Carlos Correa
which is why I said maybe he didn't want
to see any good balance there so a
little up and in make those feet move a
little bit looks like he's falling all
over the place
Alvarez was just in a little over eight
skid entering the day and yesterday on
the Astros broadcast Jeff Bagwell said
he's a little late well
that's why he's a batting average guy in
addition to the power I mean the slumps
just don't last long with him
so you see big power hitter you figure
he's very Hit or Miss no this is a
consistent man in the lineup for Houston
[Applause]
it's three in one to Correa it's a
pretty good take right there that's that
balance you're talking about yeah that's
it that just makes you uncomfortable as
a pitcher just watching it makes me
uncomfortable to see that but you know
Barlow's mixing up well it's on the
slider he's got the the slower breaking
ball the good fastball he makes good
pitch here roll him over
go hit in the night go hitting the town
yep
don't make that mistake
hitting 347 in his last 13 games
take your base it was clear they didn't
want too much part of him in that at
that right there yeah why don't you go
ahead and explain that in that situation
Carlos is a dangerous guy but you can
pitch around the guys unintentionally
but I
you can definitely so yeah so a guy that
you recognize is swinging about well
you're gonna throw some pitches that if
he swings out kind of like earlier if
it's close enough he'll swing at it but
he can't do damage on it which is what
they try to do then you fall behind they
say okay if he wants to get aggressive
and swing out of this try and play off
that we'll let him do that but the
problem is
you now face bregman who's Taken good
swings all day long on different
pitchers and so the the reward for this
is still very much uh yeah in question
puts a runner in scoring position now a
base hit gives you the opportunity
Jordan surprisingly does run pretty well
tell you what Alex bregman right now is
licking his chops first game back and
you have a chance to win it
this this is his this is his Kill Zone
this is the good stuff yep that's how
the series should end though shouldn't
it I mean it's been amazing
it really has
we'll learn to visit from uh pitching
coach Kyle Eldred and
they'll go with the new plan here
twice he swung at first pitch
if anyone's anxious to be back with the
big league club it's the man who loves
baseball more than almost any other
human on the planet
BP at midnight for fun
gregman goes after the first pitch
popped up
and Dozier can't get to it
I think Brett almost made a play on that
yeah Brett
how did that look
try not to face plant guys that one took
the bounce off the concrete behind
himself see me jumping up about six
seconds late proper
etiquette bread is to hold the player up
so they don't tumble into the uh into
the camera well
that's why he didn't go after the
baseball self-preservation too he's
doing his job gregman whips and I didn't
see him protecting Alexa either so I'm
not totally certain what Brett's doing
down there if he's checked out on us or
what's going on I agree I was trying
Alexa Ramos down there with Brett Dolan
everyone's safe and good gregman has
three career walk-off hits in the
regular season
[Applause]
first game back he missed 59.
two strikes on him
one and two
good pick by Gallagher keep the runners
where they're at yeah important in this
situation got to be able to expand it
but trust the catcher and certainly
Gallagher did a nice job on that one
[Applause]
Alvarez and Korea on for the 2019
runner-up for Al MVP Alex bragner
[Applause]
a couple of good tapes after he chased
that
that 0-1 slider
would love to be inside his brain right
now because he does display excellent
plate discipline but it's his first game
back
would you love to have a heart rate
monitor around him right now
also keep in mind
30 pitches from Barlow today
it's not nothing
it's a pretty heavy workload for a
reliever
he told Alex you're going to be in the
six hole today but hey this is an RBI
spot puts one on the grounds Lopez goes
the short way to Maryfield inning over
great job by Barlow getting out of that
one there yeah a couple strikeouts and
then Alvarez single Correa walk gregman
bounces out let's play a little bonus
baseball on YouTube in Houston Texas
shall we
[Music]
foreign
1980. the All-Star game is at Dodger
Stadium and the Astros big right-handed
J.R Richard is the starter for the
national league after four straight
years of 18 plus wins and back-to-back
300 strikeout Seasons Jr is having a
great first half in 1980. that year I
thought J.R was on his way to being the
best pitcher I'd ever seen and
everything seemed set for his big
national moment he was throwing 99 100
miles per hour in the Twilight you know
as the sun was set the two-strike pitch
to fist oh
foreign
s that night and had three strikeouts
the most memorable came against Reggie
Jackson there was power against Power
at the Reggie Jackson the slider on uh
three and one and he asked Johnny Bench
what in the hell was that because he had
never seen anything like that before
you two coming
that's Jason's him he's out
[Music]
thank you
we've hit the 10th tied at five Kendall
graveman on the mound for Houston cam
Gallagher will be at second X training
rule in effect spread Dolan with a
little more for us right now Brett I
would say there's a little bit of news
an Astros social media land today we
know Carlos Correa is on the last year
of his contract he will be a free agent
there was an article that posted at the
athletic today and it said Carlos quote
was my last year with the Astros
hopefully we can win another
championship and I can leave this great
organization with two of them so
while the two championships sounds
pretty good to Astros fans I'm sure
they're going to be parsing those words
and not exactly uh thrilled to hear
Carlos mention that today
[Music]
Brad thank you and that's been a little
back and forth here with Carlos Correa
and the media discussing the contract
offer that he really confirmed for us in
spring training at about six years 120
million and you look at some of the
other dough that's been handed out to a
short stop like Francisco Lindor or
Fernando tatsis Jr and it's about triple
that number answer Alberto is going to
run for cam Gallagher
a little bit
the Astros are like oh this guy again
with Maryfield timing is everything yeah
this is Kendall Graven the 30 year old
acquired from the Mariners having a
dynamite season
and I remember him as a starter you know
obviously he's adapted well to this role
the Astros go out and pluck him from one
of the contenders in the division and
plug him in now for a second consecutive
day it's been interesting it's always
interesting to see that transition
between roles and pitching and to see
the guys that step in like a Wade Davis
and just take that relief roll and Excel
in it because it's not easy it is not
easy to go in pitch and relief and to
have that different dynamic in
preparation than there is for a starter
looks like he's done very well with that
thus far I remember 2015 he had no
greatman was soft tosser and the
rotation he was like 90 91.
watch this fastball now
that's better 97 that'll play
with Maryfield with a big shot today for
Kansas City statcast powered by Google
Cloud good lift on this one Crawford
boxes was at fourth row
Grand Slam
accounting for four of the five runs for
KC today
I'd like to see Kendall Draymond work
back into this count and get Whit
Merrifield just because if he ends up
walking him Nikki Lopez is a guy who's
not afraid to lay down a bunt whether it
be a base hit bunt or a sacrifice bunt
handles the bat well
could really create some issues with
Runners at first and second yeah the
Royals are a team not afraid to sack
money a lot of organizations
band the numbers don't say that's
productive we're not giving an out away
but but Nikki I think has 10 sack Buns
on the year and he has enough speed that
he bunts well he can actually stretch it
into a hit as well so you're right the
importance of the leadoff hitter always
important but especially with uh with
Nikki Lopez coming up next what are you
talking about the leadoff guy is already
on second I forgot about that wow
strike three greatman big punch out to
start off the 10th against the KC
two-time All-Star lead off hitter
and that might end up being the book on
wit because he's very good fastball
hitter but a couple of Sliders for
strikeouts in this game against two
tough pitchers with very good Sliders in
McCullers engravement now so they hit
her as good as wit and take anything you
can get okay if you guys see a little
Wrinkle in the slider you think you have
a chance clear that's the way they've
attacked him today successfully at least
the first day being the 10th for the
visiting team is so pivotal because now
the pressure's on here
and it's Nikki Lopez watching one
downstairs have we adapted and adjusted
to this idea of throwing a guy on second
to start the Extra Innings is it normal
to to you at this point me yes because I
called the World Baseball Classic like
four or five years ago and they were
doing it I was sitting there with Cliff
Floyd going I like the action I'm used
to it I do not
not yet I I get it and I understand the
purpose of it but I still would like to
see that 10th or 11th inning Maybe
for you nobody on base and see how it
goes kind of thing yeah then if you get
to that 11th 12th inning then put that
guy at second base and for the you know
for the Casual baseball fan every time a
run scores it belongs to a pitcher
remaining they're responsible for it
explain right now does Kendall graveman
does he have responsibility or is it
like it's a it's an unearned honored run
yeah so his era is safe so it doesn't
belong to he's not impacted by the rule
it says we're going to put a guy at a
second yes
Nikki Lopez right back to graveman he's
going to go to third Alberto is caught
gregman to Correa tag applied and they
get the lead Runner
[Music]
Jeremy what do they call it in spring
training pfps
pitcher Fielding practice and done to
perfection right there
by graveman good throw good easy run
down for him and didn't let the runner
advance to Second which is what Lopez is
trying to do right there when he gets
into that that situation he's trying to
save but can I get the second in the
good rundown didn't allow for that
you know what else they practice in
spring training see the ball through
make sure it gets past the pitcher
before you make that break to Third Base
because that was a great job by Kendall
to recognize the base runner was caught
in no man's land right there so big play
and a check over to first if you're
Lopez you might be trying to
swipe second he hasn't been caught all
year but be careful because salvey's up
and he can change this game with one
swing especially in this ballpark not
mentioned Kaufman also but
1-0
Brett what do you have guys have the
Royals run themselves into outs for the
cycle counting the attempted steal of
home last night with Taylor and
montessor being thrown out
and then of course losing Whit
Merrifield at third base and Dosher at
second and Ella runner between second
and third the cycle
could argue that yes they are aggressive
sometimes it costs them
[Applause]
well I love what you said about bregman
last half inning uh
[Music]
[Applause]
thinking big
Luis Garcia was on it I think what gave
it away was two pitches before that
Taylor was deeking a bit so he made the
pitcher aware
and that is fouled off left side but I
think if he didn't do the dick and you
tell me you're the pitcher Jeremy
did he kind of wake up a snoozing
pitcher with a long delivery a couple
pitches before that
didn't think he had him either way I
think either way because he's in Balance
right his head's down a little bit but
he's got balance and so to break that
early he has plenty of time to adjust
and make the throw and the key is if you
have a shift if there's a shift that
allows Michael Taylor to take a larger
lead and get way down the line then
maybe he's got a chance there but you
know he didn't have a generous lead a
pretty normal lead and tried to just
time it and the Pitcher saw him and once
he saw him he was able to gather himself
so credit to him for not stopping and
balking maybe that was the biggest risk
there was for the pitcher but I think
Louise it tipped him off a little bit
because Luis has an exaggerated it's
almost a dance step that he does before
his wind-up and it was an abbreviated
version I think that's why Mike Matheny
the manager of the Royals popped out of
the Dugout was to argue hey he altered
his delivery to home plate to get that
out because it was not that that
standard typical rhythmical kind of move
that Luis Garcia has so
he I think he keyed on what Taylor was
doing and said okay if I see him move
I'm gonna I'm gonna adjust because it
was just a nice easy flip the home plate
77 miles an hour and it was perfectly
located for Castro to drop the tag
I think Taylor was even asking at one
point about the delivery and if he
Alters it significantly would it be a
buck it's almost like they were
challenging the rule with that play I
think so too challenging Authority
it didn't work out
get back to your point about salary
being at this point yeah like you were
saying last inning a guy that loves
baseball has a chance to make a big
impact on this comeback obviously savi's
been playing but a guy who equally loves
baseball and I think you know one of the
under maybe understated impacts of him
having Tommy John's surgery which he had
in Spring of 19.
is for a guy that gets as beat up as he
does salvi behind the plate it almost
gave him a Rejuvenation period
to be able to come back and have the
type of season he's having this year
gregman throws him out the Royals come
up empty in the top of the 10th leaving
a lot of room for a walk-off chance for
Houston to finish off this season series
stay tuned
here's Hunter Dozier oh Drive deep to
left field that one is long gone Hunter
Dozier
oh tester
oh baby Nikki Lopez
that looked like that was dropping that
was a little doinker trying to sneak in
there but Lopez got a great jump and
there's a looping line drive to center
field that will knock in at least one
Taylor with the throw home it's a good
one and they got it
and sharply Lopez from his knees oh he
got him got him what a play
that ball is struck well deep to right
and it is Nikki Lopez's first home run
of the year did I say the Royals won't
beat you with a long ball Jose Altuve
base hit left field
McCormick coming around to throw to the
plate
unloaded
[Applause]
rookie move
this is the MLB game of the week Live on
YouTube presented by YouTube TV watch
live TV with unlimited DVR and more
YouTube TV try it for free we're at
Minute Maid Park in Houston Texas cop
run alongside Jeremy Guthrie Jeff Blum
and Brad Dolan what a day
it's a perfect way to wrap up the season
series between these two the Royals have
played Houston very tough and now we are
in the last of the ten Houston does a
nice job in the top of the inning
keeping the royals off the board
Salvador Perez will take over behind the
plate
he used to pinch runner for cam
Gallagher
that was Alberto who ultimately was
caught between second and third
that was a costly out for KC Joe pymps
in the game
all right it's Tucker Myers
[Applause]
[Music]
Tucker with regman at second here in the
bottom of the 10th there's braggy
we might get a little snippet of that
combo in the post game show
with maryfield's miked up if you're just
joining us
I mean one hit can end this game
and you're gonna touch the legs of Alex
bregman right out of the Chute in his
first game back
the Astros on the are on the other end
of the sacrifice bunt situation where
they do not fund
I don't think Kyle Tucker has bunted
much in his life
he's definitely looking to do that right
there something he could pull and get
that Runner to Third Base
just activated yesterday this is his
first start in about a week and a half
he was on the covet IL
one for four today last hit came in the
eighth
cheese from pie amps
[Music]
[Applause]
I think Astros fans should be pleased to
see not only the production from Alex
bregman today and as he's two for five
but also the fact that he's playing the
entire game
no pinch Runner here in the 10th inning
he's back
yeah you've probably got some prone
office people and a couple of trainers
in that Dugout right now that are
sweating just a little bit concerned
about how those legs are doing about
Alex bregman it's one thing to go out
there
play seven or eight innings in a minor
league game but to come out here to a
big league game a lot of the movement in
baseball is
quick fast twitch immediate reactions
but he's going to get tested right here
and there's really you know Taylor Jones
is the only guy they have left on their
bench so if you have the option to pinch
run for a guy like Alex bregman it would
bring lead Miss Diaz in from Left Field
to play Third Base
but I'm sure it's an ongoing
conversation too between trainers and
Dusty and Alex Breakman on how you feel
are you doing all right can we keep you
in the game kind of thing
he strikes me as one of those guys
that's going I am playing
that would be a very polite version of
Alex bregman looking at statcast setting
up the arm strength Taylor's got the
best arm of the bunch in the Outfield
and it's Ben and tendy and left Taylor
in Center Dyson in right and Tucker
going to right and testing Dyson bragman
will stay put at third
[Applause]
they're on the corners with nobody down
in the 10th and here comes young Jake
Myers the rookie
[Applause]
that's that pitch inside to Kyle Tucker
where you think you could go ahead and
beat him but he does another really good
job of just bringing the hands in he
does get jammed and it is a good pitch
but just taking the base hit looking for
something he can pull moves that Runner
over to Third Base
[Applause]
and you can understand Prime to go
inside there having thrown all the back
door breaking balls getting them leaning
thinking I can get a swing through here
up and in if I locate it which it was
located but and that's just the result
you know product of not trying to do too
much it's always easier to face a hitter
that's trying to do too much that's
trying to win it with the swing trying
to hit the walk-off home run versus a
guy again like we said on balance just I
mean he was folded his arms in half and
said let me just put some bat on it but
that's where I think the guys like Whit
Merrifield Nikki Lopez some of these
other guys who aren't out there trying
to drop and drive like everybody else in
the league proved to be really tough at
bats because they know what their limits
are and they just work within their own
limits and they have tough at bats but
Kyle Tucker did a great job
runner on the move
free base for Kyle Tucker
[Applause]
only bregman matters in a five five game
here in the tent
with Jake Myers young right-handed
hitter
when you have a runner at third base
less than two outs you are looking for
something that you can drive to the
Outfield
[Applause]
and these guys are the you know the
Royals pitchers have been working right
he's inside all game long so they'll
stick with that plan and see which plan
you know wins out here
so defensive indifference gets Tucker to
Second that's Castro on Deck
are you somewhat pitching around Jake
Myers
I think you're trying to get him jammed
you're your best result here is a one
hopper to the pitcher or maybe something
to one hopper to the infielder then you
consider the walk and try and go for the
double play but you got to try and get
the first guy with some pitchers that
are borderline and get him to swing out
of the Zone if you load them up right
away which some some managers do that
but now you can kind of eliminate that
freedom to say I'm going to work off the
plate try to get some bad contact and
get him out before I then load them up
two hits for Jake Myers what he slumped
for like a week and then since then he's
looked like he belongs he's hitting 321
this year and that is off the pitcher
pie amps this one's over
RBI ground out Jake Myers you did it his
first career walk off RBI Astros take it
in 10 6'5
Pretty Good At Bat by Jake Myers not
trying to do too much like Jeremy was
talking about he's got a pitch he could
handle wasn't able to elevate it but he
was able to hit it hard back up the
middle
yeah you got I mean you got the one
hopper but clearly it was hit a lot
harder than what he was hoping for you
hope High amps is okay with it coming
off the lake he looked like he came up a
little bit lame but a great at bat
first career walk-off first career walk
yeah kid's only been here what three
weeks yep
it's been a fun three weeks 300 plus
hitter
first block off RBI
it's the big leagues
makes contact on a pitch down
good pitch too he pitched him well just
didn't work out
came off the bat at 97.7 miles an hour
that would have been a very tough play
for pounds if pyams gloves it you go
home this game stays alive
there's bragman first day back
scores the winning run for Houston
all around
great day for the Astros
and an excellent series between these
two teams not only this week but last
week as well they played seven games in
about a week and a half span
I think both sets of fans have to be
happy because the Astros get their two
out of three the Royals seat continued
success
and uh you know I think they both can
build off this clearly and uh
ready for the post game show
oh yeah 30 minutes all about the Royals
and the Astros and this game a walk-off
win for Houston let's hit it
the MLB game of the week Live on YouTube
post game show is presented by YouTube
TV Scott Brown Jeremy Guthrie Jeff Blum
and Brett Dolan will join us again in
just a moment what a day for Houston
Astros fans you show up you're excited
to see Alex bregman back in the lineup
and credit to Houston they let us know
last night brag he's back some fans go
I'm in
skip the day of whatever you've got
going on and head to Minute Maid Park
many did and they witnessed a walk-off W
for the Astros and that sets up our
final poll question that we do every day
here on YouTube for the game of the week
the YouTube player of the game who's
getting the trophy Jordan Alvarez Alex
bregman or Jake Myers Mr walkoff who
joins us right now on the post game show
the rookie with his first career RBI in
extras Jake thanks for joining us
congratulations on the W your first big
league walk up RBI what was it like
awesome uh I mean I was I was happy to
be in that situation uh and just try and
help the team win it was a fun fun
situation and our team did really well
today we fought hard the whole game and
it was I'm glad we came out on top Jake
Jeff Blum here talk us through that at
bat that you just had you are a rookie
everybody knows you're a rookie you're
in a second and third situation with
nobody out out give us an idea what's
going through your head what you're
looking for right there
um honestly I was just trying to help
the team uh I was just trying to get a
pitch over the plate and and get it to
the Outfield I didn't do that but I hit
it hard and got the running so that's
that's really all that matters that that
we won Jake Jeremy Guthrie here in the
booth
first walk-off for you what was your
heart rate like as you step in were you
comfortable where's your heart racing
how'd you feel up there not last that
bad I mean not gonna lie heart was
racing a little bit but uh I think I got
a little bit more comfortable once I
stepped in the Box uh started seeing
some pitches
um yeah it was fun good piece of hitting
congratulations thank you your 18th game
how fun has it been for you to be part
of this ball Club that's so experienced
we were talking about this earlier I
mean the Astros in these moments for the
most part are unfazed because they've
played in just huge playoff games year
after year now so are you picking brains
on a daily basis asking everyone hey
what's this situation like who you
talking to absolutely uh every day I'm
learning something from somebody uh
everybody in this this Clubhouse is an
awesome player awesome team teammate uh
and just I ask a bunch of questions and
I owe a lot of My Success to them uh
they've they've helped me really
acclimate to the big leagues um quickly
and and get comfortable and and they've
been really welcoming so it's been a lot
of fun to work with them this is your
first game playing with Alex bregman
who's back for the first time in 59
games and you end up bringing him home
to end the ball game so what was it like
being with Alex today and I'm sure he
was you know a little excited to be back
on the big league club
yeah uh it was fun to watch him uh I
mean he's a great great baseball player
he made a nice play at third and uh had
a bunch a bunch of really really good at
bats um and that's just what he does
he's a great ball player and he's I'm
glad he's on our team Hey Jake You've
Won YouTube player of the game the
trophy is yours can we get it to him do
you have it
watch out it's a little sneaky heavy
that thing's not cheap and your name
will be engraved on it hey it's a nice
first few weeks in the big league so far
huh yeah thank you thank you appreciate
it guys there it is Jake congratulations
on the walk-off W and for Houston you
guys keep trucking along what's it been
like in this division race as well you
look behind you it's not only Oakland
but the Seattle Mariners are playing
inspiring baseball as well yeah um I
mean every game matters uh every pitch
matters as you as you know we can see uh
and so just just bringing it every day
and I think we do a good job of making
sure we do that and it's just keeping
focused
so you had a big week about a week ago
when you went opposite field for the
Grand Slam had two home runs in one game
I believe you're one of the quickest
rookies in Astros history to be able to
do that go back in time a little bit it
wasn't that long ago and tell us how
good it felt not only to get that first
home run but get the first Grand Slam
out of the way yeah uh awesome
experience a moment I'll remember for
the rest of my life uh you know a lot of
fun and something to build off of
so yep
hey so Darren erstead was his coach
right yeah in college what was Darren
like I hear he's has some serious
intensity yeah uh one of the most
competitive guys if not the most
competitive guy I've ever been around
but it's an incredible uh person uh
taught me how to be a better person and
a better baseball player and
um and it was just a lot of fun to to be
around him and learn
a bunch of invaluable things from him
that I use today and lastly Jake many
kids watching worldwide on YouTube and
some thinking about being in a spot like
you when they're older can you just walk
me through the process for you and your
development as a minor league ball
player it's not like you show up here in
the big leagues a few weeks ago the
player you were a few years ago what
were some of the changes and just
developments that you've gone through
that have made you who you are right now
yeah that's a great question uh
yeah it takes years and years uh of a
bunch of different things and and just
learning about yourself and how you can
get better and and keep getting better
and I think that's the key just keep
getting better uh every day find a way
to get better and and just trust
yourself and and you can definitely get
here you got to believe it before you
before you get here and then you end up
in the big leagues with your buddies
pouring water all over you and you
finish off the game today for the Astros
they win this series Jake
congratulations again let's check out
the trophy one more time and uh good
luck the rest of the season all right
there it is very nice we'll get you one
with your name on it awesome awesome
thank you guys yeah you got it Jake
Myers joining us and there it is 48 of
the pie player of the game results here
he gets the YouTube trophy he brings
home Alex bregman and Jordan Alvarez
homered in this game for Houston we'll
give you much more a little recap full
highlights if you missed anything it's
all coming up on the post game show
[Music]
thank you
brother on the go and the throw a little
bit oh in time how about that Castro
gets his first caught stealing of the
year
there goes the runner and another guy
throw down Gerard Dyson caught stealing
Astros have not LED in this game
let Miss Diaz will try and change that
here with the bases loaded and nobody
out
there's a line driving to Center
[Applause]
big their first lead of the game it's in
the 10th it is now four to three
swinging a Miss odor Rizzy now with
seven strikeouts matching the total he
had against Seattle in his first start
against the M's this year
call third strike Raleigh throws it on
the fastball that's now eight strikeouts
for odorizzi hands over the head in the
wind up the one two swing and a mess got
him on the curveball Seeger down on
strikes eight punch-outs from the colors
[Applause]
RBI single as Wilson crosses the plate
it's an even dozen for the second
straight game 12-nothing Astros
s
gorgeous day in here in Houston the game
is over it went to extras to get to that
six to five record we've got some
highlights for you right now on the game
foreign
ERS have been around now it feels like
forever broke out in 15. he can be the
ace and if he pitches like that today
and continues on he's going to get his
career high in Innings he needs to be
that guy for the Astros moving forward
Lopez makes contact diving stopped by
bregman he's back
yeah he had to take a little slice a
couple five sign with the Houston Astros
but he knew and moving to Third Base he
was only going to make this team better
but right out of the shoot Nikki Lopez
is tested testing him and as much as we
talk about Alex bregman and what he
brings to an offense you see what he can
do defensively also this is a rotation
of a bunch of young guys Mike Miner is
not one of those he's the veteran they
brought him in for a two-year deal he's
their leader
a little flare and cop grabbed by Nikki
Lopez and shallow left for the first
down and that's what Nikki Lopez does
interesting he came into the season as
their second baseman his job to lose
injuries to uh mondassi moved into
shortstop and now he's in contention for
a gold glove this year he's 10 for his
last 20 having a huge home stand and he
whips little Chase minor picks up the
strikeout and sits down the side in
order we've completed one no score eight
strikeouts in a 12-3 win last week
and he picks up a strike at his first of
the day
one two to Taylor he Rings him up two
down and made the cuts head the
development of the slider has been huge
for Lance two adding to our conversation
yeah that's a pitch that suddenly has
become maybe his best weapon
right back to a great Athlete on the
mound as well McCullers Jr impressive
second inning after the Dozier base hit
through the right side strikeout
strikeout and Lance McCullers Jr with
the glove to finish off the Royals in
the top of the second Alex bregman in
the six hole for now he's back I love
him here I was just gonna ask do you
think they like Alex bregman in Houston
just a little bit Yeah so for bregman
it's his first game since June 16th soft
tissue injuries past couple years really
you said it's been a physical and
emotional roller coaster but he feels
better than he has in the past couple
years and goes after the first pitch
golf's one in foul ground Rivera called
off by lope has a little bump and he's
got it don't mess with the shortstop and
he just got engaged too uh you mentioned
the changeup that's probably my bread
and butter
what marigailed his toast at third nice
throw from Martine Maldonado I mean this
team can really run not easy to catch
with Maryfield hasn't happened very
often this season he had the one out
double and then caught stealing for just
the third time this year he has 37
stolen back second best in baseball
Maldonado coming up Maldonado smashes
one for the Crawford boxes and Beyond
Houston's on the board first thanks to
maldi his 10th of the Season well he got
his fastball ahead of the count middle
middle and I didn't miss him
[Music]
Salvador Perez unloads on that pitch
from Lance McCullers Jr almost the same
spot as Maldonado he goes big both
catchers on either side with home runs
one a piece that's number 34 on the
season for salvi he muscles up he is on
Pace to become just the sixth catcher to
hit 40 home runs in this history game
Runners going and he is out
Maldonado did it again he catches Hunter
Dozier this nicknames the machete
cutting Runners down
Cobalt there it goes Jordan Alvarez
muscles up it's 2-1 Astros
26 on the year Flex this young man can
figure out going to left field in this
ballpark it is frightening
gregman hard contact right center field
and he's in business
base hit with two outs in the fourth
it's got to feel good for Alex getting
back on the board third a B for bregman
today eighth pitch of the a b is smacked
to left field and going back and it's
off the top of the wall
hey with an RBI double to extend the
advantage it's three to one well I think
Mike Miner knows about that Barrel as
well was trying to stay off it inside
pounding him in Pounding him in that one
just didn't get quite to where he was
hoping and credit Alex bregman for uh
you know making the adjustment he
outbound he's getting the getting the
barrel to that one
Astros in control right it's all good
seventh inning McCullers taken out of
the game after walking number nine
hitter cam Gallagher in with Maryfield
one pitch from Christian Javier and it's
5-3 KC
Grand Slam for two hit win
so in the bottom of the seventh OLED
means Diaz
helps the Houston come back with an RBI
knock look there's Jake Myers who we'll
see again in just a moment but Diaz has
been so solid this year bummer
he's been very good filling some holes
Alex bregman on the injured list for as
long as he was but they really didn't
miss a beat having a lead Miss put
together some great at bats hitting well
over 300 since coming off the injured
list and now that you have the addition
it allows more mobility and versatility
out of the lead Miss Diaz and there's
Michael Brantley with the pinch hit RBI
knock we are in the 10th now with Kyle
Tucker turns on that one turns it into a
base hit and really the Miss for the
Royals was not coming through with any
runs in the top of the 10th it just puts
a ton of pressure on your reliever to be
perfect in the bottom of the inning
that's off Pi amps that's it hard
contact to the pitcher Jake Myers
congratulations to the rookie in his
18th ever Big League game with a
walk-off RBI
and that's how it ended 6'5 in favor of
the Astros they improved to six and
seven on the season in Extra Innings the
Royals dropped to two and four on the
urine extras Kansas City with a record
now on the season of 56 and 70. the
Astros with their 75th win their 75 up
and 52 down they're in first place in
the American League West
great view all day long for Brett Dolan
including one baseball brat that was
pretty close for you you did your job
though you were ready just in case to
protect a flying Hunter Dozier although
that probably would have been a tough
task he's a big dude he is a big dude a
lot of spin on those High pop-ups as you
can tell now they've opened the roof
maybe you could tell it feels like we're
on the side of the sun right now down
here in the camera well it was quite a
game quite a really a season series
between these two teams covering seven
games a couple of Extra Inning games
some back and forth some one-run
contests we started this about four and
a half hours ago though talking about
Alex bregman how does Houston Astros
lineup was so happy to have him back had
missed 59 games with the quad issue
which also turned into some hamstring
soreness so not only did he play the
entire game had a couple of base hits
and he scored the game-winning run had a
chance to catch up to Alex just moments
ago
when you haven't played for a couple of
months is there an extra shot of
adrenaline is there a bigger skip in
your step just to be back out here I
mean definitely definitely excited
um it was uh it was fun to come back
here at home and now hopefully take that
momentum out on the road felt like you
just missed one earlier on the game to
center field yeah you just missed out
and missed the first one too but uh
we'll uh we'll get it going how good can
this offense be down the stretch now the
Year back Kyle Tucker's back it feels
like the pieces are now in place yeah
um yeah this offense can be can be nasty
so hopefully uh we keep it rolling and
uh
yeah does it matter where you bat
normally you're a top of the lineup guy
today Dusty hatch in the six old is it
does it really matter
yeah uh I don't know uh we'll see what
happens uh just trying to put good
swings on it and uh yeah finally any
plan for you on how much you want to
play as far as every day or maybe be
somewhat cautious with it as we get
towards September in the postseason no
of course I want to play every day but
uh
I mean we'll see what the plan is uh
just trust in what um what they have
planned and uh sticking to that trying
to prepare every day that I'm in the
lineup and get after with uh with great
teammates welcome back congratulations
on the win thank you very much
appreciate it that's Alex bregman got
back to you
so Alex bregman is back he's healthy
he's contributing to an Astros win as
these teams the Royals and Astros
finished off seven games in 10 days I
have a feeling they might be even tired
of seeing each other but uh guys
sometimes you wonder about a team like
Houston that has been in four straight
American League Championship Series and
I know this is going to sound a little
bit crazy but maybe there's portions of
the regular season that bore you just a
bit you're anxious to get back towards
the postseason see if you can reach the
ALCS or World Series again but it feels
like this Astros team sometimes even
when they're down to some teams they
should defeat or have a chance to win
series that competitiveness kicks in and
I think we saw that didn't we in the
last say three four Innings of this game
yeah I mean think about it blumber when
we've talked about the Astros at times
struggles against teams towards the
bottom of their division but eventually
you see the Royals enough and Dusty
Baker said it I started off the
broadcast today going
Dusty's line was we've been punched
quite a bit by this team and not
punching back they punched back last
night they punch back again today
bregman's back in the lineup it actually
also looked like when Brett asked
craigie about the plan for him over the
next five weeks
I could sense again inside Alex
bregman's brain the answer has to be I'm
gonna do what they want I want to play
every day but really he's probably going
I better be in the lineup as much as
possible because I miss this game yeah
Alex has a lot more personality than you
see in interviews he was very tempted
about things wasn't giving the full
story I agree with you and if you do ask
Alex off camera he's gonna say I'm I
better be in there tomorrow fortunately
they do have that day off to travel and
get out on the road and start to do
these things again but I agree with you
in the sense that they are sick and
tired of the Kansas City Royals I think
they're very impressed with what they
were able to go out there and do because
they play the game hard they play the
game well they continue to fight scratch
claw whatever you want to call it and it
forced them into a situation where they
had to kind of step up and play a little
bit better I know that everybody most
overused term in August I think might be
the dog days of summer but I think that
you know with the combination of what
Brett was talking about with the
postseason experience and the issues of
covid last year adjusting back to a long
season maybe the legs are a little bit
tired but maybe this is the series or
maybe these were the seven games it kind
of Sparks that energy a little bit and
forces these guys to play some good
baseball down the stretch I don't know
what you think Jeremy well I think they
are their character building wins in
series right even the losses you can
take a lot out of them if you so choose
and that comes down to a lot of the
leadership of the team and the coaches
and manager but you need these you need
something to test you you need to be
challenged in a way that causes you to
self-reflect that causes you to step up
and say we need to do something to
ensure that we're going to advance to
the playoffs number one and then beyond
the first round which is obviously their
goal is the World Series
what do you think about this Astros team
for a while the bullpen seem to be the
missing link or maybe the weak link and
obviously they addressed that at the
trade deadline adding multiple strong
arms they can put at the back end of
that Bullpen now the health getting Kyle
Tucker back Alex bregman back plumber
Jeremy anything that you need to see
this team do over the next month and a
half or do you feel like they're in a
pretty good position heading down the
stretch
well with the way the lead is stretched
out to what started the day at four and
a half game lead over the A's it gives
them a chance to not just rush them back
into the lineup where they have to play
every day like if they choose to put
Alex on the bench a few times a week
it's not going to necessarily upfront
make a big impact because they have
depth and they have a cushion now you
don't want to mess with the cushions and
sit back but I think that allows them I
think timing is great frankly because
they have the whole month of September
to get them going and then hopefully
Peak which is what you want to do anyhow
right at the right time no I that is
exactly right and Julie garriel is a guy
who just came off the injured list he's
a little bit older salty veteran now he
had some time off he's going to come
back and he's going to get his legs back
under him Alex bregman they're going to
rely on him heavily down the stretch so
it's just a matter of giving these guys
the appropriate moments off to get back
into what is going on but the back end
of the bullpen early on was really a
weak link of this Astro ball Club they
would have those early leads starting
pitchers would come out and all of a
sudden things would blow up a little bit
with the walks and timely hits and
they'd end up losing games that's why
Graven was such a key Jimmy Garcia has
been very good now you have the
opportunity with a guy like Philip
Mayton to come in and some damage type
situations and get you out of those
situations so it's going to be a lot of
fun to see how dusty really unfolds that
bullpener figures out where these guys
mix in because once they start locking
down some of these tighter games that's
where the Astros really Excel because
they can win the blowouts they can go
out there and put 15 or 12 runs on you
it's those tight ones they need to start
winning yeah the front office set up
Dusty Baker quite nicely down the
stretch he told us today four relievers
I got four new relievers baby and we saw
some of them working today and a 6-5
walk-off win in downtown Houston much
more to cover on the post game show in a
moment
[Music]
[Applause]
great baseball right there and that
one's gonna go that ball is crushed
and this is gonna do it
strike three
that was a great play
I talked about his Fielding skills that
was remarkable
[Music]
that's what they came for
[Applause]
foreign
don't wake it up
don't let him touch it no no no no
pictures allowed to touch my back
[Applause]
I went through a little flare in there
so that way throw a little flare in
there oh boy
uh-huh sure I believe you
oh boy oh sick nobody no hits the Royals
nobody nobody
[Applause]
how many retirements
Ovation is he gonna get he's like
freaking Big Poppy and Rivera
guess what where we go
everywhere we go everybody please stand
for the fourth time today
I'll be shallow Center
at night
with him I'm gonna be like shallow
Center I'm gonna play him pretty deep
because he's he's got a fridge strapped
to him
foreign
[Applause]
get the best jump there but I've gotten
worse jokes
I've gotten better jumps but I've gotten
worse jumps
I know he's going to go fast all the way
look at wasting that pitch to go to you
that's what he got I should have gone
first one but I thought he might inside
move yeah true
some kind of special huh
shall we
I never caught so I don't know like
what it feels like
August 26th with your legs but I imagine
they're pretty heavy
it's like Barry Bonds now he just walks
in his homers
that's all he does
This Bat
is round
and the and the pelota is round
sometimes you miss by too much
that's been
but
but you this year
you haven't missed very much
I love the way he thinks
hit me on the slant
come on baby
let's go baby
[Applause]
let's go
Big Buddy
[Applause]
call it let's go
let's go I mean so much gold there and
he also snapped the second longest
career home run drought for him 47 games
so Jeremy you nailed it beginning of the
game you're like sometimes you don't
even realize you have the mic on I just
texted him thank you for all that today
and he said once or twice I forgot yeah
just felt like part of himself don't
worry we cover it up if there's anything
we need to do because he gave us plenty
of excellent one-liners with Maryfield
with a grand slam today for the Royals
in a losing effort but they played tough
against the Houston Astros all season
long and let's swing it back for a
moment last play there as with Maryfield
and the Royals fall to the Astros so
let's run through it here plumber this
is how the game ended Jake Myers off
high amps and I mean that's a hot shot
right there for a pitcher to handle
winning run on third base the only play
is the home plate to try and cut down
that winning run getting that out in
first base does absolutely nothing I
think this the stunning action of that
ball hitting him threw him into a panic
and all of a sudden everything was out
the window and he was just trying to
pick it up finding out somewhere but
that winning run is where it's at I
think you hit her right on the head I
was trying to imagine when the play
happened you know 444 someone's got to
be yelling that although but I think it
got him good I think it really hit him
pretty good at that point like he was
frazzled obviously it would have been a
nearly impossible play anyhow some kind
of backhand but
um lost a little bit of his senses as to
where the play was and and where he
needed to go with that yeah and I mean
what happens in that situation can he
grab it and turn around and make the
play it would have been a freakishly
miraculous backhanded flip where maybe
salvey's got the leg blocking the blade
and you can you can get to Alex bregman
but uh yeah as hard as that ball was
hitting as far away as it ricocheted
really no chance yeah unless his arm
moves in Direction that's not really
where it's supposed to move kind of like
this or something like that hey credit
to Jake Myers he's the YouTube player of
the game he gets the trophy the whole
deal will miss the rock off the rookie
in his 18th game in The Bigs and now we
take you around the Mages we're going
streaking the Yankees have won 11 in a
row the Orioles have dropped Is that
real is that a misprint 19 straight and
then yachty congratulations on re-upping
with the Cardinals and he said it's
going to be his final season next year
also Brandon Bell honors his late
grandmother with a four hit two home run
performance he was emotional after the
game I mean just week after week
headlines Galore in this league and what
stands out to you out of those three
well up until that trade deadline
everybody said they were dead in the
water now all of a sudden they make a
trade Joey Gallo you get a Rizzo playing
first base some of those young pitchers
are stepping up Bullpen starting to
figure itself out a little bit and
they're starting to close out these
games but with that lineup as powerful
it is as it is is a real threat in the
East now tomorrow the a start a series
at home against the Yankees the Astros
are like great here come the Yankees
might be the one time they cheer for the
Yankees exactly and for you I know I put
you on the spot but this is the Newbie
someone I think for it was like what you
said is that a misprint and having
played with Baltimore to see the 19-game
losing streak and imagine the Sports
Illustrated with the Owen 21 if I'm not
mistaken they've had some rough losing
streaks over there franchise history
that's a rough go so I think that one
stands out to me I mean a lot of things
have to go wrong for that to happen
clearly they had a road losing streak of
over 20 games this season so there's
some weird awful streaks for the
Baltimore Orioles this year the other
headline that was not listed there was
our guy Jeremy Guthrie booking a flight
a little too early on a Wednesday
afternoon just just by a tank rookie are
you gonna make it I'm no pressure do you
see me sweating no he's a cool pressure
we got the bases loaded 3-0 count the
best hitter in the world up and I'm
throwing balls down the middle and I
maybe we can still get that hey you
nailed it we can get you there please
escort please the MLB game of the week
Live on YouTube swings back Thursday
September 2nd a pair of first place ball
clubs the Brewers Giants be there
coverage begins with our pregame show at
three o'clock Eastern for the greats
plumber Guthrie Dolan on our entire
Superstar crew I'm Scott Braun logging
out for now it's the Astros winning in
10 a walk-off W 6-5 thanks to the rookie
Jake Myers thanks so much for hanging
out with us today worldwide on YouTube
foreign
foreign